Klux FM, Spreeblick, Poppolitik, Positionen.
Johnny Häusler im Gespräch mit dem Medienkünstler Tim Prittler.
Du machst, hast auch immer viel gepodcastet über Apple, Apple Produkte, Apple Technik, Software, Hardware und so weiter.
Das ist Mobamex.
Hat sich dein Verhältnis zu Apple, also nicht dein jetzt zum Unternehmen oder so, sondern einfach, wie du die Produkte nutzt? Hat sich das in den letzten Jahren verändert?
Ist durch. Fabi Tretrick aus Coupa T.
Warum und wieso?
Wann hat Apple das letzte Mal ein neues Produkt vorgestellt?
Schon seit wie lange?
18 Jahre sind es, glaube ich.
Totaler Irrsinn eigentlich.
Das ist einfach nicht gut. Wir sind ja kein Apple Podcast.
Weshalb und so?
Das ist schlecht. Ich meine, was soll denn jetzt aus diesem Laden werden?
Ich finde, es ist Zeit für Hubschraube-Einsatz.
So weit geht es jetzt nicht.
Ähm, frag mich also, woher kommt das?
Es ist wirklich, es ist wirklich schlimm. Es ist sehr kaputt. Funktional kaputt.
Vielen Dank, dass du hergekommen bist.
Ja, bitte.
Und ich sag mal, bis nächstes Mal.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zag Return.
Ja, so jetzt aber. Leichte, kleineste, minimalste technische Schwankung.
Und salzige Karamellkrümel, Gaumen und süße Kekse auch noch.
Ja, es gibt Gummibärchen.
Saftbeeren.
Ja, die habe ich mit aus dem Kühlschrank geholt, weil ich dachte, es ist heiß.
Heute haben wir übrigens einen NSFW-Moment. Fällt mir gerade ein.
Wieso?
Weil wir da unausgepackte Pakete haben, die wir im Post bekommen. Und zwar ganz viele.
Ich will das in der Mitte.
Na, na, na, na, na, na. Das ist für alle da.
Ja, aber ich will das öffnen.
Hier, Hucke, nimm du mal das Kleine.
Wollt ihr damit anfangen?
Ja, klar, also ich pack das Kleine aus.
Wer möchte denn hier eine kleine Auspachshilfe haben? Ich brauche keine. Ihr packt mal aus, dann kann ich ja mittlerweile zwischendurch.
Geschenke, Weihnachten.
Also mich ereilt hier ein Brief von Oliver Kraus.
Moment, ihr packt jetzt erstmal aus. Und ich sag erstmal Hallo an alle Hörer, denn hier ist die 110. Ausgabe von Mobile Max und wir sind auch fast alle da. Huckel ist da, Dennis ist da, Roddy ist da, nur Clemens ist nicht da. Der hat kurzfristig irgendwie sich abgemeldet und wird also nicht teilnehmen und leider auch meinen gewünschten Lieblingsthemen-Punkt für die heutige Sendung.
Was ist denn das?
Nein, Clemens wollte ja, hat ja also hätte nun müssen erzählen müssen.
Zwei in Fürstich-Aufkleber.
Was hätte er erzählen müssen? Moment, jetzt erst zurückkriegen.
Na Clemens hat auch gerade der republika Internet besorgt.
Hat der republika mal richtig besorgt.
Ja, aber richtig. Es gab richtig Netz, so wie auf dem Kongress und das war schon sehr überraschend. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Geschichte wert, aber die werden wir leider heute nicht erzählen können. Schade.
Na gut.
Aber dafür gibt es ja Geschenke. So, wer will anfangen?
Ich fange mit dem kleinsten an.
Ja, für mich.
Oliver Kraus hat Tim und dem Mobile-Mix-Team eine USB-Verlängerung geschickt. Hurra. Da müssen wir uns jetzt drum streiten.
Nur eine. In der Viertel das Ding.
Wieso willst du auch eine haben?
Na die sind ja so toll, da rutscht auch nie wieder ein Stecker raus.
Jeder kriegt eine Leitung.
Guck, ich hab hier schon ganz viele installiert.
Mindestens drei oder vier. Das war's schon bei dir.
Das, was heißt schon.
Ja, super.
Eine Menge Wert.
Das erleichtert die Studiarbeit ungemein.
So ich hab hier als Dankeschön für viele Stunden Danke, Moment, erstmal hier danke Oliver.
Also Tim muss ich bedanken, weil für den ist das vor allen Dingen natürlich Oliver Kraus.
Okay, dann bedanke ich mich vor allem.
Ja, also hier steht als Dankeschön für viele Stunden Bummsack, Return, an buy ein bunter Mixed T-Shirts. Sollte bei euch die Namensendung durch sein, drücke ich gerne dafür die offiziellen Shirts. Viele Grüße Florian.
Aha, ist das ein T-Shirt-Drucker.
Sieht so aus und...
Was für ein Druck ist das?
Wir hätten hier das. Ja, hier lest ihr mal vor.
Ein Funktional kaputt T-Shirt.
Dann hier ein...
Mobile Max T-Shirt.
Und dann ein...
Bumzack-Return-T-Shirt.
Weißes Mobile Max T-Shirt.
Und dann noch ein...
Bumzack-Return-T-Shirt.
Und noch eins.
Dunkles. Ein dunkles, funktionales, kaputtes T-Shirt. Nee, hoffentlich ist das T-Shirt nicht funktional kaputt. Aber jetzt müssen wir natürlich schauen. Tim braucht ja eine XS.
Ich hab ein bisschen zugenommen. Ich würde dann doch auch auf ein S gehen.
Aber es gibt auch ein XL.
Also wir können auch, ich weiß ja nicht, wie scharf ihr so auf T-Shirt tragen seid, aber wir können das auch wunderbar als Verlosungsmaterial verwenden.
Ach so, und dann waren da noch dabei natürlich drei Aufkleber mit 42. Oder sind das Aufbügel-Dinger? Ich weiß gar nicht, die sehen so nach Stoff aus.
Also die Mobile-Max-T-Shirts, die kann man schon mal auch, man kann die auch mal verlosen. Kann man schon machen. Also eins dieser L-T-Shirts würde ich ja schon auch anziehen, glaube ich. Vielleicht sogar. Ja leider ist das Funktional kaputt.
So jetzt hier, Roddy, jetzt schnappt ihr ja nicht die schönsten Sachen da. Jetzt erzähl was da drin ist. Ich hab die richtige Kiste, ich seh schon.
Ich hab mir die richtige Kiste gekrallt. Da steht was?
Warte mal, von wem ist der hier? Florian, gibt's da einen Text zu? Popp.
Also es könnte auch ein Bunnypupp sein.
Ich dachte also mit Doppel O.
Nee, ja, bunnypop.de ist wohl der Ort des Geschehens.
Also, Grüße aus München sendet Daniel. Mit Türkirr, also mit Y, T, Y, R, K, I, R, A, D, N und Twitter. Er schreibt, was? Bier für Mobile Max. Was genau? Ein Bier aus meiner alten Heimat, das ich ganz lecker finde. Und nicht zuletzt wegen dem sehr fränkischen Namen sollte es man mal getrunken haben. Gebraut wurde es von Greif in 91301 Forchheim. Und die Webseite bezeichnet es etwas lapidar als dunkles Landbier. Ich hoffe, es mundet. Das ist es. Greifbräu Schlöberlar oder so. Wahrscheinlich habe ich es nicht richtig ausgesprochen. Schlöberlar.
Schlöberli Schlöberlar.
Schlöberlar. Brauerei Josef Greif Forchheim. Nee, mit einem F.
Dann dürfen wir uns jeder eine Flasche mitnehmen.
Ich habe bisher drei Flaschen ausgepackt. Das sind aber, ich glaube, fünf. Jeder kriegt eine Flasche.
Forchheim ist bei?
Bei Franken.
Bei Bamberg.
Das ist ein F zwischen Erlangen und Bamberg.
Erlangen und Bamberg. Das ist dann auch im Süden. Im Kern, im Zielgebiet.
Das ist halt schon die fünfte, oder? Was ist das? 1, 2, 3, 4. Du hast jetzt die fünfte raus.
Die fünfte, da bin ich gerade dabei. Das ist auch ein ganz großer Pool an diesem Schnipsel.
Das ist aber kein Bockbier. Ich sag dir nur, nachdem die Vorräte fast erschöpft gewesen wären.
Dennis will es nicht wahrhaben, dass es nur 5 Flaschen sind.
Ich such die Rollen mit dem Geld.
Guck doch mal, vielleicht findest du noch ein paar Bitcoins.
Da müssen noch Kekse dabei sein.
Ich glaube, deine Aufkleber hier sind negativ aufkleber. Die klebt man dann von hinten auf Glas.
Lieber, wie war das? Daniel, vielen Dank dafür.
Applaus für alle Einzelner.
Die klebt man noch von vorne.
Diese Flasche ist noch für Clemens, den ich nicht so gerne als Karsten bezeichne. Was er mir bis jetzt noch nicht übergenommen hat.
Was meinst du, warum er heute nicht gekommen ist?
Oh, das kann es natürlich sein. Ach ja, und die Telekom, die Telekom sag ich schon, die Post, alles gelb. DHL hat ja noch so ein Wisch reingelegt, weil es irgendwie das Paket so ein bisschen angeschraddelt haben.
Ja und, haben sie sich irgendwie entschuldigt? Geschenke dabei noch?
Also da ist so ein Aufkleber drauf. Sehr geehrte Kundinnen, sehr geehrter Kunde, leider wurde an ihrer Sendung eine Beschädigung festgestellt. Unser Kundenservice wird zur weiteren Bearbeitung Kontakt mit dem Absender dieser Sendung aufnehmen.
Ist gar nicht angekommen.
Wenn die schwarzen Helikopter vor der Tür, äh, die gelben Helikopter vor der Tür, gestern stand ich auf der Terrasse bei Buger oben auf dem Dach und da flogen sieben schwarze Helikopter aus dem Regierungsviertel Richtung Osten. Richtig.
Hab ich auch gesehen, ich hab immer nur sechs gesehen, hab ich den ersten nicht mehr gesehen.
Und da dachten wir uns, also wenn die Regierung jetzt abhaut, entweder die Zombie-Attacke ist nah oder... Oder die nächste Mobile-Max-Sendung steht an. Und vielleicht sollten wir dann auch nach Osten. Also, sieht so aus, als wäre Osten die beste Richtung da zur Flucht. Naja, wenn die Regierung dahin fliegt. Gerade.
Kann ich auch ein paar Gummibärchen haben?
Nein.
Das sind Saftbären. Saftgoldbären sind das, um genau zu sein.
Goldschalke.
Ja, hier kriegste auch was ab.
Da wird's ins Mikro schmatzen.
Könntest du ja mal ausschalten, solange.
Welcher bin ich, ein Drei?
Genau. Ah ja, genau, wir müssen ja hier noch unsere Sprach... Sprachunterbrecher-Devices an Start bringen.
Es geht hier ganz gemächlich los heute.
Ja, es geht gemächlich los. Weil wir auch festgestellt haben, und das hat ja in gewisser Hinsicht hier auch unser Intro gerade nochmal festgestellt, dass es ja auch jetzt seit einem halben Jahr einfach sich nicht lohnt, überhaupt irgendwie über Apple zu berichten. Da das einzige News-Topic, was irgendwie halbwegs relevant jetzt noch nachzuliefern ist im Bereich Apple, ist, naja, dass wir jetzt ein Dauerthema weniger haben. Also der komische Store hat jetzt tatsächlich geöffnet, zwei Tage nachdem wir uns hier das letzte Mal trafen. Du, Roddy, warst da?
Ich war da, ja.
Ich war auch da.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Eröffnung, also um?
Ich bin etwas zu spät gekommen, das heißt, ich hab so diesen eigentlichen Ignition-Moment so ein bisschen verpasst.
Also es gab noch so einen Countdown.
Ja.
So von Richtung der Tür hat man es so leicht gehört.
Ja, auf Deutsch oder auf Englisch?
Auf Deutsch. Und, ähm, ja, das hat aber von der Tür weg keine großen Kreise gezogen. Vielleicht drei Meter oder so.
Ich hatte sowieso den Eindruck, dass das alles sehr content war. Also das fand irgendwie so ein so ein kleinen Minibubble da so davor statt. Da waren irgendwie unglaublich viele Leute drumherum, die eigentlich nur filmen wollten, wie sie sich alle zum Affen machen. Und dann in der zweiten Reihe und vor allem auf dieser Verkehrsinsel, da sind so unheimlich viele Leute, die eigentlich schon, so wie wir uns das auch gewünscht haben, im Wesentlichen unbeteiligt schauten, oder?
Du meinst auf der Mittelstreifen? Ja.
Also der Mittelstreifen war schon die Insel der Lichtbeteiligung.
Aber das fand ich so typisch Berlin. Die Leute stehen dann auf dem Mittelstreifen. Das fand ich irgendwie super.
Naja, war ja auch kaum woanders Platz da.
Sie haben immerhin eine Spur abgesperrt.
Ach du meinst, sie haben sich dann sozusagen... Schön, dass sie das abgesperrt hat auf dem Mittelstreifen, das ist schöner.
Nett fand ich ja die Busse, die da vorbeifuhren und die Leute, die aus dem Bus herausgeguckt haben und sich nicht so recht einen Reim darauf machen konnten, was denn da wieder passiert. Und besonders nett fand ich den einen Polizisten, der aus seiner Wanne rausgegafft hat und es nicht fassen konnte.
Was denn nicht? Das ist jetzt endlich der Epistode.
Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall guckte er, als hätte er das erste Mal irgendwie das Licht der Welt gesehen. Was wahrscheinlich auch so ist.
Ja, also es war im Wesentlichen schon doch ein ganz schöner Non-Event, so in meiner Wahrnehmung. Aber es lag vielleicht auch daran, dass wir da nicht reingegangen sind.
Warte, aber ihr wolltet doch, dass da nicht so doll geschrien wird und dass die Berliner da ein bisschen anders sind. So gesehen war es doch dann ganz gut oder nicht?
Also innerhalb des Stores wurde schon geschrien. Das hat man schon gehört.
Aber es waren eigentlich nur die Mitarbeiter jetzt. Aber es gab schon so ein paar Leute, die sich auch so haben beklatschen lassen.
Zugezogene.
Das war es mal aus. Aller neuer Berliner.
Beziehungsweise solche, die jetzt demnächst abgeschoben werden. Oder Touristen. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Demnächst Ex-Berliner.
Wir haben sie mal notiert.
Wieso demnächst?
Er wird da groß reinmachen als Frühling.
Wir gehen jetzt durch die Liste und dann...
Jeder, der sich abklatschen hat, lassen.
Sorry.
Der muss nach Gelsenkirchen.
Nee, auch Fissur Brandenburg reicht ja. Da ist ja eine Menge Platz. Da gibt es auch keine Wohnungsnot und so.
Jubelschwaben wird ja...
Na ja. Es war natürlich realistisch nicht wirklich zu erwarten, dass jetzt die Apple-Mitarbeiter da irgendwie auf einmal die Warnweigeanweisung annehmen.
Waren wir Berliner jetzt überheblich genug, können wir das jetzt wieder lassen?
Also wir waren ja glaube ich auch beide an dem Tag nicht drin, ne? Warst du seitdem dann nochmal überhaupt da? Nein, ich war nicht mehr drin.
Nein, nein.
Dennis, du warst da gestern.
Und vorgestern.
Und vorgestern auch. Du bist jetzt jeden Tag da, weil da gibt es so geiles Produkte und so.
Ich habe vorgestern einen Termin gemacht und der Termin war gestern. So war es.
Also du bist erst hingegangen, um einen Termin zu machen.
Ich dachte, ich komme gleich raus. Das ist so ein Scheiß. Ich dachte, ich gehe da hin und...
Ja, wir sind da überrannt.
Naja, wenn die nur 10 Minuten brauchen, hätten die mich da auch noch reingeschummelt.
In wie vielen Jahren mussten wir jetzt warten? Zwei.
Naja, nachdem wie man es sieht. Eigentlich 20.
Zwei Jahre nach Baubeginn.
Ja, aber ich meine im Prinzip hätte so ein Laden schon länger bedurft.
Ja, und diese ganzen Leute, die jetzt ihre Supportfälle da erstmal abwickeln mussten.
Ich hab jetzt extra mir eine Woche Zeit gelassen.
Die Leute, die sich extra noch einen Apple Care nachgekauft haben, weil der Store nicht fertig wurde, also dachten, ich will ihn nicht wegschicken, ich will es vor Ort machen. Die müssen jetzt erstmal abgefrühstückt werden.
Ja, also ich war dann, als ich dann reinging, dann doch etwas überrascht, weil ich hatte so ein bisschen damit gerechnet, dass die Verkaufsgeschichte sich auch noch auf eine zweite Etage irgendwie erstreckt. Dem ist aber nicht so.
Oben ist nur Kino.
Oben ist nur Kino bzw. wie das da so schön heißt, Event.
Keynote. Oben ist nur Keynote.
Oben ist nur Keynote, genau. Und unten ist ein relativ großer Raum, der so von der Fläche her, schwer zu sagen, also ich schätze mal in Hamburg von der Gesamtfläche her dürfte es in etwa das Gleiche sein. Vielleicht sind es auch ein paar Quadratmeter mehr, weiß ich nicht, es sind halt zwei Etagen. Hier eben nur eine und die haben auch diesen Genius Bar anders gemacht als sonst bisher. Also es ist halt nicht so ein Tresen an der Wand, sondern mitten im Raum, freistehender, großer langer Tisch mit so Einlassungen in der Mitte, wo dann auch so Ethernet...
Die Tische sind ja mehrere Tische da hinten.
Ja, es wirkt wie ein langer Tisch, weil die aneinander gestellt sind. Das meine ich, genau. Und die haben dann da Ethernet drin und halt diese ganzen üblichen Applikationen. Und ganz interessant, ich hatte dann so ein altes, totes R dahingeschleppt. Also es war nicht tot, es war nur ein bisschen kaputt, es war mechanisch kaputt. Ich hab mich dahingeschleppt. Ja, dann kommen sie irgendwie gleich da mit so einem USB-Ethernet-Adapter, stecken ein Kabel rein, hängen das Ding an Ethernet ran und machen Netboot. Also sie booten das Teil sozusagen übers Netz gleich so in ihren Service-Modus. Hatte ich jetzt so auch noch nicht gesehen. Das ist bestimmt nichts Neues oder so, aber man sieht ja vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer diesen ganzen Vorgang. Und auch noch mal mit meinem R, der auch noch so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten hatte, das wurde dann halt einfach mal alles so durchgecheckt und SMC-Reset und Pipapo.
Hat's geholfen?
Ja, ja. Also ich hab so ein obskures Grafikproblem hier mit meinem Rechner. Und es sieht aber für mich eher nach Software aus. Ich muss hier wohl mal das OS neu installieren, glaube ich. Mal wieder. Bisschen unklar. Naja, der andere, da war halt einfach da dieses Scharnier gebrochen. Beim ersten R war das alles noch so ein bisschen wonky. Flimsy. Naja, das war das erste Mal, dass sie diesen konkreten Klappmechanismus so, glaube ich, überhaupt gebaut haben. Und das war es halt dann noch nicht so ganz. Naja, im Sonsten kann man sagen, wie immer sind alle sehr nett geschult und benehmen sich ordentlich, sabber nicht, reden kein dummes Zeug. Das finde ich ja immer noch sehr angenehm, generell. Oder? Also ich meine, die reden jetzt keinen Stuss.
Das ging so schnell, da hatte ich gar keine Zeit, Stuss zu reden.
Ja, aber es ist einfach straight irgendwie. Die kommen einem nicht blöd, sondern die sind einfach extrem professionell trainiert auf diesen Ablauf. So, die wissen genau, was zu fragen ist, was zu checken ist, la la la. Haben die ganzen Prozesse drin und haben auch irgendwie für jeden Vorfall einen passenden Prozess zur Hand.
Ja, weiß nicht, es ging echt zu schnell, um da so große Sachen zu beobachten.
Na du hast iPhone getauscht oder was?
Power-Button im Arsch oben. Also nicht mal richtig, sondern der ging nur so ein bisschen schwerer, manchmal ging er nicht und manchmal reagierte er doppelt. Ist halt ein bisschen nervig.
Es scheint eine echte Seubostelle beim iPhone 5 zu sein. Also ich hatte das auch und ich kenne auch mehrere andere, wo es auch so war.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, war ja beim iPhone 5 auch schon der Home-Button verstärkt worden, im Gegensatz zum 4er. Aber der Power-Button anscheinend noch nicht.
Die Verstärkung haben sie wahrscheinlich nur umgeschraubt. Jetzt ist der Einschaltbutton nicht mehr stark genug.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls war er durch. Er hat es nicht mal gecheckt. Ich musste mich nicht mal rechtfertigen oder erklären, warum es mir wichtig ist oder sonst wie. Sondern er hat gesagt, alles klar. Können wir nicht sofort machen, das können wir nicht reparieren. Deswegen, zack, wird es getauscht. Kurz gecheckt, ob ich Backup mache. Und dann kam schon der Kollege, hatte schon das Neue in der Hand.
Und das eingepackt oder?
Es war eingepackt in einer ganz schmalen Pappschachtel. Und hat das getauscht, hat mein Backup gecheckt. Und hat dann mein altes in die Pappschachtel wieder reingemacht. Und dann noch so einen Aufkleber draufgeklebt, also auf die Pappschachtel, dass ich das halt bin und dass da jetzt mein altes drin liegt, damit zu wissen, falls da irgendwas mehr kaputt ist, die dann nochmal auf einen zukommen können und so. Und meins war ja von außen schon noch ganz schön angekratzt. Also dieses Aluhalt, weil es hält ja nichts aus, aber da hat er auch überhaupt gar nicht geguckt und nichts. Also es scheint ihn nicht zu interessieren.
Und du hattest jetzt Apple Care oder so Garantie noch?
Nein, das ist halt ein iPhone 5. Da hast du ja ein Jahr lang Garantie und die ist ja eindeutig noch nicht rum. Was ja gefragt ist, wie groß es ist, ob es ein 32 Gigabyte ist, meinte ich ja. Also habe ich ein 32 Gigabyte bekommen. Ich weiß nicht, was passiert wäre, wenn man dann 16er hat und dann sagt, dass man 32er hat. Nee, früher stand hinten drauf, jetzt nicht mehr.
Die Seriennummer dürfte das eindeutig codieren.
Ja, schon, aber vielleicht hätte er auch selber irgendwo bei sich gucken können, aber er hat mich einfach nur gefragt.
Damit er sich das Richtige holt.
Holen lässt, ja. Aber er hat einen Kollegen gebracht. Hat er nicht selber gemacht, der ging nicht weg von mir.
Beim Tausch haben sie ja eh noch mal die alte Seriennummer.
Kann sein, kann sein. Es ging aber alles ratzfatz. Auch gleich vor Ort angemeldet, also gleich SIM-Karte reingesteckt, kurz angemeldet, zack, ging. Und dann meinte er, Backup machst du ja sicher zu Hause. Und so, weil er schon gemerkt hat, dass ich hier iCloud überhaupt gar nicht benutze. Hat er gleich gesehen, hab ich gesagt, ja, hier iPhone-Developer. Meinte er, alles klar, da muss er sich ja keine Sorgen machen. Meinte ich, nee, musste nicht. Und dann ging alles noch ein Stück schneller und dann bin ich schon raus. Und die haben ein cooles, die haben so ein, weil ich hab letztens schon geguckt, für iPhones gibt's ja so Battery Extender. Haben wir, glaub ich, ja auch schon mal gesprochen, aber wir haben nur über Geräte gesprochen, die halt so externe Batterien sind, die man mit Kabel ans iPhone bindet. Und es gibt aber natürlich auch so wie Bumper Cases, bloß dass die Cases dann halt noch so ein bisschen Battery Power mit hinten drin haben. Und er hat da auch so einen riesen Kasten an seinem iPhone. Und meine ich, was ist das hier? Ein Third-Party-Battery Extender, oder was hast du da? Meint er, nee, zeigt zur Rückseite, da ist halt ein Scanner mit drin und ein Kartenleser und meint, das ist nur Apple Only und nix für dich meint er.
Was sagst du für dich, Junge?
Gehst du wieder nach Hause?
Sah eigentlich ganz cool aus.
Kriegst du nicht vom Laster gefallen, Alter.
Kannst du gucken, kannst du auch wenig anfassen.
So ungefähr, ja. Ich war auch ein bisschen zu fett, aber wollte ich mal wissen, was der da so hat.
Der ist die ganze Saft Goldbeeren bei euch auf der Seite. Bitte.
Du hast schon das USB-Kabel bekommen.
Ja, du wolltest es ja nicht haben. Ich hätt's dir gegeben.
Bei mir ist alles so nah dran, da brauch ich keine Verlängerung.
Ich wünschte, ich hätte Verwendung für so ein Kabel, aber die wichtigste Hardware, die ist ja über Bluetooth. Mich nervt das ja eher, dass man da ständig Batterien wechseln muss.
Was ist denn die wichtigste Hardware?
Ich hätte gern so ein Magic Trackpad mit USB-Kabel. Dass man es einfach reinsteckt und es funktioniert.
Fotografiert?
Das muss man ja nicht fotografieren. Nein, es funktioniert. Du steckst es rein und es tut, ohne dass ich hier paeren muss und das Ding irgendwie anschalten oder sonst was machen und weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab ja so einen ganz großen Scherz. Wir haben eine große Firma mit ganz vielen Macs und so und alle haben diese Bluetooth-Tastaturen und Mäuse. Und wenn ich mal jemanden richtig, also wenn ich mal so richtig Schabernack anstellen würde, würde ich in der ganzen Firma die ganzen Mäuse und die ganzen Tastaturen so random durchshuffeln. Und am nächsten Tag da so in diesem Chaos sitzen und jeder, ah, meine Maus bewegt sie, wer bewegt meine Maus, wer versucht sich mit meinem Telefon zu paaren? Und dann sieht man schon, wenn es so bei Zweien passiert. Das ist minutenlange Spaß, aber wenn das so 300 Leute machen, oh, sollte jetzt ein VUGA-Mitarbeiter dazuhören, das ist nur eine kleine Spaßfantasie. Das werde ich natürlich nicht tun. Und sollte es passieren, war ich es nicht. Aber davon mal abgesehen, so, Store ist jetzt also abgefrühstückt.
Nee, nee.
Haben sich denn die zwei...
Da gibt es noch was zu erzählen, weil ich dachte mir natürlich so, hm, okay, das kann ja jetzt nicht alles gewesen sein, großes Gebäude und so. Weil dieser Raum ja nur die untersten zwei Stockwerke der linken Hälfte des gesamten Gebäudes einnimmt. Dann gibt es halt rechts nochmal einen anderen Eingang, wo man aber so erstmal nicht rein kann.
Da ist noch zu, da ist noch Zeug davor, oder?
Nö, nö.
Du kannst, wenn du da hinten rechts in diesen Gadget-Zubehörraum reingehst, dann kannst du dann aber da auch noch Richtung Klo weiter marschieren, da sind nochmal so extra Türen und dann kommst du ins Treppenhaus und da kannst du auch, normalerweise musst du fragen, ob da nicht gerade irgendein Event ist, Treppe hoch, dann sind da diese schicken, alten Haus Wien Kino Treppen, so mit schönen Metallgeländer und ist richtig schick. Und dann kannst du da in den zweiten Glock hoch. Nix Glas. Nix Glas. Nix Glas. Genau, die kleine Glastreppe, du sagst es. Ich versuche hier gerade mal die Fotos nachzuschlagen. Dauert noch eine Sekunde. Dann haben sie da oben den einen alten Kinosaal. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Kinosaale es ursprünglich mal gab, aber oben ist halt so ein größerer Raum, der ist jetzt auch nicht riesig. Da haben sie eine Bühne und zwei recht fette PA-Boxen gehangen. Die sehen teuer aus. Das scheint gut zu klingen. Und da können halt so kleine Konzerte laufen. Das haben sie auch da teilweise. Die haben da regelmäßig Veranstaltungen. Da kann man irgendwie kieken und reinlatschen und so. Und dann halt Stühle. Und oben ist die Technik aus so einer Empore, wo vorher wahrscheinlich der Projektor war.
Ist denn in dem Saal auch so Kinobestuhlung, wie man es so kennt, zum Hochklappen?
Nee, das sind so normale Hinstellstühle. Damit man es da wahrscheinlich auch frei machen kann zum Tanzen oder Yogakurs oder keine Ahnung, was so die Apple-Mitarbeiter da alle so machen.
Die üben da Klatschen.
Ja oder... Wahrscheinlich muss man da so verschiedene Stufen so.
Wie diese Grußabnahme, von der ich mal bei der Bundeswehr berichtet hatte. Das ist dann genauso. Stehen die sich so gegenüber und dann wird sich da gegenseitig begrüßt und abgeklatscht und nee, nochmal die Hände ein bisschen höher, Schultern nicht hängen lassen hier, Brust raus, Rücken gerade.
Die Apple-Klatsch-Abnahme.
Und hat sich denn jetzt das alles gelohnt? Eigentlich so diese zwei Jahre da an diesem Haus rumschrauben, ist es denn jetzt so ein erhabenes Gefühl, da hineinzuschreiten und fühlt man sich wie in einem Palast des Konsumes. Oder denkt man sich, oh das hätten sie auch irgendwo hier in der Friedrichstraße, in so einem Neubau reingehen können?
Ich weiß nicht. Also ich meine, es ist natürlich gut, dass es jetzt so einen Laden gibt, wenn man so Apple-Kunde ist, dann ist das das Beste, was einem passieren kann, so servicemäßig.
Ja, das schon, aber diese IKEA-Betischung, die finde ich nicht so schick.
Ich meine, es hat halt wenig Überraschungen jetzt für uns. Das ist halt wieder mal Tische mit Apple-Produkten drauf und du kannst dir halt iPads angucken und wenn du den ganzen Rumpelrotz schon kennst, dann ist das irgendwie nix. Ich meine, das ist eh nix für Power-User. Für Power-User ist da nix zu holen. Ich hab da auch kein Mac Pro gesehen.
Gibt's ja auch nicht mehr.
Genau, richtig.
Da haben ja manche Leute viel zu viel dran geleckt.
Aber in drei Wochen.
Also wir haben ja hier spezielle Zuhörer, ne? Wenn demnächst die neuen Power-Makes kommen und da gibt's eine spezielle Vorführung im Apple Store, dann hätten wir doch gerne eine spezielle Einladung dafür. Wink, wink, natsch, natsch.
Das stimmt. Mal kicken. Mir kappst du den Eindruck, das Programm wird auch gehört nach dem Mitarbeiterkreis. Das ist schon...
Ja, drängt sich dir der Eindruck auf.
Ja, hat sich mir aufgedrängt und das finde ich auch gut so. Und ihr wisst ja, wie wir das meinen. Und der Raum jetzt da oben, es gibt da auch noch irgendwie so einen anderen Raum, so ein Business-Raum, einen sogenannten Briefing-Room. Wobei da irgendwie so die...
Wow, das sieht ja aus wie geleckt da.
Ja, ich habe hier gerade mal so ein paar Fotos hier. Das sieht irgendwie auch so ein bisschen aus, da die Flure wie bei... 2001.
Du bist auf den Boden schon.
Fühlt mich eher, weil das ja auch so leer war, als ich da rumging, so ein bisschen mehr an Shining.
Oder so, ja.
Also wir hätten da jetzt auf einmal so...
Aber da fehlt der Teppich, wo das Dreirad erst so...
Hier habt ihr noch mal die Theater-Optik.
Oh ja, das Boxengehänge sieht ganz gut aus, ja.
Ich kenne mich da nicht aus bei diesen PS, aber das sieht schon so nach...
Also man sieht, dass es jemand gemacht hat, der weiß, was er tut.
Woran siehst du das?
Das sieht man daran, dass die nach unten so eine leichte Kurve nach innen, nach hinten machen, weil du damit verhinderst, dass du zu stark die Abstrahlung nach vorne bündelst. Das heißt, du hast, so wie die Dinge aufgehängt sind, müsstest du eine gute Abstrahlung haben, überall hin. Und ordentlich hören können.
Ja, sonst würde es ja auch dann über die ersten Reihen einfach so rüber gehen und so.
Ja, sehr schick, aber durchaus, ja.
Oben noch eine Empore.
Genau, aber da scheint nur so die Technik zu sein. Daneben gibt es halt noch diesen Briefing-Room. Der soll wohl auch ganz schick aussehen, aber da lief gerade eine Veranstaltung, da konnte ich nicht rein.
So ein schicker Raum und dann findet alles da unten in dieser Krabbeltischhalle statt.
Ja, unten ist halt nur Sales und oben machen sie halt ihr eigenliches Ding. Also die orientieren sich ja jetzt in zunehmendem Maße, mehr so in diese Richtung von After-Sales-Support-Training, Tra-la-la, One-on-One-Business-Kram und da liegt wohl auch ein Schwerpunkt hier bei diesem System.
Das heißt, das einzige Glas ist da dieses schicke Geländer da, ja?
Ja, schick, für geeignete Werte von schick, ja. Aber machen die da nicht auch so Kulturprogramm, so Musiker und so?
Jaja, da gibt es auch so Kulturprogramm. Dann gibt es hier noch mal so eine kleine Ecke neben diesem Event. Genau, das ist zum Kochenlernen.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen fies, weil der Hörer kriegt jetzt neuer da nichts mit, ne?
Oder die Hörerin.
Ja, also da ist halt neben dem Eventraum noch mal so ein kleiner Raum, noch mal mit Tischen. Also ich kann mir nur vorstellen, dass wenn da ein Event läuft und dann gibt es irgendwie was Neues zu zeigen, dann kannst du es da dann auch ausprobieren und so weiter. Also alles im Großen und Ganzen recht unspektakulär. Trotz alledem ist das Gebäude schon sehr schick hergerichtet. Man kann nur ahnen, was da für Klimmzüge gemacht werden mussten, um aus dem alten Gemäuer alles wie neu zu machen. Weil das ist jetzt alles wie neu. Also sie haben es wirklich auch komplett saniert.
Und sehr großzügig, finde ich. Das sieht alles sehr großzügig aus.
Was das dir kostet haben muss.
Ja, das war bestimmt teuer.
Ach, Portokasse.
100 iPhones verkaufen, als du sie da drin.
Ja, ja, links sagt ihr, ich hab noch keinen links. Ich hab das hier gerade mal irgendwie von meinem Foto gekratzt.
Warum hast du das denn noch nicht voll mit Flickr hochgeladen? Oder in deine, wie heißt das, Photostream?
Na, das ist ja jetzt gerade, ich guck ja gerade hier auf meine Fotoströmung. Ich, ist ja auch jetzt kein besonders vollständiges Kompendium. Aber ich kann das jetzt mal hier gleich mal irgendwo hinwerfen. Ja, soviel zum Apple Store. Wir beklagen uns jetzt nicht. Alles super, macht weiter so.
Wir beklagen uns insofern, dass wir jetzt gar nichts mehr über Apple zu reden haben.
Ja, das stimmt, das war's.
Also, ich überleg ja durchaus, ich verbringe so die Tage vor der nächsten Mobile-Max-Sendung, verbringe ich so gelegentlich auf der Terrasse bei Buga und denk so, was ist denn eigentlich los hier in dieser Apple-Welt? Ist da überhaupt was los? Dann versuche ich wirklich minutenlang krampfhaft mir irgendwie was auszudenken, was da so passiert sein könnte und es passiert einfach nichts. Also, mal abgesehen davon, dass wenn man darüber nachdenken würde, was wir ja bestimmt heute auch noch tun, was denn so passieren könnte.
Ja, das können wir auch gleich mal machen, weil dann sind wir dann durch mit den Themen.
Ja, auch da ist ja eigentlich, also es gibt natürlich so unsere Liste von Features, wo wir eigentlich mittlerweile auch schon wissen, dass die wahrscheinlich ignoriert werden.
Nur weil wir sie haben wollen, wird Apple sie trotzdem möglicherweise.
Ja, naja, also ich meine, hier was ihr schon vor der Sendung meintet, so iOS 7, wenn jetzt der Johnny Ive da wirklich mit dem Pinsel nochmal drüber gebürstet ist und alles flach gebügelt hat oder einfach komplett geändert hat. Das wäre natürlich schon spektakler, aber es gibt ja auch gar keine Rumors. Was ich wirklich krass finde seit Tim Cook, ist auch dieser Rumorflow noch mehr abgeappt als ohnehin schon vorher. Also irgendwie passiert gar nichts mehr.
Na weil früher, Steve hat gesagt, ihr dürft alle überhaupt gar nichts erzählen, aber selber hat er natürlich immer so ein bisschen geleakt und das macht er jetzt nicht und keiner hat gewusst, dass es immer Steve war, deswegen kommt jetzt gar nichts mehr raus.
Jetzt ist er nicht raus, wer immer gepetzt hat.
Na klar, du musst ja immer so ein bisschen anfüttern draußen, das ist doch klar.
Ich finde es interessant, wie es alle total fertig macht. Oder? Also die ganze Presse, die sind einfach gefühlt arbeitslos.
Aber uns betrifft es ja Gott sei Dank nicht, weil wir wissen ja voll Bescheid, wir dürfen halt nur nicht drüber reden.
So, aber irgendwo gab es doch zumindest so ein bisschen Rumors.
Aber kann Spuren von Rumor enthalten?
Ja, also zumindest scheint es sich abzuzeichnen, dass dieses Gerücht, dass das UI überarbeitet wird, ja, dass das stimmt.
Ich müsste ja jetzt auch mal nach...
Da gab es absurde Vorstellungen irgendwelcher Grafiker, wie das dann hinterher aussehen soll.
Ja, von Simpli Cesky oder wie heißt die? Keine Ahnung. So eine irische Bude.
Ja, ich meine also, dass es mal Zeit ist, finde ich ja auch ganz angebracht, weil die Optik hat sich jetzt ja wirklich nur minimal verbessert oder verändert seit dem uiPhone. Und dass das jetzt nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss sein kann.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass es jetzt eine großartig revolutionäre Optik sein wird.
Nee, aber halt so, wie jetzt, wenn du heute dir einen Jaguar oder so installierst oder einen Tiger und dir das anguckst und denkst, das habe ich benutzt. Das habe ich benutzt! Das haben die sich getraut zu releasen.
Als diese runden, kugeligen Ampel-Buttons noch so richtig obendrauf auf dem Fenster saßen.
Das ist die Bude, die dieses Video gemacht hat.
Und so in dem Sinne stelle ich mir das eigentlich auch vor, dass du dann irgendwann mal auf iOS 6 und so guckst und denkst dir, oh mein Gott, wie konnten sie es wagen, das jemals zu releasen.
Ach, da ist hier diese Windows Phone Optik da. Also ich glaube auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt, nicht an diesen ganzen Flat-Kram. Da wäre ich schon sehr überrascht, wenn sie jetzt diesen ganzen Flat-Fu machen und was weiß ich, hier nicht abgerundete Icons und so weiter.
Nee, das sind ja nicht bei Windows.
Das sieht ja nur wirklich aus wie Windows. Also es ist ja Windows 8 durch und durch. Und in gewisser Hinsicht ist es ja bemerkenswert, dass Windows 8 da so auch so ein Radikaldesign macht und sich eben so dermaßen unterscheidet. Aber ich finde es deswegen nicht gleich besser. Ehrlich gesagt, ich war schon immer ein großer Freund von so einer gewissen sinnvollen Dreidimensionalität der Dinge. Also ich mag das. Ich finde, dass das hilft. Ich konnte auch mit Mac OS 8 Optik durchaus was anfangen. Ich mochte diese Button, wie die sich so klickten und diese Fensterrahmen, wie die aussahen und so.
Ich finde, das muss so ein sehr flaches 3D sein. Also nur so ein Minimalschatten und nur eine Levelhöhe irgendwie. Das gibt es aber nicht so voll in die Tiefe.
War das nicht bei OS 8 noch so, dass die Folder auch so im Raum standen quasi?
So schräg?
So schräg.
Ja, ich glaube, da war was. So isometrisch, ne?
Nee, ich bin auch total für so ein bisschen 3D zu haben. Also so ein bisschen Schlagschatten und runde Ecke und so. Das darf schon sein. Vielleicht sogar ein Verlauf.
Ja, aber ich meine so gebundene Bücher mit Abreißkanten von Zetteln und so ein Zeug. Das brauchen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt, oder?
Nee, Kalender und Game Center kann weg. Nee, nicht Kalender. Adressbuch und Game Center, die Optik da, das brauch ich auch nicht. Diesen Bildertisch da.
Ja, ich glaube, das wird sicherlich sterben.
Also Game Center ist tatsächlich auch immer noch eins der größten UI-Verbrechen von Apple.
Und das Adressbuch.
Ja, aber Game Center ist nicht nur ein UI-Verbrechen. Also ich meine, das ist auch so hintenrum, wie es funktioniert oder auch nicht. Aber lassen wir das.
Wobei ich insgesamt sagen muss, ich hab so mit der iOS Appearance an sich relativ wenig Probleme. Also, mir stört das alles nicht so.
Das ist eh relativ flach, ne?
Ja, das ist jetzt nicht so übertrieben und ich find da wenig falsch. Ich find die Buttons okay, ich find die Erfolgerungen, die Schatten. Ich seh da relativ wenig Probleme. Wo es mich richtig ankotzt, ist halt, wie es auf Mac OS mittlerweile aussieht.
Hast du mal Screenshots von dem neuen Delicious Library 3 gesehen? Also ich hab's selber nicht im Betrieb gehabt. Aber die haben ja oben ihr Fensterkante, die hat ja so was wie so ein alter Schrank mit so ner komischen gefrästen Board. Das sieht völlig absurd aus.
Jetzt müsste man wieder wissen, wie man Delicious schreibt.
Delicious Library.
O-U-Us.
Also ich kann da sonst nicht viel zu sagen zu Delicious Library. Ich hab auch die anderen Versionen nie benutzt. Aber diese komische, klassizistische Wand-Schrank-Optik, die fand ich ein bisschen sehr merkwürdig.
Kann man sich das denn überhaupt angucken?
Im App Store zum Beispiel, glaub ich.
Ich guck grad auf der Webseite.
So, was gibt's denn noch für iOS 7-Rumors, außer jetzt hier das, was die da alten Windows-Optik verbrochen haben?
Keine Ahnung, das Einzige, was irgendwelche Leute gepostet haben, waren Server-Logs, dass da jetzt iOS 7 tatsächlich auch auf Safari von iOS 7 ihren Servern aufschlägt, von Richtung Apple aus. Aber ansonsten...
Gibt's auch da einfach nix. Also ich wüsste so ein paar kleine Sachen, die ich gerne mal hätte.
Also bei Passbook werden sie bestimmt ordentlich erweitern, oder? Das könnt ich mir gut vorstellen. Da wollen die nichts verpassen auf jeden Fall.
Denkbar.
Also ich hätte gern mal ordentlich Multi-User fürs iPad. Das wäre gerade so für Familien.
Das fordern wir ja schon seit Generatoren.
Da bin ich auch ganz bei dir.
Fürs iPhone muss es nicht unbedingt sein. Aber fürs iPad wäre das echt mal ganz schick.
Ich fänd total toll. Das ist jetzt so das kleine Mini-Feature. Aber wenn man die Siri- oder die Maps-Sprache unabhängig von der Systemsprache einstellen könnte.
Siri-Sprache kannst du aber glaube ich unabhängig.
Ja, aber das betrifft halt nicht Maps. Das ist halt die Scheiße. Ich hab halt mein Telefon wie alles so auf Englisch. Und dann hab ich extra Siri auf Deutsch eingestellt. Und dann ist es aber trotzdem so, dass wenn ich dann Maps aufmache, dann ist es Gnisenew Strasser. Und dieser ganze Scheiße. Und du kriegst echt die Krise. Das kann man halt nicht gebrauchen so richtig. Ich lerne jetzt zwar wie Touristen diese Straßen aussprechen. Wenn mich ein Tourist jetzt fragt, wo die Gnisenew-Straße ist, dann weiß ich auch, ah, es ist Gneisenau-Straße gemeint. Aber abgesehen von diesem Bildungseffekt, fände ich das extrem schön, wenn Maps separat...
Ja, Maps könnte sich auch mal eine Tüte Grammatik kaufen. Also dieses in 300 Meter rechts abbiegen auf Gneisenau-Straße.
Das wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Das ist so der Moment, wo ich dann Apple Maps wieder ausmache und mich dann doch von TomTom leiten lasse. Die es dann hinkriegen mit ihrer Stimme. Da ist es dann richtig.
Ja, aber TomTom ist ja auch so ein bisschen neben der Spur mit ihrer Sprache. Was sagen die dann immer? In 300 Metern, sie haben ihr Ziel erreicht.
Ja, das ist auch schön.
Da würde ich dich dann eigentlich auch mal so ein bisschen durch den Bildschirm durchhauen.
Aber sie haben ihr Ziel erreicht? Ist das nicht...
In 300 Metern, sie haben ihr Ziel erreicht?
Nein. Nein, in 300 Metern Ankunft sagen sie. Weil sie haben ihr Ziel erreicht, hat sich nämlich Garmeln als Wortmarke eintragen lassen. Und das sagt TomTom garantiert nicht. Doch.
Also ich kenne nur von WoW, das Ziel ist zu weit entfernt.
Also ich weiß nur, dass das Ziel an sich auf Finnisch Parmaran heißt, weil ich irgendwann den TomTom auch mal auf Finnisch hatte. So, so. Motto Riddille ist auf die Autobahn. Wir sind total abgekommen.
Wie viel Bier hattet ihr schon?
Ich bin hier beim zweiten. Bock allerdings.
Ich hab mein erstes noch nicht mal gefinished. Aber zurück zu iOS 7. Also Multi-User-Spracheinstellungen. Ich mein, ich muss ja sagen, ich hab mich an das Level von Apple Maps mittlerweile so gewöhnt, dass ich irgendwie gar keine Beschwerden mehr hab. Ich hab mich daran gewöhnt, dass da bestimmte Sachen einfach immer noch nicht findet und falsch sind.
Zum Beispiel die Uni, wo du mal warst oder bist, die hieß immer noch Technische Universität. Da hab ich mal Report a Problem probiert und hab dir mal gesagt, dass das Berlin University of the Arts ist. Hab das schon geändert haben, weiß ich aber noch. Ich hab noch nicht wieder nachgeguckt.
Da sind halt einfach manche Straßen, die gehen halt ins Nirgendwo. Und da ist schon längst, also man muss ja in Berlin vorsichtig sein, mit Zeitangaben, Baustellen und so weiter. Aber ich hab so den Eindruck, so bestimmte Straßenprojekte und so, die kriegen sie schon relativ gut hin. Und da gibt es jetzt eine tolle Straße, schon seit einem halben Jahr, die wirklich, wo ich Dankes gebeten, gegen den roten Rathaus geschickt hab. Und die ist auch immer noch nicht drin. Der schickt dich da immer noch so einmal.
Welche ist das denn?
Dankes gebet zum roten Rathaus? Wieso zum roten Rathaus? Was haben die denn damit zu tun?
Machen die da nicht irgendwie Straßen-Stadtplanungen?
Ach du hast Dankes gebet geschickt, weil sie die gebaut haben?
Ja.
Welche Straße denn?
Und zwar, äh, wie heißt die...
Oranienrecke Kochstraße, die zur Leipziger geht, das Stück?
Die ist gut.
Nee, die Wilhelm-Kapus-Straße, oder?
Mann, also die Lindenstraße hoch, die ganze Zeit jüdisches Museum vorbei, immer geradeaus... Jüdisches Museum?
Ach so, das Berlin-Museum.
Axel Springer vorbei, immer geradeaus bis zur Leipziger. Der Durchstich.
Der Durchstich, Rudi Deutschke Straße.
Genau, und da muss es ja früher immer so tierisch einen abbrechen. Und dieses Stück Straße ist so geil, das sagt er.
Und da ist immer nichts los, man kann so rettern.
Da ist nichts los und die... Also das war so ein pain in the ass, diese Ecke da zu überbrücken. Und die ist bei Apple Maps glaube ich bis heute nicht drin.
Die ist aber auch relativ neu. Also ich meine, das ist ein halbes Jahr alt oder so.
Ja, ich hab da schon zweimal reported problem geklickt.
Aber was ich mal sagen will, ich war ja zum Kuhdamm gefahren und dachte mir, alles klar, Filmbühne Wien, war ich... Ja, das ist ja schon immer eine Reise wert. Und ich war ja als Kind früher öfter irgendwie Kuhdamm mit den ganzen Kinos und ich war auch schon, weiß nicht wie oft, in einer Filmbühne Wien und so. Und dachte, ich weiß ja, ich brauch mir gar nicht gucken und so weiter. Brede da so lang, bin mit dem Motorrad erstmal vorbeigefahren, noch mal lang, noch mal vorbeigefahren. Dachte mir, das kann doch nicht sein. Hab ich gegoogelt, also nicht gegoogelt, Apple Maps, eingetippt, Apple Store, no results. Warte, dann Apple Store hab ich B getippt, R-Completed zu Apple Store Berlin Kuhdamm. Ich so, ja, das will ich wissen. Klick so, er so, no results. Warum schlägt er mir Sachen vor, wenn es keine Results gibt? Also und das geht einfach nicht. Du kannst nicht nach Apple Store suchen.
Übrigens, Berlin Tempelhof ist hier auch immer noch als Flughafen eingezeichnet.
Ja, also, aber was man ihnen lassen muss, das was sie kennen und so und auch die Route, die Routenführung und so, das ist eigentlich ganz okay. Also ich lass mich schon immer von Apple Maps Routen mit englischer Stimme auf deutschen Straßennamen und so, ich ertrag das alles. Aber da können sie bei iOS 7 nochmal so richtig, also damit können sie nochmal so richtig Fans wieder gewinnen. Ja, wenn sie da dieses Apple Maps nochmal so richtig aufbohren.
Ja vor allen Dingen, weite Teile von Berlin sind jetzt nicht mehr in schöner Eiche bei Berlin. Also das ist auch ganz gut.
Ja, ich hab natürlich ein deutsches Apple Maps anscheinend, oder irgendwie so. Apfel laden? Ja, aber dann kommen hier nur irgendwelche Service-Läden. Aber wie sucht man einen Deutschen nach dem Apple Store? Weil nach Apple Store sagt er no results.
Ja, der ist auch nicht eingezeichnet, oder?
Außerdem schlägt er mir ja auch Apple Store vor. Ja, keine Ahnung. Also, Jungs, wenn ihr da bei Apple arbeitet, sorgt mal dafür, dass euer Store im Laden ist. Es ist kein Wunder, wenn er so leer ist. Na ja, voll war er nicht, als ich da gestern war. Ich hätte mir das schlimmer vorgestellt.
Wie viel Uhr warst du denn da so? 15 Uhr, da gehen die Leute halt arbeiten.
Also, es war schon jeder Tischbesetzer so, aber ich könnte mir den Laden noch ein bisschen voller vorstellen.
Geh mal nach 18 Uhr hin.
Soll ich mal Apfel richtig in Deutsch schreiben? Apfel Store.
Ja, also ich finde dieses Maps-Thema, da können sie auf jeden Fall noch richtig punkten beim iOS 7 Update. Das wär gut. Bin ich dafür. Dann können sie mal ihr gottverdammtes Airplay in den Griff kriegen. Das nervt nämlich auch. Das geht immer nur so die Hälfte der Zeit. Und immer dann, wenn man es wirklich gerne hätte, dann geht es irgendwie immer nicht so richtig.
Vor allem auf Macs mit Lautmachung.
Meint ihr jetzt Video oder Audio Only?
Alles.
Also Audio hatte ich noch nie Ärger.
Ja, Audio liegt dann meistens an der Base Station, stimmt. Also, nee, Audio geht eigentlich. Aber so Video...
Ja, aber Audio Only ist auch ein ganz anderes Protokoll. Das ist einfach... Hab ich schon ein paar Mal ausgeführt, aber...
Dann können sie ihr, hat man ja letztes Mal schon erwähnt, ihr Messages auch mal irgendwie so fixen.
Du bist es doch eigentlich im Wesentlichen gefixt.
Ja, nee, es ist halt immer... Du kennst doch das Phänomen auch. Du hast dein Telefon und deinen Rechner und du hast Messages auf dem Mac offen, und du hast hier dein Telefon. Und dann kommt hier so eine Nachricht, und die blinkt auf dem Telefon. Und dann kommt sie aber nicht auf dem Mac. Und dann kommt sie, und dann sind aber die Nachrichten immer noch irgendwie in komischer Reihenfolge und nicht das Neueste oben. Und dann ist eine Konversation von gestern vor der Nachricht, die gerade angekommen ist. Und manchmal sind die Lesestati nicht richtig synchronisiert. Und manchmal musst du Messages aus- und wieder anmachen. Und dann, oh simsalawim, wird wieder alles richtig gesortiert.
Noch viel schlimmer ist ja irgendwie Messages, wenn du versuchst, Video zu machen. Du kannst nämlich mit Message, kannst du tatsächlich eine Videokonferenz machen, aber nur dann. Wenn der Account, zu dem du versuchst, die Videokonferenz zu machen, kein iCloud-Account ist, sondern irgendwie so ein Java-Account oder sowas, dann geht das ohne Probleme. Aber kaum, hat der andere Account, ist ein iCloud-Account, dann musst du irgendwie Facetime machen. Facetime kannst du aber nicht mit mehreren Leuten machen.
Naja, schon wie das Facetime-Ding ist ja auch noch da, ne? Wann habt ihr das letzte Mal gefacetimed? Ist billiger.
Ja, ist nicht so lange her, dass ich das letzte Mal gemacht hab.
Na, ich hab's, glaub ich, seit... Jahren nicht benutzt. Deswegen, ich glaub, das bin nur ich.
Ob's nie deine Freundin an?
Nicht mit Facetime.
Warum nicht?
Weiß nicht.
Und du siehst auch was.
Gut. Und iCloud, da wir das jetzt alle nicht benutzen wollen, hoffen wir uns von iOS 7 auch keine teureren iCloud-Features.
Ja, ich denke sowieso, wenn sie irgendwas wirklich fixen müssen, iOS ist eigentlich völlig in Ordnung. Ja, also, ich weiß nicht, habt ihr irgendwie Major-Issues? Gibt's irgendwas, was wirklich total scheiße ist und wirklich...
Also wir reden jetzt nicht von iCloud, sondern von iOS selber.
Ja, ja, so was auf dem Device ist, usability-mäßig, also klar, hier und da so ein bisschen was, aber das wird noch nicht mal eine Major-Issue sein.
Ja, ich sag voll Niggeligkeiten, aber jetzt keine großen Löcher.
Das ist eigentlich spannend, ne? Weil wenn sie jetzt irgendwie was abfeiern wollen, kommen sie vielleicht mal wieder mit neuen Ideen.
Ja, oder mit Hardware, die wieder irgendwas möglich macht, was vorher noch nicht gab.
Hab ich doch auch gestern geschrieben, dass bei Siri als Server seitlich ein neues Feature eingeführt wurde. Und zwar, wenn du Siri zu lange Fragen stellst, dann kommen sie Siri mit entsprechend langen Antworten und sagt dir, du sollst deine Fragen mal ein bisschen kürzer stellen. Und sie macht es aber sehr eloquent, dir zu sagen, dass du das mal ein bisschen kürzer machen sollst. Da gab es ein paar Zitate von verschiedenen Leuten, unter anderem Hemingway, glaube ich.
Also nach dem Initialen ein paar Mal ausprobieren, ist die Sache irgendwie eingeschlafen. Vor allem auch, weil man es dann doch irgendwie dreimal sagen muss und dann...
Das letzte Mal Siri benutzen, das hat es für mich komplett zerstört. Da habe ich halt gesagt, hier rote mich nach Hause oder so in der Apple Maps oder was auch immer, rote nach Hause. Und dann so, denkst du, das ist echt der trivialste Use-Case von allen. Also wenn sie irgendwas fuzzy matchen, dann noch bitte das. Und dann so, ich konnte es leider nicht verstehen, meintest du zu Hause oder nach Hause? Genau das, was ich gesagt habe. Ja, ich meinte nach Hause. Ich konnte es leider nicht verstehen, meintest du nach Hause? Und dann hatte ich schon das Telefon in der geballten Faust und habe es noch einmal probiert. Sie hat es wieder nicht verstanden, obwohl sie es genauso gesagt hat wie ich. Und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, fuck it. Ich tippe es ein, ist gut, danke, wieder schauen. Und seitdem habe ich Siri nie wieder benutzt.
Also diktieren?
Diktieren?
Nee, es funktioniert auch nicht gut genug.
Manchmal, aber...
Funktioniert das gut genug für dich?
So wie du meintest, man fühlt sich so bekloppt irgendwie mit seinem Telefon zu reden.
Ich will nicht mit meinem, ich will durch mein Telefon reden, aber nicht in. Also ich nehme was auf.
Ich weiß nicht, wo...
Also nicht mit. Ich bin nicht mit meinem Reden.
Wo es mir irgendwie Siri dann gebrochen hat, als ich irgendwann irgendwas ausprobiert hab. Und dann war so, Siri so, ja willst du das oder das tun? Bestätigen oder Abbruch? Und dann sagst du bestätigen und was sagt Siri? Ich verstehe bestätigen nicht. Soll ich danach im Web suchen oder sowas? Dann denkst du ja nur so, hallo.
Oh man, so sollten wir uns ja immer unterhalten.
Also das mit dem Siri, den ganzen Hesel, den sie sich da gegeben haben, den hätten sie sich wirklich sparen und mal irgendwo anders reinstecken können. Na ja, mal sehen, vielleicht wird es ja noch. Aber wie lange ich schon mit Leuten über dieses Voice Recognition-Thema gesprochen hab, wobei du hattest ja mal irgendeine Diktiersoftware angepriesen hier, die irgendwie angeblich ganz toll wäre. Aber, nee, also dieses Diktierfeature, ich hab's tatsächlich ein-, zweimal probiert. Und dann bist du halt doch wieder dabei, jedes Wort noch mal zu lesen, um zu gucken, ob irgendwo ein Schreibfehler ist. Und ja, da sind Schreibfehler. Deswegen...
Also auf dem Telefon ist es tatsächlich so, dass das Tippen auf dem Telefon halt manchmal so nervig ist. Dass man dann versucht ist, das zu diktieren, aber irgendwie...
Ich schick dir jetzt mal eine SMS.
Das sind so Features, die benutzt man ein paar Mal, dann tun sie nicht richtig und dann lässt man's und dann graten sie in Vergessenheit.
Ich schick dir jetzt mal eine SMS, ne? Schicke eine SMS an Roddy.
Das will ich aber nicht.
Nein, nicht abschicken! Siehst du, und dann geht's schon los.
Genau das, genau. Genau, welche Nachricht möchtest du deinem Erzfeind schicken? Das ist doch echt alles bekloppt.
Also ich hab dich als Roddy hier drin, hat er aber leider nicht, äh, wollte er nicht.
Sag mal, ich hab da neulich so eine SMS von dir gekriegt, da stand nur abbrechen drin. Was wolltest du mir damit sagen?
Freundschaft abbrechen!
Ja, wir halten fest, das ist irgendwie, das geht nicht. Ich denke, diese Multi-User-Geschichte ist tatsächlich, das wär wirklich so ein...
Das wär ein dickes Feature, ja.
Weil dieses iPad wird für mich allein deshalb eigentlich so als Familientool völlig unbenutzbar. Weil man will ja eigentlich so ein Scheißteil da irgendwie ins Wohnzimmer legen und dann nutzt das, wer auch immer gerade so Zeit dafür hat.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, da ist ein halbes Unix drunter unter dem kacke iOS und dann kriegen sie keinen Multi-User hin. Das darf doch nicht wahr sein.
Ja, das versteh ich auch nicht.
Das kriegen sie ja natürlich hin, aber sie wollen es scheinbar nicht.
Ja, sie wollen natürlich, dass jedes Familienmitglied sein eigenes iPad hat. Sehe ich auch ein, dass sie das wollen, aber ich will es nicht. Also, von mir aus.
Das ist die beste Methode dafür zu sorgen, dass jeder sein eigenes iPad haben will, weil wenn man überhaupt erst mal eins benutzen darf...
Weil sie sonst nämlich gar nicht kriegen, richtig?
Also, das Feature hätte eher dazu geführt, dass ich noch ein paar iPads kaufe.
Das heißt, sie brauchen auch gleich das Feature, wenn sie dieses Multi-User machen, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, wenn man sich da ein neues iPad holt, dass man sich von seinem Gerät von Papa sozusagen seinen User auf sein neues eigenes Gerät schieben kann. Das ist sozusagen der große Moment zum 12. Geburtstag.
Lass mich raten. Wir iCloud.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Ja, halten wir fest, das ist das eigentliche, woran sie arbeiten müssen. Und da müssen sie echt arbeiten. Also, dass sie irgendwie keinen SYNC richtig hinkriegen und dass das alles irgendwie nicht geht. Ja.
Das predigen wir jetzt schon auch eine ganze Weile.
Ja, wir wiederholen uns. Das lassen wir jetzt. Wir machen das Thema zu. Und zur RS7 fällt uns nichts ein. Hauts raus, aber wenn mich wirklich etwas interessiert, wäre mal so ein Mac OS 10.9 irgendwie. Weg mit diesem ganzen Skiomorf-Scheiß. Endlich mal ein Adressbuch, wo man diese Adressen auch wirklich richtig bearbeiten kann.
So ein Management-Tool.
Ja, wo vielleicht auch mal die Features, die seit 10.0 da drin sind, die sie sich noch nicht getraut haben rauszuschmeißen, auch mal funktionieren. So was wie Mailing-Listen-Support.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn sie schon so ein Skiomorphes Buch machen, dann will ich auch umblättern können.
Hör jetzt bloß auf, sonst kommen die damit noch. Blicken wir lieber auf angenehme Sachen zurück, blicken wir auf unsere letzten Sendungen zurück. Da haben wir ja einiges ausgelöst hier mit diesem ganzen Drossel-Telekom- Funktionalkaputt-Dingsbums. Das scheint sich ja jetzt wirklich zum ultimativen Mem zu entwickeln. Morgen ist übrigens Demo, falls jemand interessiert. Morgen ist der 16. Mai, weil wir hier am 15. sitzen und das aufnehmen. Ist also jetzt wohl eher was für Live-Hörer oder vielleicht schaffen wir es auch noch rechtzeitig, die Sendung rauszuhauen. Geht irgendwie morgen früh los und die treffen sich da vor dieser Aktionärsversammlung der Telekom, die in dieser Halle mit dem unversprechlichen Namen in Köln stattfindet.
In Köln? Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß. Ich hab nur eine ungefähre Vorstellung, wo das ist.
Ja, so Lahn, Lahn, Excess, Lahn, Lahn, Excess, wer auch immer diesen Namen erfunden hat, sollte gefeuert werden.
Na, die Bude, die auch so heißt, oder?
Genau, wer ein bisschen online demonstrieren will, da gibt es ja auch noch eine kleine hübsche Seite, die heißt demo.hilftelekom.de. Da kann man dann online, auf der Telekom-Seite demonstrieren.
Lanxess Arena?
Ich mach das mal in den Chat hier an.
Ein Werbeverbrechen größter.
Also ich weiß nicht, wer auf sowas kommt.
O2 Arena, my ass.
Genau, hier auf demo.hilftelekom.de kann man irgendwie seine eigenen Protestplakate ausfüllen, die dann direkt auf der Homepage sind. Keine Ahnung, was das dann letztendlich wird, aber naja.
Es geht auf jeden Fall.
Hat auf jeden Fall ein up.net Sharing Button, kann also nicht schlecht sein.
Oh, ich weiß noch ein iOS 7 Feature. Mehr Emoji-Icons. Denn bei Emoji fehlt, oh jetzt, wie sagt man das richtig? Also es gibt Asiaten, es gibt Inder, es gibt... .White Guys, aber es gibt keine Black Guys.
Es sind Emoji nicht telefoniert oder es gibt auf dem iPhone keine?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich hatte ja den Eindruck, dass das Apple Emoji relativ umfangreich ist, aber zumindest im Apple Emoji-Universum gibt es keinen...
Das heißt aber nicht Black Guys.
Ja, wie heißt denn das korrekt?
People of Color heißt das.
Aber das könnt ihr... Nee, das sind ja auch nicht Amerikaner. Das sind ja Africans, wenn dann vielleicht sogar.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass das sinnvoll ist, sondern ich hab nur gesagt, dass es so genannt wird.
Aber People of Colors sind ja alle möglichen Namen.
Die Weißen sind dann auch People of Color oder was?
Wenn man es genau nimmt schon. Also wenn man jetzt von so additiven Farben...
Also auf jeden Fall sind nicht alle Artengruppen von Menschen da.
Also sind auf jeden Fall nicht alle Farben vertreten.
Sind nicht alle Farben vertreten. Und das prang ich hiermit offiziell an.
Genau, die Massmensch haben sich auch schon beschwert.
Wir waren bei drossel.com.
Genau, wir waren bei drossel.com. Ansonsten gibt es nicht viel zu berichten. Telekom muss erstaunlich viel Schläge dafür einstecken, finde ich, so in der Öffentlichkeit. Also mich wundert, dass das Thema irgendwie immer noch da ist. Gut, auf der Republika war das klar, dass das so zum Dauerthema werden wird, aber es ist halt auch noch nicht so richtig weg. Mal schauen. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich da groß was ändern wird, aber am Ende des Tages haben sie zumindest dafür bezahlen müssen.
Apropos...
Republika... Ja, die war gerade die Republika. Und ihr wart alle nicht da, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, es waren sehr viele Nerds auch da, habe ich gehört.
Ich habe ja gehört, was der Sinn und Zweck der Republika ist, aber ich glaube, das sollte ich ja nicht erzählen.
Aber ich glaube, es waren sogar Nerds, die auch früher noch nicht da waren. Also, ich habe von Nerds... Ne, alte Nerds, die sich der Sache eher verwehrt haben, weil da sind nur die Blogger und so, und diese digitale Bohem und so.
Alte Nerds, neu dabei.
Und die Web-Hipster. Diese Meinung hat sich jetzt verflogen und da waren jetzt auch die richtigen Nerds.
Ja, die waren letztes Jahr auch schon da und es ist ja auch Quatsch. Es war noch nie so eine richtige Hipster-Veranstaltung, fand ich. Es wird vielleicht eher noch ein bisschen mehr zu einer, aber gewesen ist es keine.
Das habe ich auch nicht behauptet. Das war eher so die Annehmung mancher.
Ja, nee, es war an sich eine ganz cremige Veranstaltung. Da war halt eine Menge los, viele Leute da, interessante Talks und uninteressante Talks und gute Talks und schlechte Talks, wie das so ist auf so einer Konferenz. Wir haben da so ein bisschen Podcasting-Raum gespielt und da gesendet. Wer Lust hat, da vielleicht nochmal anzuschließen, das Sendezentrum, so nannte sich das Projekt, hat die Sondersendung produziert, diesondersendung.de und da kann man dann auch noch die drei Sendungen, die wir da gemacht haben, nachhören. Einmal so ein bisschen Bock hat da, so den Vibe der Republik zu machen. Na ja, und wie schon von mir angedeutet, gab es vor allem auf dieser Republik ein Novum, nämlich Internet. Ernsthaft, also es war jetzt über sechs Jahre einfach immer so die Story schlechthin, so dass das mit dem Netz auf der Republik nicht klappt. Und ich meine, ihr wisst ja selber, wie das so ist, mit Konferenzen und vielen Teilnehmern und WLAN und so weiter.
Und wie sagt Clemens immer so schön, kaum macht man es richtig, geht es auch schon.
Genau, das hat er schön unter Beweis gestellt da mit seinem Team und der hat da irgendwie auch echt viel Zeit verbracht. Der war irgendwie schon vier Wochen vorher und hat dieses ganze Gebäude komplett neu verstrippt.
Das ganze Gebäude neu verstrippt.
Sie haben da so richtig lange Leitungen neu gelegt, Glasfaser über die Dächer und so weiter. Und vor allem auch so die ganze existierende bzw. nicht existierende Netzwerkinfrastruktur gepimpt, ordentliches Zeug reingestellt. Ja, und so mit Netz und doppelten Boden, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
In a Station. Und haben die das sozusagen jetzt so als permanenten Installation übernommen?
Ja, da gibt es permanente Anteile und flüchtige Anteile, die halt nur für die Veranstaltung gefahren sind. Das müsste aber jetzt Clemens irgendwie erläutern. Wer da jetzt was bezahlt hat, das zieht sich vollständig meiner Kenntnis. Auf jeden Fall war das lustig mit anzusehen, wie das so alles funktioniert hat. Es war wirklich ein wirklich gut funktionierendes Netz. Man hatte fast immer wirklich performantes W-Laden. Vor allem habe ich nicht ein einziges Mal so obskure Fehlermeldungen gesehen, dass du aus dem Netz geschmissen wirst, komplett ausbucht oder so. Es war vielleicht mal langsam, aber das war dann auch dem Fakt geschuldet, dass der Zeitplan immer wieder die Leute in die Mitte reingespült hat. Da hatten dann immer so in den Pausen die totalen Überkapazitäten oder Unterkapazitäten entstanden. Uns hat das nicht groß betroffen. Wir hatten da oben ein schön schnelles Kabelnetz.
Wie war denn die Anbindung?
Die Anbindung war, glaube ich... Ach was, das hat er mir erklärt.
War es ein Gigabit oder...?
Also wenn Clemens sagt, etwas ist schnell, das ist für uns normalsterblich schnell genug.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob er das als schnell bezeichnet hat. Er hat mir gesagt und ich bin zum Schluss gekommen, dass es für die Veranstaltung ausreicht. Aber ich kann es nicht mehr auswendig runterbeten, was es war.
Das kann er uns ja alles nächstes Mal erklären.
Wir verschieben das Thema.
Aber ich habe was zum Thema WLAN trotzdem noch so anzuhängen, was jetzt nichts mit der Republika und nichts mit der Station und nichts mit Clemens zu tun hat. Und Clemens hoffentlich auch nicht zum Zusammenzucken bringt, wenn er jetzt das hört. Und zwar folgendes Problem. Wir kennen das alle, wir klicken oben auf dieses Airport-Icon und es scrollt sich bis unten an den Bildschirmrandanschlag irgendwie eine Liste von in der Umgebung verfügbaren WLANs. Da so zusammen. Und in letzter Zeit war es bei mir so, dass das WLAN irgendwie gefühlt schlechter wurde. Zum Beispiel auch meine Airport Express, die so das Haupt-WLAN-Extended zum Musikstream und so, die hat sich irgendwie immer so ausgeklinkt.
Ja, in dem Moment, wo du das Menü aufmachst, ist dein WLAN weg, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Früher war das so.
Ja, nee, nee, nee. Aber so, und dann dachte ich mir so, okay, vielleicht, also meine Base Stations, bei Apple gibt es ja diese tolle Einstellung, irgendwie bei der Kanal-Auswahl automatisch, was bei mir bisher immer dazu geführt hat, dass es einfach auf 11 bleibt, also bei 2,4 GHz WLAN gibt es ja da diese, in Deutschland diese 11 Kanäle zur Ausbau, oder 13, irgendwie so. Und dann hab ich halt mal geguckt, wollte ich mal gucken, wie es denn hier eigentlich bei mir so in der Nachbarschaft aussieht, wo denn die WLANs da sich so rumtummeln, weil die meisten sind halt schon immer noch irgendwie auf 2,4 GHz, weil ja die alten iPhones und alten Androids noch gar kein 5 GHz konnten. So, und dann mal die Frage, ok, ich hab schon ewiglich mehr so einen WLAN-Scanner aufgefahren. Ja, so War Driving ist echt irgendwie noch von letztes Jahrtausend irgendwie, als es noch nicht Internet überall gab. Und dann früher hat man ja so Kismac benutzt, zum Beispiel. Es gibt auch ein Command Line Tool, was im Prinzip das Gleiche tut, also was in den Core-Services versteckt ist. Es gibt auch ein Command Line Tool, was im Prinzip das Gleiche tut, was passiert, wenn man oben auf dieses Icon klickt. Aber so einen kontinuierlichen Scan von den WLANs und welche Kanäle und wie die Signalstärke ist in schön und bunt, habe ich mal gesucht und dann überraschenderweise eine Antwort im App-Store gefunden, wo ich dachte, mit dem Sandboxen und ob das jetzt überhaupt was wird. Das heißt, ganz schnöde Wi-Fi-Scanner. Kostete 99 Cent.
So teuer?
Soooo unglaublich teuer, ja. Ich klick mal hier grad den Link zusammen. Das ist im Prinzip das Gleiche, was Kismac früher gemacht hat, nur in schön sozusagen, könnte man sagen. Ich kopie mal den Link und pack den in den Chat.
Das mit dem leicht lila Icon?
Ja, das mit dem VUGA-farbenen Icon, genau.
Nein, deswegen auch VUGA-farben.
Nein, ich mach Spaß. Auf jeden Fall hab ich damit dann mal laufen lassen und da kam wirklich auch eine unglaubliche Menge, weil nach einer Zeit kriegt er dann auch die mit den schwachen Signalen da noch rein und das ist wirklich Wahnsinn. Und dann hab ich nach Channel sortiert und hab dann halt auch festgestellt, ok, alles klar bei mir, ist wirklich, irgendwie sind acht, neun oder zehn WLANs waren da mit Kanal 11. Plus meine zwei Base Stations, die sich auf automatisch auch diesen Bereich getummelt haben. Und dann hab ich mir jetzt mal sozusagen den Bereich, der von den Kanälen gesucht, so nach alter Schule, der, die am wenigsten benutzt werden von den umgebenden WLANs und seitdem ist mein WLAN wieder schön.
Warum nicht gleich 5 Gigahertz?
Na ja, weil es in unserem Haushalt noch ein 2,4 Gigahertz iPhone gibt sozusagen, also iPhone 4 kann ja noch keinen 5 Gigahertz. Und deswegen, und ich hab auch keine Airport Extreme, die zwei Antennen oder zwei... Ja, ich hab noch eine sehr alte Airport Extreme. Ja, jetzt könnte man sagen, dann kauft ihr auch eine neue, blablabla. Aber jetzt hat doch hier Frabbs gerade eine neue gekauft oder angeschleppt. Egal, also wer ähnliche Probleme hat und wenn euer WLAN scheiße oder eure Airport Express irgendwie sich nicht manierlich benimmt, dann kann es sich so oder so auch mal lohnen, mit so einem Wifi-Scanner mal zu gucken, wie es in eurer Nachbarschaft so aussieht. Und wenn ihr euch dann einen Kanal manuell aussucht, der ja nicht so besetzt ist, dann funktioniert es vielleicht alles ein bisschen tollerer. Ja, das war es eigentlich schon. Das ist eigentlich schon ja auch lang bekanntes Wissen, aber da man es irgendwie in letzter Zeit nicht so häufig mehr brauchte, vielleicht auch wieder in Vergessenheit geraten. Ist auf jeden Fall mal ganz interessant zu gucken. Da sieht man auch wunderschön, von welchem Hersteller die ganzen Access Points sind. Das ist auch für so eine kleine Marktstudie durchaus geeignet. AVM ist wirklich sehr weit verbreitet, muss man auch sagen. Hier zum Beispiel in der Metaebene.
Ja, das ist interessant, dass man auch gleich zu den Herstellern sieht.
Ja, genau. Ist halt, also ich meine, ist jetzt wirklich kein spektakuläres Tool, aber tat jetzt eben mal so in dem Fall genau das, was ich mal haben wollte.
Sieht cool aus.
Und für die, es war 99 Cent, ne? Ja, und jetzt schreibt hier gerade einer im Chat, dass es ja in System Library Core Service Wi-Fi Diagnostics App gibt. Aber die Wi-Fi Diagnostics App, die macht halt nicht diesen kontinuierlichen Scan und zeigt dir nicht irgendwie nach 5 Minuten mal wirklich alle WLANs an, sondern das gibt da irgendwie nur so einen komischen Abriss. Zumindest hab ich da nicht den richtigen Modus gefunden, um das Ergebnis zu bekommen, was ich haben wollte. Dann hab ich irgendwie heute auch noch zum Thema WLAN rausgefunden, dass es auf dem Homebrew eine Applikation gibt, die heißt Aircrack NG. Hab ich mal nachgeguckt, ist so ein Web- und WPA-PSK-Cracker, den es irgendwie auf Mac gibt. Hab ich aber noch nicht ausprobiert. Ich hab eigentlich nach ECK gesucht, also ACK im Homebrew. Das kleine Suchtool. Dieses geskopte Grab im Prinzip, oder mit sane-defaults. Kann ich jedem empfehlen, du Wings, wer es nicht kennt.
Wie heißt es?
ACK-ACK. Das macht im Prinzip nichts anderes, außer ganz viele sane-defaults, wenn du Code durchsuchst, die ganzen.files, die ganzen SVN-Verzeichnungen, alles ignorieren und dadurch ist es extrem schnell auch.
Also für Suche in diesem Verzeichnis, in dem sich Code befindet, nach diesem Netto-Inhalt. Ignoriere den ganzen Mist.
Und du musst dich nicht mit Shell Regular Expressions rumschlagen. Feind, Punkt, Prinz. Also es ist gut. Und danach hab ich gesucht, weil in Aircrack auch ACK vorkommt, tauchte das in dieser Liste mit auf. Deswegen passt das jetzt auch noch gerade hier ganz schmofte mit ran. Ja, aber wer ansonsten so Kanalprobleme hat, wenn bei euch das ganze Spektrum voll ist, dann 5 Gigahertz ist die Alternative.
Ja, und wer sich sowieso eine neue Station holen will, meine Standard wäre aber für die aktuelle Airport Extreme, die kann einfach beides und dann hat man auch keine Probleme mehr, sowohl mit altem iPhone oder neuem iPhone. Die hat da irgendwie drei Antennen drin und macht einfach so, wie man will.
Ja, aber dazu muss ich den Schrank erst nach vorne rücken können.
Ich finde mittlerweile, also die Versatilität dieses Gerätes möchte ich gar nicht mehr missen.
Aber ich muss den Schrank erst nach vorne rücken.
Außer dann brechen dann die Streams dann dauernd ab.
Ja, also wir hatten jetzt hier, bevor die Sendung startete, mal wieder das Stream-Abbruchproblem, aber das lag diesmal nicht an uns. Sondern das war definitiv jetzt der nicht erreichbare.
Die anderen waren's, die anderen waren's.
Genau.
Und warum war denn mein Chat weg?
War dein Chat weg?
Dein Chat war auch nicht weg.
Also in dem Augenblick nicht, aber so fünf oder zehn Minuten später war er weg.
Höransagen.
Aber ich glaube, dein Gerät schießt irgendwie Connections weg. Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist. Welches Gerät? Welches auch immer. Keine Ahnung, was du hier für eine Konstellation am Start hast. Hast du denn überhaupt einen Netzwerkplan hier? Hat der Clemens dir keinen gemacht?
Falls die Feuerwehr vorbeiguckt. Gut, soviel zu Wi-Fi, soviel zu Kommandozahlen. Finde ich gut, dass du auf Brew zu sprechen kommst, was ich ja für ein ungemein nützliches Tool halte. Das haben wir sicherlich schon ein paar Mal schon erwähnt. Und weil das so toll ist, machen wir das jetzt gleich nochmal.
Ich hab meine Gläser noch nicht bekommen.
Deine Gläser?
Ja, die gab doch einen Kickstarter für Homebrew. Dann hab ich geplätscht und da gab's eigentlich zwei Pintgläser mit Homebrew-Logo, aber hab ich noch nicht bekommen.
Dafür gibt's ja Homebrew-Emojis, wenn du eine Formule installierst, gibt's Biergläser.
Wo war das gerade mit den Gläsern auf dem... Wo war ich wirklich schon die ganze Zeit seit Beginn dieser Sendung nachdenke, es ist Roddy. Warum trägst du eine Sonnenbrille?
Weil ich sonst nichts sehe. Die hat nämlich geschliffene Gläser. Die andere Brille, die nicht die geschliffenen Sonnenbrille... Äh, die geschliffenen, aber nicht Sonnenbrillengläser.
Setz die Brille wieder auf, du kannst ja doch nicht mal reden, wenn das Ding ab ist.
Äh, die hab ich kaputt getreten.
Oh, ach, jetzt bist du gezwungen, die ganze Zeit mit Sonnenbrille irgendwie rumzulaufen.
Wie machst du das nachts?
Äh, da hab ich zwei Möglichkeiten, nichts zu sehen.
Mit oder ohne Brille nämlich, richtig?
Genau.
Wie kommst du nach Hause?
Mitm Fahrrad. Du, ich hab mir ein Nabendynamo einbauen lassen und eine der helleren Lampen.
Roddy mit Sonnenbrille und Xenonstrahler im Prenzlauer Berg unterwegs. Vorne so eine leichte Hitzespur, wie es auf dem Bürgersteig überall so lange dran ist.
Das ist dann wie bei Grasgeflüster. Man sieht es dann am Horizont hell leuchten und da bin ich dann mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs.
Das sind aber die Schlimmsten. Ich muss das mal kurz noch erwähnen. Als Motorradfahrer ist ja sowieso alles schon mal so ein bisschen heikler auf der Straße. Und wenn dann einem so Hoshis entgegenkommen, die sich da vorne so eine Mörder-LED-Lampe ran geschraubt haben, ist ja alles ganz schön, dass die Leute auch was sehen. Normalerweise sieht man die Fahrräder ja nicht, weil sie gar keine Beleuchtung haben. Aber die Dinge, die diese Mega-Beleuchtung haben, die sorgen nicht nur dafür, dass ich die nicht mehr sehe, weil ich geblendet bin, sondern ich sehe überhaupt gar nichts mehr, weil ich geblendet bin. Und das ist auch nicht gut. Vor allem diese Turi-Segways da so am Brandenburger Tor rum. Da bin ich letztens so einer Segway-Gruppe da entgegengefahren am Ufer, da irgendwie ich hab nichts mehr gesehen und musste anhalten. Das ist doch so unglaublich. Die müsste man eigentlich weglagen, weil wahrscheinlich habe ich jetzt dunkle Punkte auf der Linse. Das geht nicht, Jungs. LEDs sind gefährlich, also blendet die nach unten ab und beleuchtet die Straße und nicht irgendwie den Leuten in die Augen.
Ich glaube, ich kann dich beruhigen, so hell ist die Lampe dann auch nicht.
Ja, die Segway-Dinger, die waren so. Richtig erwischend sind die dran.
Ich hab aber ein Fahrrad und kein Segway. Hat auch nur zwei Räder, aber ist irgendwie anders.
Ja, kommen wir zurück zu Homebrew. Und erwähnen einfach nochmal kurz, für wen das sinnvoll sein könnte. Also diese ganzen netten kleinen Kommando-Zahlen-Tools zu installieren, das ist ja ein heres Ziel. Und da gibt es dann in der Regel auf dem Mac verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Die schlechteste Möglichkeit, die aber häufig gewählt wird, ist, dass man so schaut, ob irgendjemand ein bestimmtes Command-Line-Tool so als Macintosh-Applikation eingepackt hat oder so einen komischen Installer vielleicht dafür gemacht hat, der sich so installiert, wie man das auch sonst kennt. Und dann landet das Teil irgendwo im File-System. Das kann manchmal ganz interessant sein. Das ist auch der richtige Ansatz, wenn jetzt so eine Software, bestimmte Tools, Libraries, Command-Line-Tools braucht, also die zu einer Applikation gehören. Und wenn die Applikation nicht mehr auf dem Rechner ist, brauchst du auch den Kram nicht mehr, dann ist das halt alles mit dem Applikation-Bundle mit drin. Aber wir reden jetzt einfach von richtig so Command-Line-Interfaces installieren.
Ja, machst du nicht hier so ein TataXV irgendwas mit einem Make-Make-Configure-Make-Make-Install?
Ich kann das machen, aber wir wissen alle, wie sportlich das manchmal sein kann. Sportlicher als einem nämlich lieb ist. Dann gibt es diese Hilfetools, die dieses Installieren insofern einfachen, als dass sie für jedes Tool die Anpassungen, die für das jeweilige Betriebssystem release erforderlich sind, gleich mit runterladen, die Patches, diesen ganzen Kompilations-Übersetzungsprozess ausführen. Das an die richtige Stelle linken und dafür sorgen, dass vielleicht auch noch mehrere Versionen gleichzeitig installiert sein können. Da gab es Dawin Ports, das war so das erste, was jetzt Mac Ports heißt.
Nee, Fink war das erste.
Ja, ist richtig, ganz kurz vorher waren die noch.
Das heißt ganz kurz, das waren schon die Größen. Die waren sehr lange aktiv.
Vielleicht gibt es die immer noch so.
Sie waren bis 10.3.
Dawin Ports und Finks mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig gestartet. Auf jeden Fall Fink gibt es aber nicht mehr, oder?
Niemand will Fink.
Kann auch sein, aber...
Friends don't let friends use Fink.
For the sake of completeness, es gab auch noch Fink und es gab Mac Ports und dann kam irgendwann Homebrew.
Und Fink gibt es immer noch.
Und Fink gibt es immer noch, okay. Dritt sich fest.
Jetzt gibt es Homebrew.
Und ich finde Brew bewährt sich. Das ist einfach wirklich cool.
Ja, und das ist schnell und toll. Das Problem ist ja vor allen Dingen, wenn man so einfach so ein Star runterlädt, das auspackt, kompiliert und baut, dass dann wieder zu deinstallen ist halt meistens pain, weil ganz oft gibt es gar keinen make deinstall oder uninstall. Oder man hat den Source schon wieder gelöscht, weil man es in Temp ausgepackt hat oder so. Und das ist ja sowieso natürlich, wem erzähle ich das, die ganzen Linux-Nutzer, die uns zuhören und die ganzen FreeBSD-Nutzer und Nutzerinnen, die wissen natürlich um die magische Kraft des Paketmanagers. Aber auf Mac ist man ja da noch ein bisschen unbedarfter, weil es Apple auch im 21. Jahrhundert nicht für notwendig hält, die Command-Line-Heroes aus eigener Kraft zu nutzen. Obwohl, nee, Moment, MacPods ist ja jetzt Mac OS Forge, oder?
Ja, aber das haben sie mehr oder weniger ausgegliedert und dann macht ihr mal und tschüss, nicht mehr unser Problem.
Es ist halt nicht Teil des Betriebssystems. Und so kann ich auch durchaus verstehen, dass sie da jetzt nicht unbedingt die Notwendigkeit sehen, jedes Command-Line-Tool da in ihren kompletten Bildprozess damit einzubinden. Sie liefern halt ihr Default User-Land aus. Und wenn ein OS-Update kommt, dann ist halt das User-Land auch aktualisiert und fertig. Und wenn du da halt was dazu installieren willst, dann musst du halt sehen, wie du es machst. Mit DaVin Ports geht es relativ easy. DaVin Ports macht es halt so, dass es im Prinzip diese ganze Kommando-Zeilenwelt separat von dem bereits Installierten macht. Das hat vorne Nachteile. Nachteil ist, du installierst ein kleines Perl-Tool, dann wird erstmal Perl runtergeladen und installiert in der aktuellen Version. Dann hast du im Prinzip das Perl, was schon mit dem Betriebssystem kommt und das Perl, was DaVin Ports nochmal compilert hat, nebeneinander.
Ja, es gibt noch mehr so Skript-Sprachen, bei denen das passiert.
Ja, und Ruby und eigentlich alle halt. Also bei DaVin Ports ist halt alles komplett separat. Und Brew macht es anders. Brew scharvenzelt sich da wirklich an das OS ran und nutzt einfach das, was da ist. Und ist irgendwie da mitgesunken. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das machen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ganz pfiffig. Ja, und ein so'n Tool, was man installieren möchte, ist Wry, wenn man UpdateNet benutzen möchte. Genau, es gibt nämlich jetzt einen schicken Commandline-Kline für UpdateNet, den find ich cool. Der wird auch ganz aktiv entwickelt gerade. W-R-Y, den kann man also einfach mit Brew install Wry installieren. Kann man auch normal runterladen. Wry hat so ein schönes kleines Commandline-Interface und das Ding kann seit kurzem multiple Users. Also man muss da so einmal seinen Account mit authentifizieren. Aber wenn man jetzt irgendwie so einen User hat, der eh nur gelocktes, automatisiertes raushauen soll, ja, was weiß ich, volle Stunde, ja. Wenn man will sowas irgendwie automatisieren, dann könnte man es damit machen. Gleich der Hinweis. Es handelt sich bei Vry um ein Objective-C-Command-Line-Kleid. Das ist auch etwas, was man sehr selten findet. Also es ist jetzt nicht so ein Generic-Unix-Teil, sondern das baut echt nur auf dem Mac. Und außerdem hat es jetzt gerade, ich glaube, gestern oder heute sogar mit dem 1.5er-Release auch Petter Support drin. Da kann ich aber noch nicht so viel dazu sagen, weil ich das noch nicht ausprobiert habe. Aber ich vermute mal, dass man jetzt mindestens so in Petter Roms reinschreiben kann und es gehen auch private Nachrichten. Also man hat sozusagen ein Private Messaging und Public Messaging Tool und Chat Tool auf Kommando-Zeilenebene, was halt mit ab.net funktioniert und das ist schon ganz geil.
Ich muss da zum Thema Objective-C und Command Line Tools sagen, das geht unheimlich toll. Also wer wirklich keinen Bock auf GUI hat, aber trotzdem Objective-C probieren will, damit kann man also auch ganz wunderbar arbeiten, um Command Line Tools zu bauen.
Was ist da so wunderbar dran?
Ja, schon allein das Parsing der Argumente geht relativ einfach und du hast halt diese ganzen Container-Klassen und dieses ganze, ich hab halt hier eine objektorientierte Bibliothek, das ist halt was anderes als so ein nacktes C.
Ich finde, Apple könnte mal die Foundation ohne AppKit irgendwie rausrücken für andere OS-er. Also dass man hier diese Standard-Klassen vielleicht können sie die ganz speziellen diese selber behalten wollen, sollen sie halt selber behalten. Also ich will so aber auch Command Line Tools für andere OS-er schreiben können, das wäre eigentlich ganz schick.
Naja, vieles davon ist ja quasi Open Source weil Core Foundation zu einem großen Teil Open Source ist.
Ja, aber dieses andere Projekt, wie heißt das? Das ist, das tut er mir nicht so. Ja, genau.
Gibt's noch?
Keine Ahnung, aber die haben bestimmt keine Blogs und kein Nix.
Das ist seit Jahren im erweiterten Zombie-Modus, also das ist so, das geht nicht tot und das wird...
Lebt aber auch schon lange nicht mehr, genau.
Es ist auch nicht mehr so richtig lebendig.
Heißt, zum Thema Command Line Tools gibt's auch im Homebrew zu installieren und gehört für mich auf jede Kiste, wo ich eine Shell hab, Tree. Erkennt es nicht?
Ich kenn es noch, ich bin gerade überrascht.
Das hab ich irgendwie vor langer Zeit auch beim Pair-Programm tatsächlich mal bei jemandem gesehen und dachte mir, boah, das ist ja mal voll praktisch und hab dann gleich...
Was macht das denn?
Das müsste ich dir jetzt hier mal kurz sagen.
Da listet einfach deine Direktories halt so als ASCII Tree auf.
Und zwar in schön und du kannst halt mit Level auch noch sagen, wie tiefer da so gehen soll. Also Level 2 und dann hier halt so...
Ja, ich hab's gerade selber installiert.
Na, das ist auf OSX nicht dabei. Jetzt hast du alles. Jetzt kriegst du hier deinen ganzen Tree gerade. Alles, was in deinem Home sich so versteckt. Schön schnell. Ja, also auch die Library.
Also er hat das in zwei Sekunden gebaut. Das ist wirklich irgendwie...
Also es empfiehlt sich die Option Tree minus groß L und dann eine Levelzahl und dann kann man das Ganze vielleicht mal auf Level 1, äh 2, 2 ist gut, ja.
Ok, bei FreeBest ist es aber auch nicht Default, also ist es nicht so ein ultra Default-Tool.
Nee, aber es ist wirklich... Also wenn man sich so auf Servern und manchmal ist so ein LS oder wie auch immer ist halt dann doch nicht genug, um so einen Überblick zu kriegen. Man will nicht dreimal durch irgendwelche Verzeichnisbäume durchbranchen, um dann irgendwie das File...
So, jetzt machen wir doch mal ein bisschen hier Command-Line-Hose runter. Wir können ja mal so ein bisschen gucken, was habt ihr denn so installiert?
Was haben wir denn so installiert?
Was sind denn so eure Hand, eure Werkzeuge? Also man ist ja Power-User und man hat so seinen Mac und er freut sich der GUI und der tollen Ups, aber dann gibt es ja immer wieder diese Momente, da muss man in den Keller.
Ich lebe im Keller.
Aber sind nicht alles so auf?
MTR.
Unterrattern, MTR. Hab ich auch. Wärts noch?
Hab ich auch, klar.
Haben wir alle.
4 von 4 MTR.
Das ist ein besseres Trace Route, was einem halt zeigt, wie eine Route zu irgendeinem anderen Server.
Auch so ein bisschen grafisch aufbereitet, sortiert und schickt und malt über sich drüber und gibt Updates und Prozente und Zeug und alles. So Curses-mäßig, genau.
Ja, macht vor allem alles parallel. Also der Pink nicht hintereinander an, sondern alles parallel. Deshalb man sieht relativ schnell, wo was liegt. So, wer hat noch was?
Ich hab CSSHX, das ist ein Tool, was ich ganz viel benutze. Und CSSHX, das ist ein Tool, damit kannst du halt sagen, CSSHX, dann drei Hostnames und dann teilt er dir die Terminals so schön gleichmäßig über den Screen auf und du hast einen Master Terminal, wo du die Commands auf alle drei Terminals broadcasten kannst, sozusagen. Das benutze ich halt schon öfters mal, um mal kurz auf allen Application-Servern mich mal einzuloggen und zu gucken, was ist denn da so Phase? Liegt auf allen das gleiche Pfeil rum und so, wenn ich mal selber so ein bisschen nachforschen will und jetzt nicht manuell 23 Shells aufmachen kann. Das verbindet sich sehr gut, wenn man dann Alias macht. Zum Beispiel, wenn man weiß, man hat sechs App-Server oder sowas oder drei Datenbank-Server oder was auch immer, dann kann man sich so ein schönes Alias machen, CSSHX und dann die sechs Maschinen und dann muss man nur einen Command tippen und kriegt dann hier so gleich so brrrrramm irgendwie sechs Terminals, ein rotes Master-Command-Terminal und kannst da so schön die Welt kontrollieren. Also CSSHX hat mir schon sehr viel Freude gebracht. ITerm, wer ITerm benutzt, da gibt es auch dieses Broadcast to all Open Windows Feature, aber ich finde ITerm so scheiße, dass ich das verweigere zu benutzen und da ist CSSHX mein Ersatz. Jetzt sagt einer im Chat zurecht auch TMAX. Das wäre auch gleich ein nächstes Command Line Tool, was ich erwähnen würde. TMAX kann das auch. TMAX ist im Prinzip so, dass das coole Screen, also wer Screen kennt, wie beschreibt man Screen? Was macht ein Screen? Ein Screen macht mehrere virtuelle, ja, so ein Screen sorgt dafür, ein TMI-Multiplexer, oder könnte man so sagen? Ja, so ein etwa. Also man kann halt einen neuen virtuellen Screen starten, da Programme was auch immer ausführen und dann den Screen in den Hintergrund tun und...
Genau, es ist einfach mehrere Terminal-Multiplexer, da trifft es eigentlich ganz gut. Dann hat es vor allem den riesigen Vorteil, dass wenn man auf einer Remote-Maschine ist und da ein Screen startet, also sozusagen nicht jetzt auf dem eigenen Rechner, sondern man lockt sich in der Ferne irgendwo ein, startet Screen, dann kann man sich dann halt ausloggen oder man kann diesen Screen detachen.
Das ist die VN-Werder-Sheldz.
Na ja, nicht ganz, ja.
Na doch, eigentlich schon.
Aber deswegen heißt das Team Max das Terminal-Multiplexer bestimmt. Das macht alles Sinn jetzt.
Das heißt bestimmt, das ist das, was auf der Webseite oben drüber steht.
Ich war noch nie auf der Team Max Webseite.
Team Max ist ein Terminal-Multiplexer, was soll das auch sonst heißen?
Hab ich noch nie so drüber nachgedacht. Aber wer immer Screen benutzt hat und Screen oft benutzt, guckt euch mal Team Max an, das ist wirklich tausendmal cooler als Screen jemals war oder sein wird. Also Team Max, wer so einen Use-Case oft hat, so genau dieses Terminal-Multiplex und so, benutzt Team Max. Und da kann man auch in mehrere Sessions da rein, Commands rein, broadcasten. Aber ich sag euch, am Ende des Tages ist dieses CSSHX, das ist so trivial, da muss man nicht irgendwie Shortcuts und irgendwelche komplexen Sachen erstmal lernen. Also bei Team Max muss man sich auch erstmal ein bisschen einarbeiten. Bei CSSHX sagt man einfach CSSHX, drei Hostnames bangen und es funktioniert einfach.
Braucht man aber auch wirklich jetzt nur, wenn man dieses spezifische Problem hat, dass man mehrere Server, die weitgehend identisch sind, ist eher so ein Hosting-Ding.
Ach jetzt komm, aber Team Max an sich ist halt auch wirklich, also das benutze ich auch sehr gerne und viel. Und da kann man sich wirklich schön austoben und es macht auch nicht wuff wuff, wenn man einen Command falsch eintippt und kommt auch mit Encodings und mit Shell Resets und so anderen Sachen klar, die Screen irgendwie noch nie richtig irgendwie konnte. Dennis, was hast du?
W-Geld bräuchte ich ab und zu. Ich weiß, da gibt es auch Standard-Sachen, wie FTP und Curl, aber ich nutze dann manchmal brauchen wir einfach W-Geld.
Manchmal brauchen wir einfach W-Geld, das ist richtig.
Wobei das FTP auf dem Mac eigentlich ganz cool ist, weil das ist das FTP von NetBSD, dieses Luke... FTP, genau, das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool, weil es kann auch HTTP und alles, aber es kann kein... Nee doch, V6 kann das sogar auch, aber er kann kein HTTPS und so. Also wenn man ein bisschen Special-Features braucht, dann W-Geld, weil da zu Not kann man seine HTTPS auch von Hand an die Optionszeile schreiben und so weiter und so fort.
Also ich muss ja sagen, Curl ist eigentlich so zum Web-Debuggen, das finde ich cooler, aber W-Geld ist halt so dieser Convenience. Bei Curl muss man immer über den Kleinen Ohr, Großes Ohr, Pfeil nehmen, kein Pfeil nehmen irgendwie. Und dieser eine Denkprozess, der da nötig ist jedes Mal, weil ich es mir nicht merken kann, der hat auch dazu geführt, dass ich mir ein W-Geld installiert habe.
Und dann hab ich noch Parallel BZip 2 und PIC-Z. PIC-Z ist das Gegenstück zu G-Zip. Und zwar ist es Parallel G-Zip. Und P-BZip 2 ist halt das Parallel BZip. Die können einfach auf allen deinen Cores in Parallel irgendwie compressionen. Und wenn du mal größere Sachen komprimieren musst und so weiter, oder zum Server hin und her schieben und das brauchst. Und du hast wieder mal irgendwie dein Engine X, hat mal wieder 30 Gigabyte Lockfile und so, du willst die mal schnell haben. Dann kommt gerade BZip, das war geil von der Kompression, aber wenn es wirklich viel ist, braucht er ewig. Also Parallel BZip 2 und dann geht es ab wie nix.
Das stimmt. Und es macht echt klein.
Also es gibt noch XZ, was ich aber nur installiert habe, weil ich mal irgendwo so eine Datei her hatte.
Ja, das sind jetzt die neueren, die noch besser sind als BZip 2.
Die XZ komprimiert war, deswegen gibt es, es gibt halt diesen XZ, wie auch immer man den ausspricht.
Ja, aber gibt es den auch schon einen Parallel?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Weil Parallel ist jetzt mal angesagt, auf jeden Fall bei den Tools.
Vielleicht haben die neueren Packer das schon eingebaut, weil sie inzwischen wissen, dass Rechner mehr als ein Core haben. Ich weiß es nicht.
Weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, was macht der nur, besonders klein? Oder ist er bekannt dafür, das schnell zu sein?
Du, keine Ahnung. Also da kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen. Ich sage nur, ich habe ihn hier installiert.
Ja, ich glaube, die Kompression ist noch viel besser. Das ist jetzt auch diesen neuen LZM-A-Standard und so.
30% smaller than G-SYP und 15% smaller than G-SYP II.
Ja. Alle paar Jahre kommt ja da was Neues und so.
Aber das stimmt. B-SYP II habe ich auch installiert.
Nicht B-SYP, den hast du sowieso. Parallel B-SYP.
Meine ich auch.
Ich habe noch, das klingt jetzt komisch, wenn ich das sage, aber ich habe noch Git mit Homebrew installiert.
Damit du den neuesten hast.
Wieso sollte das komisch klingen?
Weil das, was bei Xcode dabei ist, ist immer meistens ein bisschen angestaubt. Deswegen habe ich mir Git direkt über Brew installiert. Da kommt, wenn ich glaube, da kommt auch gleich ein Subversion mit.
Was ist denn das aktuelle Git?
Also das von Xcode kann ich dir sagen.
1724. Ne, 1724.
Ich habe 1796.
1823 ist das.
Ja, wir sind schon bei 18 noch was. Muss mal Brew Update sagen. Zwischendurch auch.
Hab ich. Aber das ist nicht installiert hier.
Wenn du es über Brew installierst, bekommst du immer relativ flott. So mit einem Tag oder zwei Verzöger.
Ja, aber welche Vorteile bringt das mir?
Ich hatte irgendwann mal Probleme mit dem eingebauten Git von Xcode. Und hab deswegen das Git von Brew installiert. Und seitdem ist es drauf.
Also ich kann das auch nur empfehlen, tatsächlich ein aktuelles Git zu fahren, weil die da schon sehr viel optimieren und rumschrauben und verbessern. Und cooleres Command, also ich meine diese Rapper-Skripte, also dieses Git-Command ist ja so ein Rapper-Skript für ganz viele kleine Git-Commands. Und da ist halt auch so Convenience-Features sind da ganz viel hinzugefügt noch. Und das lohnt sich auch, das Change-Log tatsächlich zu lesen. Das ist recht angenehm zu konsumieren teilweise. Da gibt es ja dieses Git-SCM dort kommen. Das ist sowieso eine relativ coole Seite für Git.
Das ist die Seite für Git. Ich glaube, das ist die offizielle Homepage davon.
Naja, es ist nicht die offizielle, weil das ist eigentlich von einem Typen, der mal bei, also der bei GitHub arbeitet, der hat dieses Buch geschrieben hier pro Git. Und er hat auch diese Webseite gemacht. Und die ist nicht offiziell, ist vom Git-Team. Aber der hat das so gut gemacht, dass es irgendwie jetzt so miteinander verschmolzen haben, hab ich den Eindruck.
Quasi-Standard.
Quasi-Standard. Also das ist auf jeden Fall die Seite, weil du kannst dieses Pro-Git-Buch da auch kostenlos lesen. Also die Dokumentation ist wirklich fantastisch gut. Ah, okay, wenn man im Chat meint, das ist mittlerweile offiziell. Also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es eine Zeit lang nicht offiziell war. Aber ja, kann man mal auf jeden Fall machen. Und ich kann das auch nur empfehlen, da immer mal wieder so ein aktuelles Gitzig aus dem Homebrew zu ziehen. Hat sich bisher, bin ich da noch in keinem Fettnapf gelandet. Und, ja, irgendwie, was wollte ich denn gerade hier noch eigentlich für ein Command-Line-Tool einwerfen? Achso, ja, ich brauch gar nicht so wahnsinnig viele Command-Line-Tools, seitdem ich ja Z-Shell benutze. Da ist nämlich schon echt viel tolles Zeug mit dabei. Und für Leute, die immer noch nicht Z-Shell benutzen und immer noch Bash, ey, letztens ist mir ja was krasses passiert, ne? Geh ich auf so eine Amazon EC2-Instance oder irgendein Ubuntu, ich glaube, das war auf Amazon, und dann tippe ich ein Command, dann ist es falsch eingetippt und dann kommt nicht Command not found, sondern dann rotzt mir da so ein Python-Skript, so ein Error-Trace irgendwie in die Shell und sagt, dieses Command ist nicht implementiert und dann haben diese Ubuntu, sei es jetzt von den Amazon EC2-Images, oder irgendjemand hat sozusagen das Bash-Command gewrappt mit einem Python-Skript, was irgendwie einen Error wirft, wenn das Command nicht da ist. Diese Linux-Leute, die haben doch echt ein Ding an Wirsing, ey. Also, was ich bei diesem Ubuntu schon für Scheiß gesehen hab, die rappen auch, die rappen wirklich alle möglichen Standard-Unix-Gnue-Tools mit noch mal eigenem Scheiß obendrauf. Wieso denn das? Ja keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Die rappen auch, war das die Bash, die sie auch sowieso schon rappen und es ist da nicht die richtige Bash, sondern was auch immer. Furchtbar, egal. Ja, keine Ahnung, was die da machen. Die rauchen komisches Zeug. Da in diesem Gnuland. Aber egal. Z-Shale ist einfach, also ich hab echt lange, ich hab's auch schon mal hier in dem Podcast erwähnt, aber wer Z-Shale noch nicht benutzt, der ist wirklich irgendwie, dem kann man auch nicht mehr helfen. Und ich pastee hier mal einen Link rein in den Chat. Da ist so eine schöne Präsentation bei ZSH is cooler than your shell. Und die ist jetzt nicht komplett. Also mir würden da noch einige andere Sachen einfallen, aber er erwähnt da schon ein paar, so einige ziemlich coole Features. Auch einige, die ich noch nicht kannte. Und ich kann das nur empfehlen, sich meine Z-Shale anzugucken. Ich hatte das auch schon mal hier erwähnt, dass die im Default-Zustand, wenn man die sich so installiert, ich glaube bei USX ist es sogar dabei, aber auch eine alte Version kann man sich auch schön aus einem Brew nochmal installieren. Ja, ich glaube die bei USX, die ist jetzt auch nicht viel älter. Also, aber wir wollen ja alle neue. Neuer ist besser. Und die kommt halt im Default-Zustand, kommt man jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig weit. Man muss da schon so ein bisschen ein paar Config-Options machen. Und das hab ich schon gemacht. Und hier paste ich jetzt auch nochmal in den Chat für die Show Notes meine.files auf github.com/huckel/.filesund da könnt ihr euch mal inspirieren lassen. Und wenn ihr einfach meine ZSH-Konfig da übernehmt, dann kommt das schon mal weit und könnt so die coolen Goodies alle mal benutzen. Und sowieso an der Stelle könnte man gleich mal empfehlen, wer sowieso mit seinen Shell-Tools so ein bisschen am Start ist und Konfig-Files macht und so, empfehle ich auch schwer, da ein Git-Repository draus zu machen und die auch einfach auf GitHub oder sonst wo hin zu schieben. Das lohnt sich total, auch wenn man mal auf dem Server ist, eine Shell-Installiert-Dot-File-Repository auschecken und man ist gleich zu Hause auf dem Server. Kann ich schwer empfehlen und ist halt auch echt cool.
Du checkst die dann direkt ins Home-Verzeichnis aus?
Ne, ich symlinke sie dann. Also ich check sie in mein Dot-Files-Verzeichnis und symlinke dann die Verzeichnisse, die ich auf dem Server brauche. Also ich...
Vielleicht hast du ein Repro für deine wichtigsten...
Dot-Files, ja. Also im Prinzip, da ist jetzt aktuell wirklich nur Wim und ZSH drin, aber...
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Aber damit bin ich halt in wenigen Sekunden, sobald ich einen Git habe, habe ich auch meine Dot-Files da und dann funktioniert mein Wim, wie er funktionieren soll und dann funktioniert meine Schere, wie sie funktionieren.
Du, Tim, wenn du die ersten Dutzend Git Repositories angelegt hast, dann machst du es nicht mehr ohne. Weil es ist so einfach und es rettet dir so viel den Arsch, dass du irgendwann das Gefühl hast, warum ist eigentlich nicht das ganze Dateisystem mit Git Repository oder so.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Also das ist so, ich habe ja auch irgendwann mal gesagt, dass ich so manche Finanzsachen halt auch so, wenn es da so PDFs sind, die da auflaufen, halt auch einfach in Git Repository reinschmeiße, nur um zu sehen, was sich wann wie geändert hat und dazugekommen ist.
Ja, also ich muss auch sagen, ich war ja früher Heavy-Cornshell-User und die Z-Shell ist ja im Wesentlichen, glaube ich, eine Reimplementierung oder zumindest basiert das viel aus Cornshell. Äh, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Also musst du da Rehash tippen um...
Ich glaube nicht.
Weil das muss man bei der Z-Shell, weißt du, Z-Shell, mostly, ja doch, mostly, closely resembles Cornshell, doch, genau.
Ja, das war ganz cool.
Also ist auch Bash-compatible und kann als Drop-in-Replacement für Bash...
Lustigerweise habe ich die Cornshell damals... Oh man, habe ich die Geschichte schon mal erzählt?
Ne.
Wahrscheinlich. Doch, ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal erzählt. Aber ich erzähle es einfach nochmal. Also damals in Klondike, ne?
Als die Straße noch staubig.
Und jeder Computer, mit dem man arbeitete.
Jetzt in den Cricket Sound hier machen.
Damals, kurz vor der Erfindung des Automobils. Ich musste mal... Also ich war ja so ein Frühunixer oder vielmehr Xenixer gewesen.
Also...
War ich da bei Anfang? 89 oder so. Und dann musste ich mal unter DOS was programmieren. MS-DOS. X-Windows und so und DOS. Genau. Und dann dachte ich mir schon so, oh weia. Damals gab es irgendwie so ein... Doch, da haben wir Schmutz-Rolli-Red. Jetzt erinnere ich mich wieder. Deswegen mache ich es kurz. MKS Toolkit war damals so die Rettung. Das machte nämlich so ein komplettes Unix-Environment unter DOS. Das war so ganz early on. Ich meine, unter DOS, das war wirklich eine Leistung. Dass sie das überhaupt geschafft haben, so ein komplettes Unix-Userland der damaligen Zeit unter DOS zum Laufen zu kriegen. So dass ich eigentlich nie... Also ich habe einfach nicht das Gefühl, jemals wirklich unter DOS gearbeitet zu haben, weil ich eigentlich immer in diesem Unix-Environment gearbeitet habe. Aber da bin ich so ein bisschen auf Cornshell gekommen. Komischerweise habe ich das nicht wieder aufgegriffen. Aber wenn Z-Chall wirklich so der Nachfolger ist, guck ich mir vielleicht nochmal an.
Also Z-Chall, guck dir mal die Präsi an. Und das ist so convenient und so schön. Und so ganz viele Sachen, die man bei Bash halt mit großem Voodoo-Magic-Zauber irgendwie noch anstellen muss, die sind da einfach schon da und müssen nur angeschaltet werden. Also gerade so Navigationssachen completion. Das kann halt nicht nur das erste Command completen, sondern es kann, wenn du Mahntipps completedst, dir die Mahnpages, wenn du Git-Pull tippst und dann tapptappt, dann completedst dir alle Dash-Dash-Options für dieses Command und so. Also es ist so richtig schön drin so. Sie baden gerade ihre Hände drin, so fühlt sich das an. Also es ist so irgendwie...
Ganz geschmeidig, seifig.
Wow, irgendwie dieser Stuhl erledigt sich hier, glaube ich, gerade.
Ja, du erledigst den Stuhl.
Oh ne, der Stuhl erledigt den Huckel.
Ist da was gebrochen? Bleibt es auch hinten irgendwie eine Schiene raus oder so? Kannst du mal diesen Metall da ziehen.
Gucken Knochen raus.
Ich gucke mir das mal an, ich geh mal kurz.
Ja, haben wir unseren Command-Line-Tool-Schwanzvergleich schon fertig?
Nein, ich vermisse ja noch mindestens ein Tool.
Ja, schließ los.
Also ich finde, das ist mit das Erste, was man installieren sollte, aber ich nenne es jetzt als Letztes. Sondern da noch mal ein paar andere Sachen, die ich noch so habe. Ich habe glaube ich auch einen etwas anderen Fokus als ihr. Was aber glaube ich bei euch auch installiert ist, was ihr nur übersehen habt, ist Nmap. Wirklich nicht.
Also ich brauche ein Nmap sehr selten. Hab ich gerade hier, sehe ich es gerade nicht.
Telnet.
Na ich hab tatsächlich ein Netz-Start halt. Also ich lock mich auf der Kiste ein.
Nein, auf dem Rechner.
Wo du nicht rankommst oder nicht rankommst.
Telnet.
Den Use-Case hab ich tatsächlich relativ selten, dass ich irgendwie bei fremden Kisten gucken müsste.
Das müssen nicht unbedingt fremde Kisten sein. Es kann nur sein, du kommst nicht rein und du weißt nicht warum. Und dann so, scheiße hab ich da Screen Sharing an, hab ich da SSH an, was hab ich denn da überhaupt angemacht? Grad wenn ich in so einem Paranoia-Modus bin und was weiß ich, mein Laptop auf eine Konferenz getragen habe und erstmal wieder alle Logins ausgeklickt, Firewall an, so Stealth-Modus. Und dann steht der woanders und ich will von außen ran und dann einfach nmap. Also ich hab das auf jeden Fall immer installiert, das wollte ich dazu sagen. Ansonsten hab ich halt noch ne ganze Menge Zeug.
Aber was ist denn deine Standard nmap-Command-Line? Die würde ich jetzt auch gerne mal wissen.
Nmap-Hostname.
Das glaub ich meine Standard-Command-Line. Weil da gibt's ja auch Options wie...
Ich bin kein Nmap Wizard. Ich schlag mal nach, wenn ich was Spezifisches brauch.
Nee, also meine Network-Debugging-Tools sind tatsächlich netstat, netcat, telnet und ja.
Ja, auch gerade so Unterscheidungen mit was läuft da über V4, was läuft da auf V6. Das ist auch alles ganz praktisch.
Ja genau, aber das sind eben so, ich mach das halt immer eher auf Kisten, die meins sind, wo ich mich auch einloggen kann, wo ich aber trotzdem nicht weiß, was da jetzt gerade alles so konkret eine Socke nach außen hat. Aber netcat und netstat, die sind ja immer installiert. Oder auf dem Linux gibt es da netstat? Ja, doch, netstat gibt es auch.
Ansonsten hab ich halt noch ganz viel Medienkonvertierungen, weil damit bin ich halt die ganze Zeit beschäftigt. Also ffmpeg, mp4, v2, id3, v2. Also alles, was man hier so für Medien-Dateien klimmbim braucht. Und natürlich den IQ, mit dem ich mir halt v6 mache, wenn es kein v6 gibt. Ja, aber das tue, weil ich der Meinung bin, dass es jeder installieren sollte und wo auch wirklich selbst die Leute, die jetzt bisher nur Ohrensausen bekommen haben von dieser ganzen Diskussion und wenn ihr wirklich mal Homebrew installiert habt, da geht ihr auf die Homebrew-Seite, ist ganz einfach. Eine Zahl eingegeben, zack habt ihr Homebrew installiert und das erste Tool, was ihr dann installiert, ist Fortune. Weil ich finde ohne Fortune ist auch kein Unix und ohne Unix ist auch nichts. Fortune ist einfach the Tool. Das ist einfach für mich der Inbegriff von Computer History und das ist einfach geil. Du gibst einfach Fortune ein.
Wenn du nicht mehr weiter weißt, Fortune.
Nee, ist auch geil. Du kannst auch Fortune-S machen. Dann kriegst du immer was Kurzes. Das schreibst du dir am besten gleich in deine Bescherzee oder deinen Punkt Login oder was. Immer wenn du dich einloggst, kriegst du halt einen coolen Spruch. Du kannst auch mit Optionen explizit Optiones auswählen oder Optiones rauslassen, je nachdem wie du es lieber hast.
Dann kann ich mir endlich das Pfeffel-Fortune-File installieren.
Ja, man kann auch andere Fortune-Files, aber ich finde einfach die Standard-Fortunes auch geil. Und vor allem jetzt habe ich gerade einfach mal fortgegeben und was kommt? Einstein, wenn gefragt, um Radio zu beschreiben, hat er gesagt, du siehst, Wire-Telegraph ist ein Kind einer sehr, sehr langen Kat. Du ziehst seinen Haar in New York und sein Kopf klingelt in Los Angeles. Du sendest Signale hier, sie bekommen sie dort. Die einzige Differenz ist, dass es keine Kat gibt. Großartig, oder? Und da muss man nicht im Web suchen, da gibt man einfach Fortune eins. Und ich hab schon Tage und Nächte damit verbracht, einfach immer nur wieder Fortune einzugeben. Das ist einfach ein Füllhorn von Großartigen.
Hast du schon jemanden mit Fortune zweimal gesehen? Ja. Auf verschiedenen Kisten wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ich mach das schon ein bisschen länger mit dem Fortune. Ich bin Spezialexperte.
Hast du hier den Lock-In mit Fortune, dass beim Lock-In immer der Fortune kommt?
Hier hab ich's gerade komischerweise nicht, aber ich glaub, da hab ich's. Nee, doch, hier hab ich's auch. Nächstes Terminal.
But Officer, he's not drunk. I saw his fingers twitch.
Ja, ist total großartig. Installiert, Fortune. Und ein Nethack könnt ihr auch gleich installieren.
Und es gibt auch, wie ich gerade schon sagte, von FIFA zwei Fortune-Files und zwar die gesammelten Werke aus dem Usenet. Einmal Produktempfehlung von FIFA, haben wir auch schon mal verlinkt und zum anderen, ich glaube, seine besten Sprüche aus dem Usenet und das, also für FIFA-Fans unter euch, das kann durchaus mal noch mal ein Schmunzler zwischendurch bereiten. Also wirklich ganz großartige Sprüche dabei.
Wie FIFA sagen würde, what could possibly go wrong.
Ja, warte mal, ich kann mal versuchen, für die, die es jetzt nicht, also unsere unsere Mobile-Max-Block-Suche, die funktioniert bestimmt hervorragend. Und wahrscheinlich findet man binnen kürzester Zeit auch die Erwähnung von... Ah, ich hab sie hier. Ich hab sie für euch.
Pass auf.
Die gibt's irgendwie, genau, Fortune-Mod. Irgendwie kann man sich dieses Fortune-File auch runterladen. Das müsste man selber rausfinden. Hier ist der Fefe von Leitner. Ich glaube, das ist der erste und dann FVL-Vendor, das sind die Produktempfehlungen oder Produktbewertungen. Und die sind, die sind wirklich ganz großartig. Na gut, so viel also dazu. Fortune hab ich tatsächlich auf den BSD-Kisten, also bei BSD ist es immer installiert, ne?
Aber ob es immer noch so ist, weiß ich nicht. Wir haben ja auch eine riesengroße Datei dieses Fortunes. Ich glaube, bei einem Dollar konnte man sich sogar ausruhen, ob man es haben will oder nicht, weil die Dictionaries so groß waren.
Na, die sollen noch besser groß sein, also.
Ja, muss man halt doch mal mitinstallieren, dauert und so.
Aber so groß wie eine Bitcoin-Blockchain sind sie bestimmt nicht.
Das ist schon lustig hier.
So, sind wir jetzt aus der Oper-Phase raus, oder?
Ja, also meine Productivity-Tools sind damit schon abgefeiert. Also Wim, ZSH, Git, was hatte ich vorhin noch? Tree und WeGit und das war's dann eigentlich.
Ich hab noch so ein paar Sachen installiert, die ich aber nur so ab und zu mal benutze, so zum Rumspielen. Also das eine ist Doxygen, das ist so ein Doku-Tool, was, wenn man das benutzt, ganz schöne Dokumentation erzeugt. Dann so ein paar Sprachdinger. Einen Erlang hab ich installiert, ich hab einen Go installiert, ein Node hab ich installiert.
Dafür ist es auch schön, wenn man mal solche kleinen Programming-Invariements, gerade so diese VMs, benutzen möchte, wie Node oder Erlang. Das hat schnell damit an Start gebracht.
Dann, was ich eigentlich immer installiere, aber eigentlich nie benutze, ist Midnight Commander.
Du hast es gesagt.
So wie Norton Commander. Nur auf einem System, das es eigentlich nicht nötig hätte. Also ich meine, damals unter DOS war der Norton Commander ja irgendwie die Rettung in Seenot. Heutzutage braucht man es eigentlich nicht mehr.
Gut, dann können wir ja diesen Teil beenden. Liebe Show Notes, neues Kapitel. Wir machen weiter mit...
Mit?
Vorhin hatten wir ja Rai angesprochen und damit ja auch ab.net angesprochen. Ich wollte eigentlich dann auf Twitter umschalten. Und zwar drohte ja bei Twitter seit längerem schon das Abschalten der API 1.0. Da hatten sie ja schon mal einen Termin genannt. Der ist ja dann verstrichen und nichts passierte. Und jetzt haben sie wohl auch nochmal ganz klar gemacht, dass sie das auch noch ein weiteres Mal nach hinten geschoben haben. Das aktuelle Datum sei jetzt der 11. Juni. Wo dann wirklich die 1.0 abgeschaltet wird. Interessant ist, dass Echo Phone, der eigentlich schon aufgegebene Mac Twitter client, jetzt dann doch wieder resurrected wurde von dem Developer. Aus mir nicht näher bekannten Gründen, vermutlich Geld. Und ja, nicht nur das. Er hat das Teil dann auch gleich in den App Store gestellt. Also da war es nämlich vorher nicht. Und jetzt kann man halt im App Store sich auch Echo Phone wieder kaufen, wenn man will.
Also es war ja schon mal im App Store, oder? Also ich habe es doch über den App Store gekauft, bilde ich mir ein.
Also ich habe bisher zumindest keine App Store Version benutzt. Und kann sein, dass es auch eine App Store Version gab. Da erinnere ich mich jetzt aber nicht so dran.
Echo Phone von Twitter, am 3. Dezember 2011 gekauft im App Store. 2011?
Dann müsstest du ja ein Update bekommen.
Ja, habe ich auch. Und da habe ich mich auch sehr gefreut drüber. Genau, das war nämlich, was ich vorhin auch erwähnen wollte. Siehst du mal. Siehst du mal. Ja, habe ich mich auch sehr gefreut über dieses Update.
Genau. Für mich bedeutet das natürlich nochmal alle Accounts eingeben, aber das macht man nicht alles. Dass es da keine bessere Methode gibt. Ja, es hat sich nicht viel verändert. Sie haben einfach im Wesentlichen das Ding so auf die neue API geändert und so ein paar alte Dienste rausgeschmissen, ein paar Bugs gefixt. Im Wesentlichen ist immer noch das Gleiche, was vielleicht auch ganz gut ist.
Genau, also ich, mittlerweile bin ich bei Veränderungen bei Software echt vorsichtig geworden. Die zu embracen, diese Veränderungen. Und Echo Phone nach wie vor ist, ich komm irgendwie an andere Twitter-Klines irgendwie nicht ran. Der ist nicht perfekt, aber...
Es gibt keinen wirklich guten.
Es gibt keinen wirklich guten und von denen nicht wirklich guten ist der noch der beste, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, komischerweise kam Tweetbot da auch nicht ran.
Nee, nee, never ever.
Tweetbot war mir zu teuer und ich hab das ganze Twittern auf dem Mac quasi aufgegeben. So wie ich eigentlich auch das ganze Twittern aufgegeben hab, aber ich lass nur am Rande.
Bist du jetzt auch ADN-only?
Nee, ich bin nicht ADN-only, aber so... Ich bin Twitter fast read-only.
Sag mal, aber dieses Kiwi, da passiert jetzt auch gerade nichts mehr, ne?
Ah und, und, und, und, ich hab ja die 100% geknackt, ne? Ich hab mehr ADN-Follower als Twitter-Follower inzwischen.
Ja, das ist bei mir noch nicht so weit.
Von ein paar Tagen.
Ich hab Halbzeit.
Wie viel waren's denn?
Na, beide Male so um die 1,8.
Wow.
Ist ja schon richtiger, ist ja schon richtig.
Celebrity. Ja, Celebrität. Ich hab jetzt auch diese, diese tolle...
Eure Celebrität.
Dieses tolle Angebot, wo du mir auch unterbreite, dass ich jetzt so 100 Invite-Links und so bekomme, weil...
Ja, ich auch, aber ich hab's immer noch nicht wahrgemacht und die unters Volk gestreut.
Ich hab die jetzt einfach noch mal rausgeschoben. Ich mein, das klickt jetzt eh keiner mehr an, aber das ist ja okay. Nee, ich hab Halbzeit... Ey, ist ja sogar genau Halbzeit, oder? Naja, nicht ganz. Also, 2.7 hab ich auf ab.net und 5.4 auf Twitter. Also, da ist erst 50 Prozent erreicht. Ich steig auch erst vollständig auf ab.net um, wenn das 100 Prozent ist. Wenn die ganzen, wenn die ganzen Twitter-Bots, die die anderen 2.700 ausmachen, auch auf ab.net gelandet sind. Das heißt aber, du hast 1.800 echte Follower, weil die Bots ja nicht auf ab.net wollen.
Also bei ADN sind es jetzt fast 2.000.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Bots da nicht hin wollen. Auf jeden Fall sind sie da noch nicht so.
Ja, genau. Vielleicht wollen sie da hin, aber sie sind da nicht.
Ja, was kostenlos ist, das zieht das natürlich auch an. Also das Spam-Problem wird sicherlich da auch irgendwann einschlagen, auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Ja, aber durch diese 40, ich kann nur 40 Leuten folgen.
Wieso zum Spam-Wort muss ja keinem folgen. Und besser noch, du kannst ja sogar noch in der Regel auch noch private Nachrichten schicken und so.
Mal sehen, wie sie das in den Griff kriegen.
Wenn es soweit ist. Erstmal müssen sie relevant genug werden, dass die Spammer da überhaupt hin wollen.
Ja, gab es da eigentlich irgendwelche Software-Updates? Hab jetzt schon lange nicht mehr geguckt. Also Api, Rill dieses oder so.
Wenn Tim schaut, können wir...
Achso, es gab ja, genau, es gibt ja diese up.net Passport-Up. Die könnte man dann noch mal erwähnen.
Was macht die denn?
Was macht die denn? Naja, also up.net Passport for iOS kann man sich halt auf sein iPhone laden oder auch iPad vermutlich. Weiß nicht genau. Und ist im Wesentlichen erstmal, wenn das Ding hochkommt, ein Verzeichnis aller Up.net-enableden Programme. Also du kriegst quasi so ein iOS-Verzeichnis. Aber das ist nicht der einzige Anwendungszweck, sondern du kannst mit der Up auch mal so eben dein Profil managen. Allerdings nur für einen Account. Also ausgerechnet die Up ist nicht multi-Account-fähig. Das finde ich ein bisschen schade. Aber für die meisten Leute, die jetzt primär nur einen Account nutzen, ist es schon mal ganz sinnvoll. Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, gibt es halt so eine Authentication-SDK, mit der man dann sozusagen die Authentication einer Up über diese Up machen kann. Deswegen heißt sie auch Passport, weil die quasi, wenn du dann mit dieser Up dich einmal in dein Account eingeloggt hast und du hast dann eine neue Up und die will dann auch erstmal wieder Credentials haben, dann kann die Up halt auch gucken, gibt es ADN Passport auf diesem iPhone, launch dann dieses Teil und dann läuft irgendwie die Authentication da durch und der reicht dann wieder zurück. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie geht denn das mit dieser Interkommunikation?
Wie geht denn das eigentlich?
Interkommunikation?
Ja, wie wird das? Ist das dann so über URLs?
Du kannst da so einen URL-Händler halt anmelden.
Und rauskriegen, ob der auch da ist.
Ich glaube, du rufst den einfach nur auf.
Ja, wenn es nicht geht, dann weißt du auch, dass er nicht da ist. Oh, hier steht auch noch, wenn man die ab runterlädt, dann kann man auch einen free tier Up.net-Account anlegen. Das heißt, ohne Invite. Aha, man kann jetzt ohne Invite, wenn man nur ein iPhone hat, sich einen freien Account holen.
Ja, iOS 7, Up.net-Integration oder was? Schön wär's. Übrigens, was mir gerade noch einfällt, ganz kurzer Nachtrag aus diesen Command Line Tools, wer auch Wim sozusagen als seinen Editor mal ausprobieren will beziehungsweise noch nie so richtig warm geworden ist mit Wim, da gibt's so ein tolles wimadventures.com. wimadventures.com. Das ist ein tolles Spiel. Ist wirklich ganz putzig gemacht, um sozusagen Wim zu lernen. Ich pack den Link mal in den Chat. Das Dove ist, sagen wir mal, dass man die ersten drei Stages irgendwie kann man halt so spielen und dann kostet es halt 25 Dollar. Ich bin da zwar kurz davor, die mal auszugeben, aber warte gerade noch ein bisschen. Aber es gibt jetzt diverse Kollegen gerade in der Firma, die das mit ganz großer Leidenschaft spielen. Und das ist wirklich ganz cool gemacht. Also es ist ein HTML5-Spiel. Und da muss man halt, man hat erst nur die Movement-Keys sozusagen freigeschaltet und dann muss man so durch die Levels stiefeln und dann bekommt man halt so das W und das B und das E. Glühende Wim-User werden wissen, was damit gemeint ist. Und dann kann man halt plötzlich Gegenden erreichen, die vorher unerreichbar waren und so. Ist irgendwie ganz knuffig gemacht. Wer das also spielerisch mal ausprobieren will, der kann das mal kostenlos dafür diese drei kleinen Levels ausprobieren und ansonsten muss man dann halt mal dem Entwickler was zu Gutes überweisen, was auch okay ist.
Ist ja lustig.
Weil wir, Command Line Tools nochmal, die meisten, blöde Überleitung, aber die meisten sind ja in C geschrieben und es gibt diese komischen ISO C Header und Unix C Header und dieses ganze Zeug, was man inkludieren kann und da gibt es eine schicke Seite, wo jemand wirklich akribische Arbeit geleistet hat, um zu gucken, welche Header auf welchen Systemen existieren. Die Survey of Commonly Available C System Header feiert sich. Ich mach den Link mal in den Chat. Leider funktioniert die Seite unter Safari nur so mäßig, aber mit dem Firefox kann man das aufmachen. Das sieht dann auch gut aus. Da sind sogar so Sachen wie Android API und Ming Gw und Microsoft Visual C dabei. Nur so mal als Gag, was man sich auch sonst noch so antun kann.
Wenn einem langweilig wird, weil man die Wim Adventures durchgespielt hat.
Und man schon immer mal wissen wollte, ob es unter IREX 6.5 ein gewisses Header gibt oder unter HPOX 11.31. Wie weit geht denn das zurück? Solaris 2.10. Was gibt es denn hier noch? AIX ist 7.1. Keine Ahnung. Nee, oben kann man nicht richtig scrollen. Und wenn man da unten scrollt, dann passieren komische Dinge. Aber...
Das ist ja nur so ein bisschen was.
Ist nur so ein bisschen was. Aber ich fand das ganz niedlich. Vor allen Dingen ganz weiter unten die Abteilung. Commonly... Wie war das? Non-standard, but widespread.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall mal cool. Das ist eine Seite, die ich mir jetzt glaube ich mal bookmarken werde. Schon cool, was so Leute anstellen mit diesem Internet.
Oh man.
Jetzt scrollen sie alle in dieser Liste drin rum.
Da muss man aber wirklich auch schon wirklich eine merkwürdige Digitalsexualität entwickelt haben, so über die Zeit, um so was wirklich beschäftigen zu können, oder?
Du, keiner kann.
Header-File-Listing über alle Unixe.
Keine Ahnung.
Esoterisches Mischmasch UX.
Also mal echt, ich meine, was dem einen eine fucking machine ist, dem anderen wie so ein C-Header-File ist.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht hat da irgendjemand versucht, ein Tool zu schreiben und ist dann auf die Nase gefallen, als es unter AIX nicht laufen wollte, unter HBOX nicht laufen wollte.
Aber es ist wirklich schön. Also ich fände dieses Diagramm, also für Hardcore-Nerdcontent ist das auch wirklich hübsch geworden.
Ich hab noch so ein kleiner Tipp für Unix-Tools-Benutzer. Fällt mir gerade mal so ein. Gerade hier so auch in Huckels Arbeitswelt, da guckt man ja auf den Logfiles rein. Und dann steht vorne nur so eine große Zahl, die jetzt gerade so mit 1,3 Milliarden irgendwie anfängt. Ihr wisst, was ich meine? Den Timestamp in Sekunden. Und wenn Leute sich da immer irgendwie voll den Alarm machen, das irgendwie umzurechnen oder auf irgendwelche Webseiten gehen. Der normale Datumsbefehl, der kann das auch. Man macht einfach Date minus R und dann diesen Timestamp und dann zeigt einem die Uhrzeit an. Oder vielleicht auch für dich Tim als Kalenderfreak, ne? C-A-L. Kommt dann Kalender. Hab ich auch schonmal einem gezeigt, der auch schon lange auf Unix unterwegs ist und der auch meinte, den kannte ich auch noch nicht.
Haben wir auch schonmal erwähnt, glaube ich.
Ja, da gibt es überhaupt eine Menge zu entdecken, auch so irgendwie der Business Calculator und der Desktop Calculator und so.
Absurdes Zahlen in Command-Line-Land.
Wir haben ja, also bei VUGA, wenn man irgendwie so Engineers einstellt, da gibt es auch immer so einen Screening-Call manchmal und da gibt es ja dann auch so unter anderem bei den Backend-Entwicklern so die Frage, ja, angenommen hast du einen Log-File mit 20 Millionen Einträgen, also irgendwie jetzt so tabsepariert, was auch immer und dann ist an einer Stelle auch die User-ID drin und die kommen auch mehrfach vor und ich will jetzt von dir eine Liste irgendwie von, also ich will wissen, wie viele unike User-IDs sind in diesem 20-Millionen-Lines-Log-File drin und dann wie würdest du es machen und dann gibt es halt die Leute, die dann erstmal eine Java-Klasse aufreißen oder sich ein Pythonskript schreiben und so weiter und die ganz Pfiffigen, die sind dann...
Und sie würden es nur erzählen?
Ja, sie würden es nur erzählen, so. Wie würden sie es bauen, so und dann ja, die coolen Jungs, die machen natürlich Sword Unique? Ja, Cut, dann AWK, Sword Unique, WC-L und dann ist natürlich die Bonusfrage, ja, das ist jetzt alles nur auf einem Kern. Wie machst du das jetzt auf deinen Vierkern im Notebook gleichzeitig, sozusagen? Und dann gibt es ja noch... Ja, da gibt es halt, ja, gibt es halt auch... Ja, oder da weißt du dann auch gleich Bescheid, wer sich schon mal mit den Command Line Tools so ein bisschen beschäftigt hat.
Mach mal dein Mikrofon noch mal so einen Zentimeter näher ran.
Ja, das kann ich schon mal weg.
Was?
Wie?
Ja, du rückst es viel näher.
Leute, die in einer großen Datei mit grep suchen und dann ein Pipe wc-l hinten ransetzen, ja, da kann ich euch sagen, grep kann auch die Option minus c und dann zählt grep gleich von rein, dann muss man nicht nochmal alles nach wc-l durchschieben. Nach wc-l durchschieben. Spart mal nochmal ein Command, eine Processor-ID und viel Geschiebe.
Super. So, nachdem wir ungefähr die Hälfte unserer Hörer wahrscheinlich schon abgehängt haben.
Dann machen wir gleich weiter.
Genau, wir machen jetzt immer so lange Sendung, bis keiner mehr steht.
Und zwar, ich hab noch eine kurze Geschichte, wie ich was versucht hab, was ich nicht hingekriegt hab. Und zwar, wir haben vor zwei Sendungen ja mal darüber gesprochen, dass Samsung der Meinung ist, sie bräuchten jetzt ihr eigenes OS. Wie hieß denn das?
Bada.
Bada war das?
Du meinst den neuen Browser und diese ganze Mozilla-Geschichte?
Ja, nee, da gab's noch irgendein Betriebssystem. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall hab ich versucht, das zu installieren und hab bei dem Versuch, dieses Zeug zu installieren, etwas gelernt, was ich auch noch nicht wusste. Wenn Gatekeeper an ist und man versucht, eine Java-App zu starten, die nicht signiert ist, dann erzählt er einem, die wäre korrupt und man müsste sie neu runterladen. Und nur dann, wenn man Gatekeeper wirklich ausschaltet auf die Version, einfach alles starten, dann geht das.
Ah, das hatte ich neulich.
Nochmal.
Was?
Ich hab gar nicht zugehört, jetzt noch mal.
Also, wenn du ne Java-App runterlädst und starten willst und du hast Gatekeeper auf der mittleren Einstellung, nur signierte Dinger zulassen. Ja, hab ich. Wenn du die dann doppelklickst und er soll sie laufen lassen, dann sagt er, das ist korrupt und das musst du normal runterladen. Nur wenn du dann Gatekeeper ausschaltest, die untere Einstellung ist das, glaube ich, dann lässt er das laufen. Hat nicht geholfen.
Dann kannst du mal mit rechtsklick machen und dann open und dann wird Gatekeeper übergangen. Hast du es nicht gewusst?
Doch, aber das funktioniert bei Java Apps trotzdem nicht. Ich weiß nicht wieso.
Und im Terminal mit dem Open-Command?
Ja, wie auch immer. Das wollte ich sagen. Ich habe diese Entwicklungsumgebung versucht, da zu installieren, habe sie auch installiert gekriegt. Was ich nicht installiert bekommen habe, ist den Emulator, weil der irgendwie unter irgendeinem Emu, Qemu oder wie das Ding heißt, läuft, lässt er da so dieses Linux oder was das ist da laufen und Qemu läuft aber nicht in einer VM oder VM. Insofern war das alles sinnlos. Ich wollte den Scheiß nicht in meinem normalen System installieren, deswegen war dann der Versuch an der Stelle zu Ende irgendwie. Weil ich dachte, ach das schaust du dir mal an. Ist ganz lustig, die sagen einem so, ja hier Entwicklungsumgebung mit allem drum und dran und was kriegt man dann, ein Eklips.
Ja, dieses Eklips, das ist auch eine, das wären wir auch nicht mehr los. Irgendwie letztens hatten wir, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das erzählen darf, aber ich mach's mal trotzdem. Letztens hatten wir ein, also, nee, es war kein Sales Droid von Windows Azure. Wie sagt man Windows?
Da sterben aber dann immer, stirbt dann immer ein Kind irgendwo.
Auf jeden Fall hatten wir so einen so einen bärtigen Windows Azure Hipster. Das war wirklich so zerrissene Jeans, buntes Hemd, langer Bart, Bartek Jutebeutel, so ein so ein so ein Hipster-Hippie. Und der hat aber uns, der arbeitet für Microsoft, uns über Windows Azure Azure, Azure, Windows Azure. Hat uns berichtet, was wir denn da so bei Vuga alles tolles machen können. Ich sag, diese Folge sehr oft Vuga, Vuga, Vuga. Und dann hatte er uns halt vorgeführt, dass das ja alles in der Entwicklungsumgebung integriert wäre und bla, bla, bla. Und es gäbe auch ein Eclipse-Plugin. Und dann tatsächlich fährt er da halt auch ohne Schmerz so ein Eclipse hoch. Und es dauerte auch wieder die gefühlten Minuten, bis es gestartet war. Und dann irgendwie diesen Java-Guys und so weiter und so fort, konnte man also die Wolken steuern. Ja, also du konntest ja dann so eine neue Applikations-Server hoch und runter fahren und alles mögliche. Also ich will das auch gar nicht schlecht machen, das ist bestimmt ganz toll, dieses Windows Azure, aber ich dachte, jetzt kommt irgendwie mal eine tolle Benutzeroberfläche. Irgendwie dieses Windows Azure sieht ja alles ganz, sieht ja ganz fluffig aus und dann startet wieder dieses Eclipse. Ich bin so froh, dass ich noch nie in meinem Leben mit Eclipse arbeiten musste.
Ich hatte es ein paar Mal in meinem Leben aufgemacht und war froh, dass ich es wieder zugekriegt habe. Aber gearbeitet kann man das dann nicht nennen.
Ja, ich kenne auch Leute, die sind damit total produktiv und Java-Entwicklung ist mit Eclipse bestimmt super.
Wie produktiv wären die erst, wenn die mal ordentliche Tools benutzen würden? Mir ist das schon einfach zu träge. Die Latenz von diesem Tool ist schon viel zu hoch.
Ja, keine Ahnung, ich wär mich sowieso gegen Sprachen, wo ich eine IDE brauche. Deswegen ist das sowieso nochmal ein ganz anderer Ansatz. Aber ich glaube, Java-Entwickeln, das willst du mit Eclipse machen, da gibt es einfach nichts besseres. Ist einfach so. Das sagt vielleicht auch einiges über dieses. Aber ja, ich will das gar nicht so schlecht machen, aber ich finde es trotzdem so irgendwie, wie lange gibt es Eclipse? Doch bestimmt jetzt auch schon zehn Jahre.
Ewig.
Es sieht auch immer noch genauso bescheiden aus.
Sieht auch aus wie ewig.
Ja, sieht auch aus wie ewig.
Okay, genug gelästert, wir wollen ja ein bisschen positiv bleiben. Was ist noch auf dem Teller?
Der Bitcoin-Kurs fällt.
Nee, er ist wieder gestiegen.
Ich hätte da noch ein wieder sehr freakiges Thema. Und zwar habe ich mir Rust angeguckt, diese Sprache, die Mozilla verwendet, um irgendwie ihr Next-Generation-Web-Rendering zu machen. Und muss sagen, es ist sehr strange. Also, ähm...
Strange gut oder strange schlecht?
Das würde ich nicht abschließend beurteilen wollen. Also, ich sag mal so. C++ ist ja eine Erweiterung von C, wo jemand den Präprozessor missbraucht hat, um Klassen an C ranzupatschen. Gut, inzwischen läuft das nicht mehr so, aber man merkt das noch, da kommt die Sprache her. Objective C ist so eine... Da hat jemand C erweitert, um das, was Smalltalk ist. Keine Ahnung, kann sein.
Er war erst präprozessiert.
Und bei Rust, ich sag's mal so, da hat jemand R lang auf C draufgesetzt. Und das ist sehr merkwürdig. Also Structs und Enums sind so wie in C ungefähr. So If-Clause sind auch wie in C. Es gibt If? Es gibt If, ja. If und Else, ja.
Wieso, da gibt's auch R lang.
Lokale Variablen sind by default immutable. Also wie in R lang. Man kann sie aber auch mutable machen, wenn man das unbedingt haben will. Funktionsdeklarationen sehen sehr nach R lang aus. Also das mit diesem Minus größer, mit diesem Pfeil nach rechts. Dann, es gibt Pattern Matching, aber interessanterweise nicht in Funktionsheader. Also so wie man es bei R lang hat, wo man halt mehrere quasi gleich lautende Funktionen untereinander schreibt und sie sich nur dadurch unterscheiden, dass er halt die Eingabeparameter Pattern matcht. Sondern es gibt so eine Art, so wie so ein erweitertes Switch-Statement, was ein Pattern Matching macht. Dann es gibt wie in R lang Tupels. So und dann das Memory Management. Das ist echt merkwürdig, weil das ist, also es gibt Memory auf dem Stack, so wie man es halt so von C so kennt. Wenn die Variable aus dem Scope geht, ist das Memory weg. Dann gibt es sogenannte Owned Boxes. Ich hab mir aufgeschrieben, kein Reference Counting, nur eine Referenz. Also es ist wie ein Reference Counted Objekt, aber auf das es nur eine Referenz gibt. So und alle Sachen, die in einer Box sind und die wiederum andere Boxen referenzieren, inheriten die Mutability von dem Zeug. Also es ist alles ein bisschen, es war schwierig zu lesen die Doku. So, dann gibt es die sogenannten Managed Boxes, die sind garbage collected, haben aber keine Mutability Inheritance und owning aber ihren Content. Und was es mit den Borrowed Pointers auf sich hat, das weiß ich nicht mehr genau. Also es gibt Closures und Methoden haben ein explizites Self-Argument. Also es ist so eine Art Objektorientierung für, weiß ich nicht, für Schmalspur. So wie ein Ader, also du hast da Funktionen, wo du einen Self-Pointer übergeben bekommst, was dann halt die Struktur deines, wenn es so etwas gäbe, Klasse wäre.
Sprachen, wo das Wort Self drin vorkommt, nehme ich nicht ernst.
Das sind eine ganze Menge Sprachen dann.
Er ist ein Fan von C++, da ist es ja this.
Ja genau, JavaScript ist auch this.
Es gibt Generics und zwar sind die wirklich so hässlich wie C++ Templates, das ist unglaublich. Es gibt sogenannte Crades, Compile Units, die so ähnlich sind wie in Erlang diese Module, wo man irgendwie so Metadaten mit angeben kann, so Outdoor, Inversion und so was.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die Compile Unit einfach, aber auch die Module quasi.
Genau, ein Crade ist da ein Compile Unit. Dann gibt es Task, die so ähnlich sind wie Erlang-Prozesse, und die haben auch so ein Linkage zwischen anderen Prozessen. Wenn der eine stirbt, stirbt der andere mit und so weiter.
Naja, das klingt so wie bei diesem Zitat von Robert Verding.
Das letzte, was ich mir noch aufgeschrieben hab, war die Task Communication, die ist ziemlich ähnlich der Go-Channels, die ich auch irgendwie komisch fand. Ja, die Go-Channels, die sind so ein bisschen wie die Erlang-Messages, aber nicht ganz so einfach zu benutzen. Das war so ein grober Überblick über Rust. Wahrscheinlich bekomme ich jetzt ganz fürchterlich ans Bein gepinkelt, weil ich die wichtigsten Sachen vergessen habe oder manche Sachen falsch dargestellt. Aber im Prinzip ist es eine interessante Sprache. Aber das muss man erst mal abwarten, wie sich das entwickelt. Vor allen Dingen sind wir jetzt bei Version 0.6.
Der Hund, der mit drei Beinen versucht zu pissen, ist auch interessant, aber gut ist das nicht.
Das hast du jetzt gesagt. Ich habe dir nicht widersprochen.
Einen von diesen Erlang-Jungs gibt es ja so ein Zitat hier. Any sufficiently complicated concurrent program in another language contains an ad-hoc informally specified bug-ridden slow implementation of half of Erlang. Das klingt bei Go und Rust auch irgendwie so.
Go ist vielleicht so bei 40%, Rust ist vielleicht jetzt so bei 60%. Also Go ist noch viel, viel barebones mehr, weil die halt auch sowas wie Pattern-Matching nicht haben und weil die vor allen Dingen auch kein Immutable by default haben.
Die haben sowieso ganz komische Ideen.
Und da ist Rust doch noch deutlich näher dran. Ob das jetzt das beste seitgeschnitten Board ist, das wird sich zeigen, aber ich finde es erst mal interessant. Kann man im Auge behalten.
Das Schöne ist jetzt auch beim Pair-Programm, das ist ein Schwabe, mit dem ich da Pair-Programme. Das merkt man ihm jetzt nicht so an, aber er hat hin und wieder immer so schöne Sprüche. Kaum schwätzt man vom Bär, kommt er daher. Zum Beispiel kam letztens locker aus der Hüfte geschossen und kaum schwätzt man von der Überleitung.
Der Schützereim, der schützereim, der reimt sich nicht. Wir könnten jetzt wählen. Wir könnten uns entweder über Adblocker unterhalten, Audio-Technik, Podcasting, Bitcoin oder BitTorrent.
Ich hab wild schnell Bitcoin gemacht.
Ja, Dennis hat schon ganz lange nichts erzählt.
Ich war gestern mal wieder im Room 77 Burger essen. Auch Bar bezahlt, alles ganz normal. Er ist eh immer so voll da. Du hast eh die Zeit. Die ruf ich gar nicht an. Hab wieder hier mit dem Jörg Patzer gesprochen, der dem da der Laden gehört. Ich kam gestern an, hatte da schon wieder eine Kamera im Gesicht gehabt. Der hat da bestimmt gefühlte 2, 3, 4 Interviews die Woche nur wegen Bitcoin, weil er ist der Laden weltweit, wo er irgendwie Bitcoin-Alarmen macht. Gestern war da irgendwie, der war auch deutscher, ich hab kurz auch Hallo gesagt. Er meinte, er muss fürs chinesische Fernsehen glaube ich was machen oder so. Also es ist wirklich weltweit, kommen die da an und beauftragen irgendwelche Kamerateams oder wie auch immer und dann wird er gedreht. Keine Ahnung, weiß nicht genau. Jedenfalls meinte der zu mir, so was es an News so gibt, dass er nächste Woche den Bitcoin-Pizza-Day hat. Bis am 22.05. bis 12 Uhr abends meint er, weil irgendwann macht wohl auch die Küche zu. Und die Pizza wird, so wie damals nämlich, die erste Bitcoin-Pizza für 10.000 Bitcoins kosten. Ich weiß nicht, wer die jetzt da so an dem Tag dann kaufen wird oder wie er sich das denkt. 10.000 Bitcoins, ja. Der erste Deal, der mit Bitcoins gemacht wurde, waren 10.000 Bitcoins für zwei Pizzen. Das macht er nächste Woche auch nochmal.
Ach, du meinst, er findet einen Dosen?
Keine Ahnung, ich denke mal, es ist eine Marketing-Aktion. Ich hab ihm auch schon gesagt, es ist ja doch ein bisschen teuer jetzt. Und wir haben schon überlegt, ob man das nicht dann vielleicht doch eher in MilliBitcoins machen würde. Aber in MilliBitcoins wäre das halt auch immer noch viel zu viel. Ja, da wird es halt schwierig. Dann haben wir überlegt, ob wir was mit Satoshis machen, 10.000 Satoshis. Aber Satoshi sind wieder so wenig, dass es dann für ihn auch für sich wieder nicht lohnt.
Ja, warum macht er das?
Eine Marketing-Aktion?
Ja, da sollte er nochmal drüber nachdenken. Vielleicht hört er die Sendung ja auch. Weil in meiner letzten Sendung hat er dann gehört, dass ich ein bisschen für seinen Bitcoin-Keys Werbung gemacht habe. Hat er sich dann auch nochmal angehört, hat er sich auch bedankt und so. Und wenn er nochmal hört, unsere Idee wäre auch, mach es mit Satoshis. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu seinen Verlusten, aber ich glaube, er wird es überleben.
Ja, dann macht er halt die Millionen Satoshipizza. Das klingt ja auch viel geiler. Na, es ist immer noch im Nachkommenbereich, wenn es acht Stellen nach hinten geht, oder?
Na ja, es wird schwierig. Egal, er soll da mal irgendwie das ordentlich machen. Die Leute werden ja dann auch vielleicht verspenden, oder wie auch immer. Na, dass er nicht zu viel Verlust macht. Dann fressen sie ihm die Bude ein und fressen die Pizza leer. Keine Ahnung, wie er sich das so denkt. Wird das schon irgendwie hinkriegen. Aber da ist auf jeden Fall wieder mal Bitcoin-Tag am 22. Und am sonstigen immer am eben ersten Donnerstag im Monat. So, dann Tim, hast du was erzählt, dass irgendwie Mt. Gox Probleme hat. Ich hab vorhin kurz reingelesen. Gox hat Probleme mit dem Department of Homeland Security wegen irgendwelchen de Waller, das ist noch so eine andere Währung, Interaktionen oder Changes. Und das würde ich mal behaupten, das betrifft nicht wirklich den Bitcoin in Richtung Dollar und den Bitcoin in Richtung Eurotransfer. Deswegen ist der Kurs heute kurzfristig um 10 Euro runtergerutscht, aber auch gleich wieder hoch, weil alle gemerkt haben, ja, nee, ist alles gar nicht so schlimm. Deswegen das läuft unter ferner liefen und interessiert gar nicht so Dolle.
Mir ist übrigens heute erst aufgefallen, weil Mt. Gox beim Einloggen einen jetzt endlich mal darauf hingewiesen hat, dass du diese Two-Factor Authentication jetzt auch da machen kannst.
Bei Mt. Gox?
Genau, und zwar kannst du das dediziert angeben, ob du Two-Factor aushaben willst fürs normale Einloggen schon oder nur, wenn es um Money-Transactions geht. Und was war das dritte? Hab ich vergessen? Wenn V-Ups...
Ja, hab ich noch gar nicht gemacht, aber da können wir gleich kurz anknüpfen, wenn wir eine Prima-Überleitung zu zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung tun, weil bei Apple geht das ja jetzt auch weltweit.
Ja, aber leider nicht so wie alle anderen das machen, sondern nur so mit SMS.
Ja, irgendwie, du musst deine Geräte, die SMS-fähig sind, dann noch mit angeben und am besten auch von jemanden aus deiner Familie, dem du vertraust, weil du zur Not dann auch eine Nachricht zu dem schicken kannst, falls du dein eigenes iPhone verlierst, kannst du dich bei Apple melden, kannst sagen, ja hier hab ich verloren, schickt aber mal die SMS, an Telefon X, was ich damals angeben habe, was dann das von einer Frau oder von einem Mann oder Partner oder wem sein kann, damit man sich das wieder freischalten lassen kann, muss man halt aber vorher natürlich angeben. Aber wollte ich auch gleich machen natürlich, aber es geht nicht, weil dann komischerweise wieder diese komischen Security-Fragen da kommen, die ich meines Erachtens nie angegeben hab. Normal kaufen kann ich wieder, aber diese Security-Fragen, die kommen da immer noch, also keine Ahnung.
Das heißt, du kannst dein Profil gerade nicht ändern?
Ich kann gerade nicht auf diese zwei Fakta-Authentifizierung umschalten, weil ich erst mal an dieser Fragewand da vorbei muss.
Was war dein erstes Haustier?
Ja, genau diese Scheiße. Wie hieß dein bester Freund an der ersten Klasse? Ich bin Nerd, ich hatte keine Freunde.
Wo man irgendwann mal so Fuh, Fuh, Fuh angegeben hat. Du hast doch bestimmt Chatroom-Freunde dann wenigstens gehabt, die dich nicht in echt gesehen haben.
1976 oder wann?
Du bist ja nicht mehr ganz so jung.
So, jetzt ist Mount Cox wieder mal nichts zu erreichen.
Ja, das sind jedenfalls die Updates zu Bitcoin. Sonst gab es da eigentlich jetzt in letzter Woche. Der Kurs ist stabil, ist alles ganz ruhig. Die Zocker machen gerade alle Urlaub anscheinend.
Stabil auf niedrigem Niveau, was haben wir hier?
Also 80, 90 Euro.
Das war am Jahresanfang 10 Euro, Jungs. Das ist nur, weil es zwischendurch kurz mal 200 war. Das ist die Hälfte von 200, aber es ist das Neunfache von Jahresanfang. Also ihr seid schon zu verwöhnt.
Du hast ja recht.
Wie mit den Apple-Aktien, ne?
Wie mit den Apple-Aktien.
Immer noch scheiße hoch.
Ja, kann man mal richtig ordentlich runtergehen, der Kurs, damit die Leute mal wieder was spenden.
Jetzt kriegt keiner mehr Spenden rein per Bitcoin.
Hat keine Stabilität mehr, die Währung.
Ja, ich hab auch schon lange keine Bitcoins.
Nicht, dass das jetzt das Wichtigste wäre. Ich bin bloß immer noch der Meinung, was glaube ich viele Leute verstört bei Bitcoin ist. Einfach, dass man so recht kein Gefühl dafür bekommt, was es so wert ist.
Da muss man nur auf Silk Road gucken. Dann weiß man, was eine Bitcoin wert ist gerade.
Ja gut, aber auch, dass es eher relativ zu dem, was es gerade in US-Dollar wert ist.
Du musst trotzdem auf den Straßenkreis kennen.
Die Drogen, die sich in Afghanistan die Bitcoins in ihre Leben hütten und fahren.
Ich hab gehört, dass es da Händler aus allen Ländern gibt. Ich hab auch von Leuten gehört, die sich Sachen aus Nepal bestellt haben. Wer zum Beispiel wüsste, was ein Gramm Marihuana üblicherweise in etwa kostet, der kann sich auch ganz leicht auf Silk Road den aktuellen Bitcoin-Wert ausrechnen. Jetzt ist Tim leider vom Stuhl gefallen und kann nicht darauf antworten. Wir warten noch fünf Sekunden, bis er sich wieder aufgerappelt hat.
Ja, aber das muss man auch erst wissen. Also den Straßenpreis von Drogen, muss ich sagen, kann ich schon seit Jahren nicht mehr mitreden. Schon seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr. Ist auch okay soweit.
Machst du selber anpflanzen, ja?
Ich habe jetzt angepflanzt Hopfen.
Ist auch eine Droge.
Ja, aber legal.
Ist zum Beispiel die Marihuana sehr ähnlich.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Aber du kannst ja auch überlegen, oder du gehst halt zu Room 77, dann weißt du halt auch, was so eine Bitcoin wert ist.
Ja, du weißt, was ich meine. Die Leute haben alle Rätsel, was wird es irgendwie, wird es überhaupt jemals stabil sein? Oder ist das jedes Jahr eine neue Achterbahn der Gefühle? Keiner weiß, irgendwas damit anzufangen.
Das ist ganz einfach, umso weniger Leute da mitmachen, umso mehr Achterbahn ist es.
Also ich würde sagen, je weniger echte Sachen und Dienstleistungen man damit kaufen kann, desto mehr Achterbahn ist es, weil dann ist es wirklich nur der Spekulation wegen und nicht der echte Gegenwert.
Oder es wird halt wirklich benutzt, um Dienstleistungen auszutauschen, aber das, glaube ich, findet derzeit nur so nebenbei statt.
Na, es kommt immer schon was Neues dazu, aber es ist noch relativ überschaubar. Wenn ich was zu verkaufen hätte, würde ich es auch in Bitcoin verkaufen. Das sage ich jetzt hier mal so. Also ich meine, dieses Coinbase-Start-up, das wächst und wächst und wächst. Und die machen ja da irgendwie Profite und Gewinne ein. Quatsch, weiß nicht, ob sie Profite und Gewinne machen, aber sie stellen dauernd neue Leute ein und machen mehr und mehr Umsatz jeden Monat. Das heißt ja, ja, was heißt das denn eigentlich? Was machen die nochmal? Die machen, ach nee, das waren nicht die, die PayPal in Bitcoins machen wollen, glaube ich. Das war die Hosted, ne doch, genau, Merchantools. Die machen halt sozusagen, wenn du jetzt was zu verkaufen hast, kannst du bei Coinbase dir so ein hier Pay with Bitcoins-Button machen und sie rechnen dir dann auch die Preise schön dynamisch um und so. Und da gibt es irgendwie immer ganz tolle, neue Wasserstandsmeldungen, dass sie ja wahnsinnig erfolgreich werden und so. Try a Demo, Pay with Bitcoins.
Ich hab ja bisher noch gar nichts verkauft. Wie funktioniert denn das eigentlich genau?
Dann machst du mal ein Angebot, was ich nicht ablehnen kann und dann kaufe ich dir die ab.
Naja, es gibt halt, es gibt zum Beispiel das Problem bei Coinbase, was halt so Merchantools anbieten, aber das glaube ich nur USA gerade ist. Und das europäische Pendant, das sah so grausam aus, dass ich schon längst wieder vergessen habe, wie das eigentlich hieß. Aber eigentlich will man sowas wie Coinbase benutzen, glaube ich. Dann kriegst du dann nämlich diesen Pay with Bitcoin-Button und sagst wahrscheinlich auch, was du gerne in echtem Geld haben würdest wollen, dann rechnen sie den Bitcoin-Preis da dynamisch aus. Auf dem Button.
Ich hab letztens was gekauft und das ging über bitpay.com. Da kam auch so eine Seite mit dem QR-Code und deren Dollarpreis automatisch in Bitcoins umgerechnet. Du hast zwei Minuten Zeit, das zu bezahlen. Wahrscheinlich nicht, weil sie keinen Bock haben, so lange zu warten, weil es könnte ja eigentlich ewig dauern. Aber weil sie wahrscheinlich wollen, dass du nicht wartest, ob sich der Kurs zu deinen Gunsten verbessert oder nicht. Weil sonst ist es ja zu deren Ungunsten. Deswegen sollst du möglichst schnell bezahlen, damit die Umrechnung noch frisch ist. Genau, und das lief ganz gut. Hab ich bezahlt und es wurde auf der Webseite innerhalb von 2-3 Sekunden sofort bestätigt. Das ist vielleicht noch nicht in einem Blog drin und wurde noch nicht 6-mal konfirmt, aber die haben die Transaction schon bekommen.
Ich hab zwar jetzt eine Ahnung, wie es sein könnte, aber vielleicht denke ich auch gerade selber falsch. Jetzt hab ich irgendwie meine Bitcoins, die hab ich jetzt hier auf meinem Rechner. Das heißt, die liegen im Wesentlichen auf diesem einen Computerfestplatte. Mehrere. Wenn ich jetzt da auf Plattform X was verschärbeln möchte, ich mal sage hier, ich schnapp mir jetzt mal hier so eine Bitcoin und werf die einfach mal in den Topf. Dann muss ich das quasi an Mount Gox, ich bleib jetzt mal bei dem Beispiel einfach, kann ja irgendwas sein, hin überweisen sozusagen. Dass es erstmal in deren Besitz übergeht und dann führen die das für mich auf meinem Konto, was ich dort habe.
Korrekt, erst mal musst du bei Mount Gox klicken, dass du was einzahlen willst an Bitcoins. Du kannst ja Euro oder Bitcoins einzahlen, dann sagst du Euro und dann zeigt dir deine Adresse an, eine Bitcoin-Adresse, zu der du hin überweisen sollst. Und da steht doch gleich dabei, bitte nur dieses eine Mal und danach nicht mehr, weil die müssen ja ewig und ihr Leben lang diese Adressen auf jeden Fall noch mal hin überweisen, damit das Geld nicht weg ist. Deswegen schreiben sie schon, mach's möglichst nur einmal. Kann sein, dass es beim nächsten Mal die gleiche kommt, aber sie sagen erst mal, immer nur frisch, sich immer das neu klingen. Du sollst sie also nicht aufheben. Dann überweist du an diese Adresse dein Geld und dann nach sechs Confirmations oder wann auch immer erscheint dann bei Mt. Gox, wo du ja zwei Konten hast, erscheint dann bei Bitcoin, dass da jetzt zum Beispiel 10 Bitcoins angekommen sind. Zack. Und dann hast du bei Mt. Gox in deinem Bitcoin-Konto 10 Bitcoins. Dann kannst du bei denen traden, kannst du zum Beispiel mal 5 verkaufen oder nochmal 5 verkaufen und auch wieder von Euro, die du bekommen hast, wieder zurückverkaufen und hin und her. Und dann hast du ja Bitcoins auf deinem Bitcoin-Konto und eventuell hast du dann auch ein paar Euros auf deinem Euro-Konto und kannst die wieder auszahlen lassen.
Okay. Dazu eine Frage. Wenn ich jetzt was verkaufen will, dann heißt das ja erstmal nur, ich biete das jetzt an und dann muss ich einen Preis nennen, für den ich es gerne verkaufen wollen würde.
Immer noch bei Mt. Gox? Oder meinst du jetzt Produkte?
Ist egal wo. Nee, jetzt, nee, nee, Mt. Also angenommen, ich will jetzt wirklich meine Bitcoin in Geld umwandeln.
Okay, also wenn du deine Bitcoins dahingeschoben hast zu Mt. Gox, dann hast du die halt in deinem Konto. Dann hat der ja noch da diesen Trading-Market. Gox selber verkauft ja alles, die vermitteln ja nur. Und dann zeigen sie dir an, was gerade so der Verkaufspreis für Bitcoin ist, nämlich, oder ich weiß gar nicht, was die anzeigen, ich glaube, die zeigen das an, was der ist, der am meisten gerade für Bitcoins bietet. Und aber noch keiner ihm gegeben hat, weil alle nicht so billig verkaufen wollen. Aber er zeigt dir halt irgendeinen Preis an. Und dann kannst du klicken, entweder du verkaufst so, dass einfach die oberste Spitze an Einkäufern dir deine Bitcoins abnehmen, dann ist es aber deren billigster Preis, den die da liefern, also die Spitze zwar vom Eisberg, aber genau nur dieser Preis. Oder du nimmst einen Preis, der ist leicht drüber und du wartest halt so lange, bis einer kommt und sich das wegschnappt. Weil es sind so zwei Mengen. Die einen wollen ganz billig kaufen und die anderen wollen ja ganz teuer verkaufen und dazwischen ist so eine Lücke halt. Und du kannst ja aussuchen, ob du denen entgegenkommst oder ob du wartest, bis die dir entgegenkommen. Dazwischen ist halt so ein Euro-Unterschied circa.
Ja, aber manchmal auch ein bisschen mehr. Also als ich hier als diese große Kurssturzpanik kam, da habe ich ja bei Bitstamp auch den Easy-Sell gemacht. Und das ist dann genau das, dass sie dann eben versuchen, die offenen Asks gerade oder Bits irgendwie mit deinen Bitcoins abzufrüstücken, zu was für Preisen auch immer. Und dann kriegst du halt nicht den höchsten Preis.
Aber bist du sofort los.
Genau, und bist du sofort los. Und sonst, wenn ich ein paar Bitcoins mal verkauft hatte, so als ich so mal so mein Mittagessen immer am Tag irgendwie da so reintreten wollte, da habe ich dann halt gesagt, ich will die jetzt für 40 Euro verkaufen. Es mir scheißegal, ob der gerade bei 30 Euro ist. Und dann irgendwie einen Tag später oder so, als es sich dann immer so hochklamüsert hat, wurde die dann halt irgendwie... Also da hatte ich keinen Druck. Das war ja eher so als Spielgeld deklariert. Und das Schöne bei diesem Easy-Cell ist halt, wenn du halt so Bruchfragmente von Bitcoins hast, also so 3,9461 hast du nicht gesehen, niemand... also die meisten Leute, die wollen halt immer ganze Bitcoins oder so. Und wenn du halt dieses Easy-Cell machst, dann versuchen sie halt auch so deine broken Bitcoins irgendwie da so zu verteilen, dass du wirklich alle los wirst.
Also mein Gorks wirst eigentlich immer alle los, weil er splittet deinen Verkauf oder Einkauf splittet der sowieso in Einzelteile auf. Das heißt, wenn du 10 verkaufst, kann sein, dass du 5 sofort los bist, weil da war einer, der das geboten hat, aber die anderen 5 ist kein weiterer, der so viel bietet und dann musst du halt ein bisschen warten.
Aber bei diesem Easy-Cell, in Anführungsstrichen, da geht es halt dann auch relativ sofort alles weg.
Du bist bei Bitcoin irgendwas anderem, ne?
Nee, Bitstamp.
Genau, weil bei Mt. Gox heißt das nicht Easy-Cell, sondern Market Price. Kannst du so ein Häkchen setzen und dann musst du nicht warten, dann mach da einfach sofort, kriegst aber auch eventuell einen nicht so guten Preis.
Verstehe. Da haben wir auf jeden Fall gleich was los. Ja, ich komm da nicht mehr ran.
Ja, also ich kann nach wie vor, ich finde dieses Bitstamp nach wie vor...
Engine X 1.4.0. War doch nicht so ein Bug, Jungs, Jungs, Jungs. Nee, da war so ein Bug irgendwie letzte Woche und man soll ganz, ganz, ganz dringend auf 1.4.1 updaten. Oder 1.41. Ich weiß nicht, war es eine 40 oder war es eine... Noch mal kurz gucken hier. 1.4.0 ist bei denen, ja.
Also, bitstamp.net finde ich irgendwie immer noch irgendwie mit den angenehmsten Marketplace. Die traden zwar auch in Dollar nur, aber zahlen auch in Euro aus und konvertieren da zum aktuellen Bankkurs, ohne da jetzt nochmal bei der Umrechnung zu verdienen. Und der Marketplace, also selbst bei der großen Torschlusspanik, Kursschlusspanik, konnte ich da halt verkaufen, wo alle anderen Markets wirklich nix mehr ging. Also ich musste auch ein paar Mal reloaden, aber die hatten es noch vergleichsweise drauf. Und die sind vom Marktvolumen halt relativ weit vorne mit dabei, wenn man auf Bitcoin-Charts guckt. Es bitstamp irgendwie so unter den Top 5 oder so weltweit und das große Trading-Volumen hat halt dann auch so seine Vorteile, weil man dann halt irgendwie immer Bitcoins kriegt und auch schnell wieder los wird und irgendwie die Kurse da alle so ein bisschen stabiler.
Machen die auch Two-Factor-Authentication?
Die machen natürlich auch Two-Factor-Authentication.
Das scheint jetzt in dem Segment aber auch wirklich zum Standard zu werden jetzt.
Die waren da auch sehr früh dabei mit Two-Factor-Auth.
Und auch hier so mit Zahlen und so.
Also diese Bitstamper, die kommen halt aus Slowenien, aber die, wie gesagt, traden in den US-Dollar und die sind wirklich, ich finde die extrem nett und auch ich habe denen schon ein paar mal so Support-Mails geschrieben, die haben sie irgendwie schnell beantwortet und so. Ich bin da bisher, muss ich sagen, sehr zufrieden. So als Alternative mal zum allgegenwärtigen Mt. Mal den DSR testen. War das eine schöne Überleitung zum Audiothema?
Ja, kann man gelten lassen.
Ja, das Audiothema.
Ich hol mir noch einen Schluck Wasser im Moment.
Wollen wir mal klein und fein anfangen?
Klar.
Dann würde ich doch einfach mal hier mit dem Gerät anfangen, was ich mir zugelegt habe. Ich schmeiß das doch mal hier chatwärts. So, ein Alesis IO2 Express heißt das Ding. Tim meinte, als wir uns das letzte Mal gesehen haben, so offline, das wäre ja doch eher so, die würden so einen plastikmäßigen Eindruck machen, die Alesis Sachen. Das ist nicht so ganz falsch. Also es ist tatsächlich eine Plastikkiste. Aber die tut eigentlich ganz gut. Ich hab die nur quasi zum Audio chatten, weil ich da dieses gute, wie heißen die Teile, diese Headsets, die guten Biodynamic Headsets, die du gerade aufhast, die ich gerade auf hab.
DT297.
Ja, genau, die kann man so mit dem Standardkabel, wie es ist, einfach da mit zwei Steckern Klick Klack rein und dann tut alles. Dann dreht man da noch so. Genau, XLR-Klinke fürs Mikrofon und genau, XLR fürs Mikrofon, große Klinke für den Kopfhörer. Dann hat man auf der rechten Seite noch ein Regler, wo man direkt vom Mikrofon auf den Kopfhörer latenzfrei reinmischen kann, damit man sich selber hört. Man hat in der Mitte ein paar Leuchtioden, die einem sagen, ob man jetzt übersteuert oder nicht, und dann ist es eigentlich schon fertig. Dann stöpselt man das Teil so, wie es ist, an den Rechner an mit USB. Der macht also tatsächlich eine 48 Volt Phantomspeisung aus dem USB direkt.
Ja, das machen viele USB-Preamps.
Und dann kann man einfach loslegen. Das ist so pain-free. Also ich würde damit jetzt auch keine Bandaufnahmen machen, wahrscheinlich, aber so als kleines Ding, was man sich so neben einem Rechner stellt und einfach nur sein Headset reinklingt, das ist völlig in Ordnung.
Das ist auch so dieses Level von Headset mal reinklinken. Das ist wirklich für 95% der Leute da draußen, die jetzt so ein Headset denken, für die ist Headset so ein Grubbelplastik, keine Ahnung, 0815 für 24 Euro aus dem Apple Store Zubehörabteil für Skypen. Und jetzt hier so ein Biodynamik-Headset mit irgendwie einem ordentlichen Pri-Emp mit Phantomschweisung und irgendwie allem Pipa-Po. Das ist schon echt Deluxe de la Cac, würde ich sagen. Also selbst wenn das Gerät selbst eher noch im Budget-Bereich anzusiedeln ist, ist das schon eher die gepflegte Art, so ein Headset an einem Rechner zu betreiben.
Naja, ich sag mal so, bei dem Biodynamik kostet das Kabel ja schon fast so viel wie diese Anleseskiste. Insofern hast du da nicht ganz unrecht. Also ja, aber es tut einfach.
Ja, das ist ja das, wo ich dann dieses X2U verwende, was aber nur einen Kanal macht. So kann man ja zwei kanalig machen. Aber kann man die auch separat betreiben?
Ehrlich gesagt, so viel habe ich damit noch nicht rumgespielt. Ich nehme es mal an.
Dann kriegst du zwei Inputs von dem über USB?
Die Frage ist, kann man da zwei Headsets reinstecken und hat dann ein Monitor-Mix?
Von beidem?
Also kann man ein Mono-Monitor-Mix machen? Da gibt es so eine Stereo-Monotaste, sehe ich da gerade, bei den Phones. Achso, es gibt nur einen Phonenausgang?
Es gibt nur einen Phonenausgang, ja. Also du könntest bestimmt zwei Mikros reintun und dann bei einem Phone-Ding so einen Y-Stecker benutzen und dann hast du halt zwei Dinger da dran.
Genau, und wenn du den auf Mono machst, ist halt die Frage, was da mit auf Mono gemacht wird. Also macht das den...
Genau, das müsste ich nochmal nachgucken. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Oder sonst wäre es unter Umständen eine lustige Minimal-Lösung, um zwei Hatsets mit Local Mixing zu betreiben.
Also wenn es dich wirklich interessiert, dann kann ich es nochmal ausprobieren mit einem zweiten Mikro.
Probier es mal aus. Interessiert mich soweit, dass ich wüsste, ob es so geht.
Aber wenn ich das richtig sehe, dann hast du die Phantomspeisung aber auch nur auf der linken Seite, also Mik Input 1.
Ach so.
Oder?
Sehe ich das richtig? Dann fällt es eh raus.
Echt, die brauchen Phantomspeisung? Stimmt, das ist ja Kondensator.
Wie gesagt, müsste ich mal gucken. Ich kann mir nicht so recht vorstellen, dass man mit nur einem Schalter auch Phantomspeisung auf beiden Seiten anschaltet. Aber...
Ja doch, aber ist schon relativ üblich tatsächlich. Also meistens schaltet man ja die Phantomspeisung nicht pro Eingang ein, sondern gleich für so 4 oder 2 zumindest am Stück.
Naja, mein 8-kanaliges mit 4 Mikro-Vorverstärkern, da kannst du in jedem Kanal einzeln die Phantomspeisung einschalten.
Ja, bei meinem Focus-Ride, da kann ich pro so vorne die 2, kann man glaube ich, ne, man kann entweder 1 bis 4 oder 5 bis 6 oder beide Gruppen sozusagen, 5 bis 8, also ich kann immer nur 4 auf einmal Phantomspeisen. Wobei ja die dynamischen Mikros, denen ist das ja egal, ob da Phantom anliegt oder nicht.
Nicht allen, aber im Prinzip ist es denen egal.
Ja, naja, also ich nehm da für den X2U, der ist noch etwas teurer, kompakter.
Aber hat der denn auch so eine Klinke, so ein Klinkenausgang, oder wie geht das dann da mit dem Headset, weil der ist ja jetzt...
Miniklinke hat der. Ich hab mir da auch so eh noch einen Adapter gebaut. Ja, das stimmt schon. Da muss man dann noch mal anders ran. Von daher, mit Standardbestückung fährt man mit diesem Alesis da sogar besser.
Der ist tatsächlich teurer noch als das Alesis, ne?
Der ist aber auch echt gut.
Das Alesis kostet so einen Huni.
Das X2U liegt so richtig schwer in der Hand. Sehr vertrauenserweckend.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das unbedingt will, dass es schwer in der Hand liegt. Stabil soll es schon sein, aber nicht unbedingt schwer. Ich gehöre ja zu den Leuten, die immer die Gewichte aus den Mäusen rausschrauben, weil mir das zu dämlich ist, wenn das Zeug schwer ist. Deswegen kann ich auch keine Funkmäuse, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Ja, du hast ja bei so kabelgebundenen Mäusen, damit die wertig erscheinen, hast du da immer ein Metallstück drin.
Das ist für Gamer sehr wichtig, diese Gewichtsverteilung.
Ich rede nicht von Gamer-Mäusen, ich rede von so einer Wald-und-Wiesen-Desktop-Maus. Die nimmst du in die Hand und die hat eine gewisse Schwere. Wenn du sie aufschraubst, dann ist da irgendwo ein Stück Metall, was du rausschrauben kannst und danach ist sie schön leicht.
Die haben die Maus schwerer, weil die sich auf ultra empfindlich stellen. Wenn du die so leichtest, hüpft die gleich einen halben Meter und geht von einem Bildschirmrand zum anderen. Oder mit deiner Figur machst du zwei Drehungen im Kreis im Counter-Strike.
Ich rede ja nicht von Gamer-Mäusen.
Das ist nicht nur für die Gamer gut. Da machen uns die Gamer was vor, wie eine gute Maus ist.
Ich will nicht den ganzen Tag einen Stein rumschieben.
Du schiebst sie kaum noch, du machst sie extrem fein.
Aber das Thema Mäuse hat sich eher erledigt. Let's move on.
Außerdem waren wir gerade bei Audio, nicht bei Mäusen.
Dann ist es elegant rumschiffen.
Darauf schiffen wollte ich.
Wir haben ja so ein Pinkel-Memier am Start.
Also wir haben jetzt quasi das untere Ende der Audio-Interfaces abgegraben. Und jetzt kommt Tim mit dem oberen Ende der Audio-Interfaces, oder?
Ist das das obere Ende?
Nein, das ist noch nicht das obere Ende, aber es ist auf jeden Fall die gehobene.
Die Luft wird dünn, einigen wir uns mal so.
Also es ist noch nicht der Lamborghini oder so, aber es ist eine S-Klasse definitiv schon in der Richtung, würde ich sagen, ja.
S-Klasse würde ich nicht sagen. Weil S-Klasse ist dann auch wirklich so mit allen irgendwie erdenklichen Bells and Whistles. Ich würde sagen, es ist eher solide. Deswegen sag ich Audi.
Das ist ein Bentley oder so.
Wie auch immer.
Aber hoffentlich zuverlässiger.
Das wird sich zeigen. Also ich hab so ein paar Issues mit meinem Equipment gehabt, als ich das auf der Republika zum Einsatz gebracht hab. Und es nimmt jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen Züge an, wo ich mir dachte, jetzt Zukunft.
Investieren Sie jetzt.
Da bist du ja immer für zu haben, für die Zukunft.
Bin ich sehr für zu haben und das ist ja auch nicht ohne Wagnis. Und nach langem Überlegen hab ich mir also jetzt mal so ein RME bestellt. Das haben mir verschiedene Leute schon empfohlen, nachdem ich hier häufiger schon mal das Klagelied angehoben habe. Und das ist heute angekommen. Ich kann jetzt noch nicht so sehr viel dazu sagen, außer dem, was ich jetzt letztes Mal schon auf der Musikmesse ohnehin rausgefunden habe. Beziehungsweise, was man natürlich auch im Web einfach so nachlesen und glauben kann. Allerdings schon erstaunlich, wenn man das Ding so in die Hand nimmt, das ist schon so ein solides Gerät. Also häufig hast du ja so 19 Zoll Equipment, wenn du das so kaufst. Oder auch so dieses USB-Gebammel mit so Plastik drumrum. Da denkst du dir so, ah, sieht ja echt solide aus. Dann nimmst du das in die Hand und dann so, Huch, sagt das solide. The Internet doesn't weigh anything.
Ist das UFX oder UCX?
Das UCX ist ja so ein kleines. Und das FX hat halt 2-3 entscheidende Features für mich. Also einerseits hat es halt 4 Mikrofoneingänge, das war mir schonmal wichtig, obwohl ich noch nicht abschließend beschlossen habe, ob ich die tatsächlich nutzen werde, das wird sich noch zeigen.
Was machst du da?
Ich hab ja auch noch den alten Pri-Emp, den könnte ich auch nehmen. Das wird jetzt... Ich bin ein bisschen zu weitführend. Ich denke da über verschiedene Baukonstellationen nach, weil ich jetzt quasi die nächste Generation meines mobilen Studios damit bauen möchte. Das ist ja eigentlich das, worum es geht. Und was halt hier wirklich sehr schön ist bei dem Teil, was auch echt ein Killer-Argument ist und wo ich mich auch wirklich frage, warum das nicht einfach jeder hat mittlerweile. Du kannst halt auf USB-Sticks aufnehmen. Multi-Track. Einfach so.
Unkodiert, er brät es einfach raus.
Genau. Er schreibt da irgendwie seine WAF-Files oder was das genau ist. BWF oder so. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht so genau. Ist zwar nur FAT32, also jetzt hier auch kein EXFAT und kein VODO und so weiter. Kein ZFS. Kein ZFS, nichts. Das kann mir dann auch herzlich wurscht sein. Hauptsache er schreibt und du steckst halt vorne deinen USB-Stick ran, der einfach die richtige Kapazität haben sollte für deine Aufnahme. Und dann kannst du eben in dem ganzen Setup sagen, welche Kanäle aufgenommen werden sollen. Du kannst halt nicht nur irgendwelche Eingabe-Kanäle aufzeichnen, sondern du kannst im Prinzip auch alle Mix-Kanäle, die du machst. Also du kannst nicht nur zum Zeitpunkt des Eingangs, sondern auch zum Zeitpunkt des Ausgangs aufnehmen. Also du kannst sagen, das was hier über den Main rausgeht oder das was hier zum Kopfhörer geht oder das was hier zum Adat geht oder so, nimm auf. Und damit kannst du halt Mixen machen, du kannst aber auch die einzelnen Spuren machen. Du kannst also auch gleichzeitig multitrack die einzelnen Mikrofone und aber, weil es so schön war, auch nochmal den Mix, den du da konkret erzeugt hast und vielleicht auch nochmal einen anderen Mix und was weiß ich mit und ohne Kompressor, Pipapo. Das kannst du halt alles auf USB schreiben und du brauchst halt keinen Rechner.
Das ist schon ganz cool, weil du nur vorne sagst, kannst du auch beides gleichzeitig machen?
Ja.
So als Backup sozusagen, weil das wäre natürlich dann die optimalste Lösung.
Ja logisch, das eine schließt das andere nicht aus. Also ich sehe es jetzt wirklich als Backup vor allem, weil so habe ich das bisher auch gemacht, nur dass ich halt noch einen externen Recorder hatte, der dann nochmal beim optischen Kabel angeschlossen war und es ist halt alles so, Kabel, Gebimsel, kann kaputt gehen, geht auch kaputt.
Was kaputt gehen kann, geht auch kaputt.
Ja, oder wenn es nicht kaputt geht, fängt es auf einmal an sich erratisch zu verhalten. So wie ich das jetzt gerade habe. Ich schließe das Ding irgendwie an und er sagt halt kein Signal. So was wie kein Signal. Es kommt Licht raus irgendwie, dann muss da auch ein Signal sein, aber es ist alles total gaga. Naja, wie auch immer. Ich habe das jetzt erst mal so erhalten und denke, dass jetzt von seinem technischen Setup her, also wie es aufzusetzen ist, schon ganz gut verstanden zu haben. Nur jetzt muss man es halt machen und vor allem ist es halt auch der Sprung, so ein bisschen ins kalte Wasser, weil ich mit dem Gerät mich auch im Prinzip darauf einlasse, die ganze Expansion und Kompression im Gerät zu fahren. Also es ist halt allerlei DSP-Klimpen da drin, damit kann man das irgendwie machen. Habe ich so bisher nicht gemacht. Vielleicht klingt es besser, mal schauen. Aber vor allem ist halt immer so eine Frage mit User Interface-Controls und wie kriegst du das eingestellt. Eigentlich schätze ich das, wenn du so ein separates Teil hast und du hast da so die Regler. Du drehst da einfach mal eben so ein bisschen. Da war jetzt der Expander so ein bisschen zu früh in der Ansprache. Klack, so ein kleiner Dreh an so einem Knopf, das hat schon was. Und das hätte ich eigentlich gerne wieder. Da muss ich dann halt einen Rechner haben, wo dann diese TotalMix-Software drauf fährt und dann musst du da in so einem völlig unübersichtlichen 1000-Channel-Strip-Interface die richtige Stelle finden, um das irgendwie einzustellen.
Das schaffst du schon, Tim.
Ja, im Prinzip will ich es darüber dann nochmal weg abstrahieren, dass ich halt auf so einem iPad mir so mein Custom-Interface mache, dann mit OSC und so. Naja, aber das ist glaube ich noch ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik. We'll see.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall ein schönes Gerät. Aber ich dachte, es hätte 8 Eingänge, also Preamps, aber es hat nur 4.
Es hat 4 Preamps und es hat nochmal 8 analoge. Also du hast halt 4 Mix- oder Analog-Line-Innen und dann nochmal 8 nochmal Line-Innen.
Aber nicht XLR.
Nicht XLR, aber halt balanced Klinke, also läuft ja aufs gleiche raus. Also mit XLR meinst du Mikro.
Ja, Mikro-Preamp.
Nee, aber du kannst dann wiederum die Kapazität auch leicht erhöhen. Du kannst ja natürlich nochmal so ein Preamp kaufen und den einfach mit ADAT daran...
Ja, bei dem Focus-Ride zum Beispiel ist es, da habe ich ja 8 Preamps und da kann ich dann nochmal mit ADAT nochmal 8 sozusagen ranclenen, dass ich 16 habe.
Das heißt, hier würde es ja auf 12 rauslaufen.
Von RME gibt es natürlich auch noch einen reinen Mikro-Preamp, wo du halt hinten mit Klinke rausgehst, geht es in das Teil analog mit Klinke wieder rein und fertig.
Gibt es das nicht auch mit ADAT oder so?
Ja, aber ich glaube, es gibt es halt auch ohne ADAT, also reiner Preamp, der nichts anderes macht als zu preampen.
Ja, das machen ja die anderen auch, nur dass es... Ach nee, ja gut, du kriegst noch mehr Kanäle mit den anderen.
Ja, weil du halt da, ja. Aber er sagt ja hier was von 30 Kanälen, also das sind die vier, die da drin sind.
Das sind die vier vorne, dann zwei mal acht über ADAT, also 16 sind die 20, dann nochmal die acht analogen und dann fehlen noch zwei. Und dann noch ein AESA EBU.
Die kannst du also alle gleichzeitig benutzen. Das ist natürlich sportlich, das musst du erstmal schaffen.
Ja, und vor allem versprechen sie niedrige Latenz und halbwegs zuverlässigen Betrieb über USB. Einen Bug habe ich allerdings schon gefunden, das hat mir Heugi auch schon vorher gesagt, ich wollte es nicht glauben, aber es ist so und ich frage mich ernsthaft, was das Problem ist hier. Das Ding hat ja auch Firewire und ehrlich gesagt, ich würde es lieber mit Firewire betreiben, weil ich traue einfach USB derzeit auf dem Macintosh nicht über den Weg. Das ist ein Drama und das Ding ist, da bin ich jetzt leider vor der Sendung nicht mehr ganz mit dem Testen durch, aber es macht so den Eindruck, ich habe das hier in meinem Mac Pro angeschlossen, alles super. Ich schließe das hier mit dem Thunderbolt-to-Firewire-Adapter an und er meint irgendwie, can't list Firewire-Devices.
Jetzt ist die Frage, ist das jetzt ein RME-Problem oder ein Apple-Problem?
Das ist die Frage.
Also es gab ja da jetzt Thunderbolt-Update, ne?
Das ist aber schon installiert.
Das ist schon installiert, okay. Vielleicht gibt es noch eins.
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen bedrückend, weil ich habe hier durchaus schon Firewire-Devices dran betrieben, so ist es nicht. Also grundsätzlich funktioniert das ja auch. Nur in dem Zusammenhang mit diesem RME scheint es nicht zu gehen und da müsste man mal klären, was Sache ist.
Ja, und wer sozusagen die günstige Variante von einem vierkanaligen, also mit vier Mikro-Pre-Ems-Interface, USB und so weiter haben will, da gibt es ja von der Budget-Firma, im Vergleich zu RME zumindest, von Focusrite gibt es ja auch seit kurzem ein weiteres Scarlet-Gerät, was vier Mikro-Pre-Ems hat und ich muss echt sagen, ich bin diesen Focusrite, die haben ja zwar nicht so die DSP-Features und sind jetzt nicht so ganz Feature explodiert, wie diese RME-Firefaces und so, aber die klingen extrem gut und ich habe jetzt schon diverse von denen in den Händen gehabt, weil auch Freunde, die sich gekauft haben und die machen echt einen guten Job. Also ich kann das so für die Einstiegs-Begeisterten, die nach einem guten Klang und einem guten Interface suchen, die kann ich echt nach wie vor empfehlen. Da haben sie jetzt eben vor kurzem ihre Produktpalette so ein bisschen aufgebohrt noch und vorher gab es ja nur mit zwei Inputs und jetzt gibt es sie auch mit vier Preamps.
Tja, wenn sie auch gleich noch, da haben sie zwei Kopfhörerausgänge, warum machen sie nicht gleich vier rein? Das wäre echt mal innovativ. Ja, das verstehe ich immer nicht. Immer nur die Hälfte von denen, die man braucht da. Das wäre dann wirklich ein geiles Podcasting-Device. Du meinst dieses Scarlett 18i8, ne?
Ja, dieses Podcasting wird sich ja nicht durchsetzen.
Nein, nein, das stimmt.
Aber ich habe jetzt ja mit meinem achtkanaligen jetzt auch schon ganz viel aufgenommen und bin auch da nach wie vor schwer begeistert von. Also uneingeschränkte Kaufempfehlung für auch diese Focus Ride Produkte. Für wie gesagt die Einsteigerklasse wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich habe das haben wir aber auch schon mal erzählt. Ich habe ja so ein Moto-Teil. Das ist auch ganz schön, das einzige, du brauchst halt einen Treiber dafür.
Ja, das ist das schöne bei den Focus Rides. Also auf dem Mac brauchst du halt keine.
Ich habe das schon eine Weile. Damals war das noch nicht so üblich, dass die Treiber loskamen.
Du, das ist auch heute immer noch bei vielen Interfaces leider nicht üblich.
Ich glaube bei Moto ist es nach wie vor nicht üblich. Würde ich wahrscheinlich so auch heute nicht mehr kaufen, aber es tut gut und es klingt gut und es tut gut. Im Sinne von es tut halt. Es hatte damit noch keinen Aussetzer oder so.
Talking about podcasting, da muss ich noch mal was pluggen hier noch.
Hast du schon wieder einen neuen Podcast? Noch nicht?
Na ja, also, ich finde, so ein zweistelliges Podcast-Portfolio, das muss man schon irgendwie haben irgendwann.
Das gehört schon zum Ego dazu.
Ja klar, es ist ja steigern, nicht? Die Kurse müssen steigen. Das ist Wirtschaftswachstum einfach. Also, erstens habe ich einen Vortrag gehalten. Das ist wahrscheinlich für die meisten Leute jetzt keine News, aber ich denke, der Vollständigkeit halber sollte ich noch mal darauf verweisen. Auf der Republica und der ist auf YouTube dann sehr zeitnah hochgeladen worden, was sehr nett war. Leider ist so die Audioqualität, die Aufnahme an sich ist okay, aber ist halt leider ein bisschen leise.
Bei Konferenzen kann man aber auch immer nur das auch wieder, dieses Cup-Theoremen, es gehen immer nur zwei von drei Sachen. Gutes Netz, irgendwie gutes Programm, schlechte Aufnahmen, gute Aufnahmen, gutes Programm, schlechtes Netz, irgendwie, man kann nicht alles haben. Ja, ich glaube doch, dieses Cup-Theoremen aus dieser NoSQL-Zeit, aus dem Zeitalter, das finde ich sehr oft wieder in der Realität.
Choose two.
Ja, ich hab, wie soll das anders sein?
Nichts, was man nicht mit Ophohnik fixen könnte, oder?
Ich hab das auch schon gefixt, ich hab bloß das jetzt, also ich hab das Video da einmal durchlaufen lassen, danach klang es besser, aber ich hab das jetzt noch nicht wieder republikiert. Müsste ich vielleicht noch...
Ein schönes Wort in dem Zusammenhang, wenn man weiß, wie die Konferenz heißt.
Ja.
Genau. Ja, also wer Lust hat, schaut sich das vielleicht mal an. Der Link ist jetzt schon... Hast du den Link da gerade geschickt, Dennis? Ach so, du verschickst so ganz andere Sachen.
Der hat uns das gleich gesagt.
Dann zweitens, es gibt einen neuen Podcast-Client. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wie lange der schon im App-Store ist.
Das ist super.
Vielleicht mal darauf hinweisen, weil er nämlich auch aus Deutschland kommt. Und zwar heißt er treffenderweise Podcatcher.
Mit, das war ein 4R?
Mit ohne E, ja.
Mit ohne E und 4R, nein.
Ne, gerollt. Und Podcatcher. Ja, liegt auch schon in einer Version 1.1 vor. Ist noch nicht vollständig bugfrei. Aber ein frischer Ansatz zum Thema Podcasting auf dem iPhone macht auf jeden Fall ein paar Sachen anders. Ich habe jetzt leider da noch keinen intensiveren Test fahren können. Ich war auch irgendwann mal Beta-Tester, aber ich bin dann irgendwie komplett aus der Spur geworfen worden nach diesen ganzen Kaskaden von iPhone-Wechseln, wo dann immer wieder ein neuer UID ist und man irgendwie aus allen Beta-Programmen rausfliegt, weil man einfach, wissen schon, das alte Problem.
Kannst du das Video nicht auch noch in den Chat werfen?
Das wäre eigentlich auch so ein Service von Apple. Ich meine, wenn die wissen, dass ich ein neues iPhone mit einer neuen UID bekomme und die alle meine Beta-Geräte oder meine vorherigen Geräte bei sich eingetragen haben und dieses Jahr einkassieren, könnten sie doch eigentlich automatisch auch alle I.D.s gleich dort überall tauschen oder nicht?
Ja, könnte, könnte, könnte.
Die müssten das aber alles neu signieren und so weiter.
Stimmt, kann man eben nicht so einfach. Okay, hast recht.
Was wir in der letzten Sendung nur kurz angedeutet haben, weil es gerade erschienen, kann man auch nochmal kurz darauf hinweisen, Instacast auf dem Mac, die Public Beta, die läuft nach wie vor, hat sich auch schon ein paar Mal aktualisiert, hat jetzt auch ein paar nette Features dazu bekommen seit dem letzten Mal. Ich weiß gar nicht, wovon wir letztes Mal gesprochen hatten, aber es ist unter anderem auch dieses Flatter-Feature über Syncing jetzt mit dabei. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt auf seinem iPhone was hört und man hat den Instacast-Client auf dem Mac, dann kann das Hören, die Höraktivität auf dem iPhone trotzdem den Flatter-Trigger auf dem Mac anwerfen.
Ein Fuchs. Ein Fuchs der Maddin.
Ja, deiner Fuchs. Und man kann auch sagen, ob man sofort klettern will, wenn es angefangen hat zu spielen oder wenn es fertig ist oder nur wenn man halt fafft.
Oder wenn man die 60%-Stufe überschritten hat.
Genau. Ich hab's noch nicht so richtig überprüfen können, ob es auch funktioniert. Da müsste man nochmal etwas gezielter vorgehen. Aber ich schätz mal, das wird auch ein bisschen getestet worden sein. Und wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, sucht der Leute, die Lust haben, hier so Sharing-Plugins zu machen. Also wenn man mit irgendetwas in diesen Podcast-Client reinklinken will und Sharing in Netzwerk XY, dann könnte man das sozusagen...
Share this nach Pinterest oder so?
Ja, Share this nach Pinterest, Share this nach my new social network that nobody asked for.
Ja, an Pinterest, dass es das noch gibt, erkenne ich ja immer nur daran, dass sie ab und zu meine Mail schicken, was für neue Pins mich denn so interessieren könnten. Wobei ich das aber irgendwie spätestens nach einer halben Stunde aufgegeben hatte, dieses Pinterest, weil ich es nicht verstanden habe.
Was nicht verstanden?
Nicht so richtig. Mir war nicht so recht klar, wie man Sachen... Also irgendwie, du machst das Ding auf, machst dir einen Account und plötzlich ist der ganze Bildschirm voll mit Dingen, die dich nicht interessieren. Und dann fängst du an, ne, das will ich aber nicht sehen, ne, das will ich aber nicht sehen, ne, das will ich aber nicht sehen. Und dein Bildschirm wird nicht leerer. Es ist immer noch voll mit Zeug, was dich nicht interessiert. Und irgendwann machst du es dann wieder aus.
Weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, was du da jetzt gemacht oder nicht gemacht hast.
Ja, ich auch nicht mehr. Ich hab's halt dann ausgemacht.
Das ist nicht für alle.
Ja, ich war einer von ihnen.
Es gibt da definitiv ein Feature, was ich halt gerne... Also ich find das Follow-Modell von Pinterest extrem innovativ und das hätte ich auch gerne bei uptart.net.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist so das einzige Social-Media-Follower-Konzept, was da noch gar keinerlei Verankerungen hat.
Ich hab's mir noch gar nicht angeguckt. Ich hab kein Pinterest-Account.
Ja, also Pinterest ist schnell zusammengefasst. Pinterest ist, ich finde Dinge im Web und reposte die quasi auf Pinterest. Oder wie man so schön sagt, pinne die auf mein Board. Also du richtest da Boards ein, schnappst sozusagen diese Webseite. Dieser Schnappprozess, dieser Bookmark-Prozess ist dann aber immer noch verbunden mit so einem interaktiven Vorgang, wo du dann Bilder aus der Seite vorgeschlagen bekommst, die du dann auswählst, um so emblematisch für diesen Pin-Vorgang zu stehen, sodass das automatisch die Visualisierung ist. Davon ausgehend, dass du eigentlich auf nahezu jeder Webseite in irgendeiner Form irgendein Bild hast. Was ja meistens der Fall ist. Und dann tust du das auf dein Board. Und du kannst halt mehrere dieser Boards haben. Und das ist im Prinzip die Umkehr von dem Circle-Modell von Google+. Während du bei Google plus deine Leute in Circles packst und dann in diese Circles rein postest, damit ist diese Leute erreicht. Und dadurch eben auch andere, die nicht in den Circles sind, nicht erreicht. Du aber quasi immer wieder darüber nachdenken musst, wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich mein Freund in welchem Kontext und hab ich da jetzt eigentlich alle drin und fehlt da einer und so weiter.
Das ist doch funktional kaputt.
Das ist funktional total kaputt. Das ist mein Hauptkritikpunkt an Google plus, warum ich diesen ganzen Circle einfach für Quatsch halte. Ich weiß, das sehen andere anders, aber das ist nun mal meine Sicht.
Die arbeiten aber alle bei Google, glaub ich.
Ja, und bei Pinterest ist es halt andersrum. Bei Pinterest hast du quasi erst mal diese Information. Hier was interessant ist im Web. Also es ist ja weniger jetzt, ich schreib was, sondern mehr, ich finde was. Und das tust du dann in ein Board. Du kannst halt davon mehrere haben. Das erreicht jetzt so erst mal gar keinen. Andere Leute folgen dir dann, also Follower-Modell, was ja bei Google plus irgendwie auch im Prinzip so halbwegs mit drin ist. Nur, dass du halt wählst, welchen Board du wirklich folgen möchtest. Weil wenn ich jetzt dir zum Beispiel auf Pinterest folgen würde und du klickst jetzt fleißig Pins, Pins einfach Dinge, ja, dann hättest du wahrscheinlich ein Board Programmierung und ein Board Audio und ein Board Bier, so. Und vielleicht Musik. Und dann würd ich sagen, Musik lass ich mal raus, aber ich folge gerne Bier und ich folge gerne das, so. Und Andreas Burg hat auch Bier, aber hat auch Krypto und keine Ahnung. Das heißt, du folgst im Prinzip bestimmten Aspekten einer Person.
Du folgst dem Bier.
Und das ist halt, ich folg dem Bier. Und das ist das, was mir auch bei up.net so ein bisschen fehlt. Also es gibt da viele Leute, die finde ich interessant. Und dann merke ich aber, bei dir gibt es aber eigentlich nur einen Aspekt, der mich wirklich interessiert. Vielleicht zwei, aber definitiv dieser eine, der jetzt im Staccato bei mir einschlägt, der interessiert mich nicht.
Du meinst, dieser Baseball-Rotz von Gruber. Das ist so ein klassisches Beispiel. Warum ich aufgehört habe, Daring Fireball zu lesen, weil mich dieser Baseball-Rotz nicht interessiert.
Genau. Man möchte das eigentlich abonnieren und sagen, alles außer Baseball. Oder gerne Apple, aber nicht das. Und gerne auch deine anderen Sachen, wenn du mal über die Privatsphäre und die TSA irgendwie meckerst. Weißte doch, ne? Genau.
Das sind diese Grappler in Amerika.
Genau, die Grappler. Aber halt nicht Baseball, weil kein Bild, kein Ton. Spieß das Händeschloss in den 70ern.
Ja, die haben blöde Klamotten an.
Ja, und alle waren in Mützen.
Jersey heißen die.
Die Mützen?
Nein, diese Klamotten. Hab ich gelernt bei Silver Linings Playbook.
Aber habt ihr das jetzt mit diesem Follower-Prinzip... Und angenommen, ich könnte jetzt bei up.net in meinem Client immer einen aktuellen, ich würde das jetzt nicht Board nennen, sondern Kontext, Mood, was auch immer einstellen. Aspekt, genau. Also ich sage, ich poste hier was und ich poste jetzt was in dem Kontext X. Niemand wird gezwungen, das zu machen. Niemand wird gezwungen, einen Aspekt auszuwählen. So, aber man kann zumindest dann sagen, ah, hier gibt es die und die Aspekte und wahrscheinlich sorgt sich diese Person auch so halbwegs darum, Posts einen bestimmten Aspekt zuzuordnen. Dann hätte ich gerne die, die aus dem Kontext sind und so weiter. Und vielleicht bei default gibt es auch keinen, aber man kann halt auch einen wählen.
Ja, das heißt dann, die ganzen Piraten, die wählen keinen Kontext aus und dann...
Damit man dir einen Scheiß liest.
Folgst du Piraten?
Nicht mehr. Ja, doch.
Gutes Beispiel. Piraten könnten einfach alles in ihrem Piraten-Kontext machen. Ohne jetzt immer wieder an jedes Ding Lattenzaun Piraten ran schreiben zu müssen.
Wir brauchen Smart Agents, die das automatisch machen.
Du hast 1500 Follower in Allgemein und zwei in Piraten.
Wollen wir noch über Piraten reden?
Nein, leider nicht. Die sind doch jetzt abgelöst von dieser anderen Bude, oder?
Was willst du da groß ranten?
Wobei ich von diesen Piraten ranten, eigentlich die Berliner fast so ein bisschen ausnehmen würde, weil was die so im Abgeordnetenhaus treiben, das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Das ist ja wie bei allen Parteien so. Also umso kleiner du runtergehst bei denen, umso besser wird's. Also ich meine, es gibt ja kleine Dörfer, da arbeiten die ja prima, grün, SPD, also schwarz, rot, weiß nicht, alle Farben super zusammen. Aber gehst du weiter nach oben bis zur Bundesebene, da wird alles nur noch müllig. Und wahrscheinlich ist es bei den Piraten auch so. Wenn wir die Einzelnen unten angucken, was sie für Arbeit machen, ist bestimmt alles super. Aber sie kriegen es halt bundesweit nicht geregelt.
Das war es jetzt aber auch mit denen.
Okay, kommen wir wieder zur Technik. Wir wollen nicht wirklich jetzt über Piraten reden.
Nee, nee, das haben wir gar nicht. Nein, nein, nein. Niemand hat die Absicht, über Piraten zu reden.
Okay, es gibt da noch ein neues Programm. Und ich wundere mich, dass wir da nicht schon seit längerem drüber gesprochen haben. Ich weiß gar nicht seit wann gibt es denn das. Dennis, das sagt dir doch was. Hast du schon mal ausprobiert?
Nee, ich hab mir nur das Zeug dadurch gelesen.
Und?
Da war irgendwas, was ich blöd fand, dann hab ich aufgehört zu lesen.
Also vielleicht kurze Schilderung, worum es sich dabei handelt aus meiner Perspektive. Es ist so eine Art... Aber Vergleiche sind immer schlecht. Aber es geht darum, Dateien zu sharen permanent. So wie man das unter anderem auch mit Dropbox realisieren kann. Nur bei Dropbox und bei vergleichbaren Diensten bedeutet das immer erst mal Datei von meinem Rechner auf Server und von dort auf alle anderen, die daran auch noch teilhaben. bit.org und Sync ist jetzt eine Applikation, die installierst du. Und dann kannst du einen neuen Ordner anlegen und für diesen Ordner erzeugst du zwei Hashes, zwei komische Zeichenketten, wo Foo, Krypto, Foo, bit.org und Foo drin ist. Die Kenntnis des einen ermöglicht an einem beliebigen anderen Rechner weltweit, auch bit.org und Sync zu betreiben und dann Read-Write-Access auf deinen Ordner zu bekommen. Und dann sind die halt einfach immer gesynced. Ich schmeiße dann die Datei in diesen Ordner und automatisch alle bit.org und Sync Instanzen, die diesen Read-Write-Hash kennen, können da auch was reinschreiben und werden gesynced. Und der zweite Hash ist Read-Only. Das heißt, du kannst dir einen Ordner auf deiner Platte machen und sagen, ich hab hier so einen Ordner, da sind so Dateien drin. Und wen es interessiert und wer diese Dateien jetzt auch immer in dieser aktuellen Form genauso auf seinem Rechner haben will, der installiert sich bit.org und Sync. Und hier ist euer Hash und ihr könnt da zwar nicht reinschreiben, aber ihr könnt immer sozusagen den aktuellen Stand dieses Ordners, wer auch immer definiert, was der Inhalt davon ist. Manche haben Read-Write-Key, manche haben ihn halt nicht.
Das ist nicht Single Sign-On, oder? Das heißt, wenn du mir so ein Passwort gibst und ich verteile es an 1000 Leute, können alle 1000 Leute das Gleiche tun und du kriegst es nicht mal richtig mit?
Ja, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dürfte ich nichts davon...
Okay, aber es ist sowieso so, weil wenn ich die Dateien von dir hab, hätte ich sie ja auch so weiterschieben können. Also ob sie es nun von dir holen und an dem Netzwerk mitmachen oder ich sie so weiterschiebe, ist dann auch egal.
Ja, aber das Read-Write-Passwort, da kannst du natürlich bei ihm im Ordner trollen.
Ja gut, aber das geht auch mit jedem anderen Login-Kram auch.
Ja, stimmt schon. Da muss aber immer mindestens eine andere Instanz gleichzeitig online sein, weil es ja keinen Server gibt.
Genau, also das ist eben...
Ist aber gut und auch schlecht, also kann man ja auch ausnutzen, wenn es irgendwie Security-Probleme gibt, machst du es halt aus, zack, dann ist es aus.
Ja, ich meine nur, das ist halt eine Randbedingung.
Ja genau, es funktioniert anders, aber es funktioniert halt auch ohne zentrale Instanz, ohne bezahlen.
Ja, hast du schon genutzt?
Ausprobiert hab ich's. Genutzt wär jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben, weil ich ehrlich gesagt noch ein wenig grübel, was so die Anwendung sein kann.
Ja, du hast ja gesagt, soll dafür schnell mal was irgendwo zu einem anderen schieben.
Na gut, da hat natürlich Dropbox schon so seine Vorteile.
Bei mir nicht, weil ich hab keinen Dropbox.
Ja, siehst du mal, bei dir... Wir könnten uns mal eine Mobile-Max-Ordner machen.
Zum Beispiel.
Die Frage ist nur, was tun wir da rein, ne? Affenbilder.
Na den Porn, den wir sonst auch immer tauschen. Mach doch einfach mal eine Mobile-Max, die alle Sendungen rein irgendwie, nur mal so zum Testen. Und dann publishst du das Read-Only. In ADN. Und schiebst dann...
Oh, für FreeBSD gibt's das auch.
Ist ja gut. Um sozusagen so ein komplettes Archiv zu...
Ja, dann brauchst du die neuste Sendung immer nur reinschieben. So ist dein Bit-Tor und dein Bit-Lav. Siehst du, du kannst alles jetzt über die Tonne treten. Die haben das mal für dich gelöst. Du schmeißt einfach immer nur die neuste Datei rein. Und der Fisch ist geputzt.
Na ja, gut, da kommt natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr dazu.
Ja, stimmt, du hast dann deine Stats nicht. Aber ansonsten so grundsätzlich. Hast du aufgegeben?
Nee, ich verpeil mich bloß am laufenden Meter. Bei meinem System-Setup hab ich gerade wieder festgestellt, dass ich seit Anfang des Jahres keine Lockfalls geschrieben habe. Ja, ich muss mein Admin-Modell mal umstellen. Aber das ist eine andere Frage. Mir geht es nicht so sehr am Stats, sondern mir geht es darum, dass natürlich jetzt niemand oder es ist kaum jemand, sagen wir andersrum, das Interesse daran, immer eine Kopie aller Sendungen zu haben, dürfte jetzt nicht so sehr verbreitet sein. Ja, es ist ein interessantes Backup-Konzept.
Man kann sich da nicht ein bestimmtes Teil von aussuchen, dann von den ganzen Sachen?
Na Ordner ist Ordner.
Aber kann man, weil bei BitTorrents kann man ja sagen...
Also Ordner ist immer der ganze Ordner mit all seinen Zapfholtern, also alles.
Weil bei dem normalen BitTorrent kann man ja auch das Torrent drunter laden und dann kommt ja so ein Vorfenster so, was man jetzt wirklich laden will. Und dann lade ich hier halt irgendwie die dicke Staffel runter, sage, die erste Staffel habe ich schon gesehen und hake die weg und lade nur noch den Rest oder so.
Das ist halt dann SYNC. Das ist dann halt einfach da. Aber ich kann mir schon durchaus Szenarios vorstellen, wo das eben sinnvoll ist und wo vor allem BitTorrent seine Vorteile ausspielt. Weil erstmal hast du natürlich, gerade wenn viele daran teilnehmen, ganz anderen Speed. Du bist eben unabhängig von so einem USA-Ding.
Das ist halt dezentral.
Aber ist das nicht vielleicht sogar... Also ich habe ja mal gehört, dass Facebook, ich glaube es war Facebook, zum Beispiel ihre ganzen Config-Files für ihre ganzen Server über BitTorrent verteilt. Also wenn unpublished, vielleicht benutzen die am Ende BitTorrent SYNC dafür. Weil das wäre eigentlich ganz geil.
Aber BitTorrent SYNC ist ja noch ganz neu.
Genau, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie neu das ist. Warte mal, das steht doch bestimmt in der Wikipedia. Priviorelease, es gibt wohl gerade ein neues. 24. Januar. Naja, ist halt auch nicht wirklich so, also ist halt jetzt nicht open source, also ist jetzt nicht in demselben Sinne wie BitTorrent so wohl dokumentiert, sondern es handelt sich hierbei eben jetzt um ein Produkt der Firma BitTorrent. Muss man auch noch mal bedenken. Das heißt, man braucht eben die passenden Binary's.
Das Binary Only.
Wie sagtest du, Odi, sagst du nicht gerade, es gibt auch was für FreeBSD, weil das habe ich bisher noch nicht gesehen.
Also wenn ich hier auf das Download gehe, dann steht da Download für Windows, Download für Mac und dann gibt es da unten Linux and NAS-Devices und dann gibt es da NAS-Devices und dann gibt es da Linux in diversen Ausführungen und FreeBSD.
Nerds halt. Wo gehört sich das?
Nerdses.
Bei Linux muss man erstmal die richtige G-Lib-C aussuchen.
Brauche diesen Lektar los, gib mir den mal schnell.
Du klickst einfach da in das Experiment Sync HTML. Da im Chat war das doch, LabSpit. Und dann drückst du den Download-Button und dann bekommst du dieses Ding.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Variante, einfach um jetzt Backups von Servern zu halten. Also wenn man jetzt eben so ein Mirroring machen will von so einem kompletten Web-Verzeichnis, einfach nur, ich will es woanders auch haben, dann ist es eben very easy. Sofern es gut funktioniert. Und um diese ganze Nut-Problematik zu umgehen......
was gerade gedrosselt ist.
Ja gut, da können Sie jetzt auch nichts dran drehen. Hab ich es richtig verstanden habe, setzen Sie eben auch Ihre eigenen Trecker ein in dem Moment, wo eine unmittelbare Peer-to-Peer-Kommunikation so nicht möglich ist. Und natürlich auch für dieses Initial-Auffinden benutzen Sie da entsprechende Trecker. Also, ich schätze mal, die melden sich an so einem zentralen Trecker an und sagen hier, ich will haben Hasch sowieso und dann, wie das eben bei BitTorrent auch sonst läuft, nur dass der Hasch eben der Code für den Ordner ist und nicht für die Dateien. Und dann können Sie aber auch über dieses Server auch Nut Traversal, so S-Tun-Server-Support und diesen ganzen Climb-Bim machen. Was ich nicht weiß, ist, ob Sie irgendwie V6 nutzen. Ich könnte es mir gut vorstellen, aber ich glaube, das steht da nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist bei denen so normal, dass sie es gar nicht extra erwähnen müssen, glaube ich, oder wollen.
Vermutlich. Ich bin jetzt durch.
Ja, na ja, irgendwer wird es schon reversen.
Oder?
Ja, und? Habt ihr eure Adblocker jetzt alle wieder ausgeschaltet?
Du, ich hatte gar keine Adblocker, aber...
Dann hattest du welche.
Du musst sagen, erstens hatte ich einen Click-to-Flash. Was irgendwie ja auch schon so ein 70% Adblocker ist. Also ich meine, wenn man Flash ausschaltet, dann kriegt man die meisten Ads nicht mehr, besonders die, die nervt. Das sind, weil sie blinken. Und dann hatte ich dieses, es gibt so ein Tool, ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, wie das heißt, wo du dieses ganze Getrack von irgendwelchen Sachen. Ghostory. Genau, und wenn man das anmacht, dann funktionieren auch die meisten Ads nicht mehr, weil das Tracking der App-Netzwerke nicht mehr funktioniert und dann zeigen sie einem auch irgendwie kaum noch Ads an. Also insofern, keine Ahnung. Ich hab auch nie gesehen diesen Hinweis, dass man seinen Adblocker ausschalten soll.
Den hab ich auch nicht gesehen mit meinem Adblocker.
Das ist alles an mir vorbeigegangen und vor allen Dingen...
Ja, also ich benutze tatsächlich den Adblocker schon lange. Früher hab ich meinen Glimmerblocker benutzt, aber der hatte so ein V6-Problem mal eine Zeit lang. Und Ghostory, das sind so meine beiden Blocker. Und ich hab auch, ich glaub, vor ein, zwei Sendungen hab ich ja auch mal erzählt, dass ich, oder ich hab's zumindest getwittert, dass ich auch mal Adblock was gespendet hab. Weil ich dann mal beim Kollegen gesehen hab, wie das Internet oder das Web ohne Adblocker aussieht. Und dachte mir, okay, dieses Tool, das spart mir jeden Tag größere Schmerzen. Die kriegen jetzt mal ein paar Euros.
Aber jetzt bist du doch ein schmieriger Raubkopierer, der die kostenlosen Inhalte von Zeitungen stielt.
Ich lese keine Zeitungen im Internet. Wenn die kein Flatter-Button irgendwo hinkleben, ist das ihr Problem.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Ja, also was waren das für Zeitungen, die das jetzt ange...
Sponnen Zeit.
Spiegel online? Okay, dann blockt mein Adblocker das wirklich.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, also Zeit zum Beispiel ist sowas, das klicke ich nur noch extrem ungern. Weil meistens kriegst du halt so einen Link über Twitter und ich lese Twitter in der Regel oder ADN in der Regel über ein iOS-Device. Und wenn du dann auf einen Zeitlink klickst, kriegst du als erstes diese bekloppte Frage, ob du denn jetzt wirklich die volle Version oder nur die abgespeckte Version sehen willst. Und zwar wirklich jedes Mal.
Abgespeckte Version von wo?
Von der Webseite.
Ach so, mobil. Ja, so nach dem Motto, wir wissen nicht, was responsive design ist und deswegen musst du entscheiden, wie...
Und schon allein dafür bräuchte es mal einen Blocker. Für dieses Pop-Up willst du die mobile Seite sehen oder willst du unsere App runterladen? Oder willst du, weißt du, dieser ganze Schrott. Ich meine, was soll ich denn auf so eine Seite gehen, die mir als erstes einen modalen Dialog entgegengeschmeißt? Das ist doch irgendwie, das steht doch schon im Vorwort von der Apple Hic drin, dass es modale Dialoge bäh sind.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, also ich kann schon verstehen, dass Sie da jetzt nicht so glücklich sind, wenn alle Leute die tollen Ads blocken, aber...
Ja, wenn's mal tolle Ads wären.
Ja, okay, gut, das ist die nächste Frage.
Das ist ja das Problem. Also ich mein, das haben Sie sich ja doch erst damit eingetreten.
Aber ich blocke die Ads so lange, bis sie mal auf die Idee kommen, vielleicht dieses Internet so zu umarmen und da sich irgendwie sind volle Geldverwertungsmodelle, wie auch immer, auszudenken. Also ich weiß nicht, ich sehe nicht, dass Werbung die Lösung ist.
An welchen würdest du denn teilnehmen?
Na, wenn, also ich mein, Flatter kann ja auch nur der erste Schritt gewesen sein. Also ich stell mir das ja schon vor, dass das prinzipiell vielleicht auch noch mal ein bisschen besser funktionieren könnte. Oder weiter verbreitet sein könnte. So im Groben. Oder keine Ahnung, irgendwie in irgendeiner Form überhaupt das attraktiv machen, irgendwie zu bezahlen für Sachen, die ich viel konsumiere, für Spiegel Online. Könnte ich mir das tatsächlich sogar vorstellen, aber ich hab schon mal... Also nee, gibt's da überhaupt einen Weg für Spiegel Online direkt zu bezahlen?
Ganz ehrlich, und dann gibt's diese Paywall, wo dann wollen sie jetzt zwei Euro für diesen Artikel bezahlen. Nein, will ich nicht. Ist es mir nicht wert. Danke, ich mach sie dazu.
Also für zwei Euro ein Artikel, da kriegst du ja sonst ein ganzes Wurstblatt dafür.
Also bei Sponnen ist halt der Content auf der Webseite eigentlich immer kostenlos. Sie hatten früher mal dieses, oh hier, alter Artikel, wirft eine Münze ein. Das hat natürlich überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Ja, aber wie wärs denn mal mit, erstmal anfangen überhaupt so mit diesem Freiwilligen bezahlen. Das können sie doch überhaupt, also das juckt sie doch überhaupt nicht. Sie können einfach sagen, hier, du bist hier jeden Tag so, du kannst, wir können dir irgendwie in der Site einblenden, Alter, du warst diesen Monat 526 Mal auf dieser Seite und hast nun so viele Artikel geklickt, ja. Das können sie ja alles irgendwie selber mal einblenden und so. Hast du nicht Bock irgendwie uns dafür vielleicht so ein Euro oder so?
Wird nicht funktionieren.
Ist ja egal, du, aber das, also das juckt sie doch nicht. Das können sie doch mal machen. So, dann kriegen sie vielleicht so ein paar Euro darüber schon mal rein und können sehen, wie es funktioniert. Nee, nee, aber sie verstehen das nicht. Nee, ich erwarte vom 21. Jahrhundert echt mehr. Ich erwarte, dass die jetzt mal von ihren komischen alten Verwertungskonzepten von physischen Kopien und von irgendwie verkauften Einheiten und so wegkommen.
Na gut, das kann man Spiegel Online jetzt nicht gerade vorwerfen, weil die waren irgendwie... Doch, Spiegel Online war überhaupt die erste News-Seite im Web.
Naja, in Deutschland vielleicht.
Nee.
Jetzt mal von Heise vielleicht abgesehen.
Nee, Spiegel war richtig, richtig early, early, super early, aber richtig early.
Die waren early, aber bestimmt nicht die ersten.
Die waren unter Garantie unter den ersten zehn.
Die ersten, die ersten.
Ja, darüber müssen wir uns jetzt nicht streiten.
Ja, aber trotzdem, also für mich gibt's da irgendwie keinerlei Anreize oder irgendwie Möglichkeiten, überhaupt immer so ein Euro zukommen zu lassen für irgendwas.
25. Oktober.
Und ich laden...
94.
Ja, ist ja gut. Ich lad jetzt auch kein...
Es ist früh.
Es ist früh. Aber ich lad jetzt trotzdem keine iPad-App runter auf'm iPad, wo ich sowieso kaum jetzt so News konsumiere, nur um den Geld zu geben für ihre digitalen Inhalte. Und ich kauf mir auch nicht den PDF-Spiegel.
Ja gut, was du alles nicht tun würdest, das hab ich jetzt schon gehört. Die Frage ist, was...
Hat er doch gesagt, was er tun würde.
Nee, er hat nur gesagt, es wäre ja schön, wenn vielleicht irgendwann mal unter Umständen vielleicht mit Flatter irgendwas...
Nein, nicht mit Flatter, er hat gesagt, die sollen da was machen, dass er dort für freie Inhalte bezahlen kann.
Einfach Geld geben, einfach, mit einem Klick PayPal, was auch immer, irgendwas einfaches, wo jeder sowieso schon einen Account hat. Weißt du, wo du nicht jetzt bei Spiegel dir einen Account anlegen musst, wo du nicht nochmal eine Kreditkarte bei Spiegel angeben musst.
Und nicht wo sie zwei Euro pro Artikel haben wollen.
Wo sie nicht eher sowas wie hier irgendwie Monat, was auch immer oder im Jahr einmal so, wisst ihr, so Flicker, irgendwie du gibst uns im Jahr irgendwie einfach 30, 50 Dollar, was auch immer und dafür kriegst du hier alles werbefrei, alles irgendwie Access-All-Areas, Access-All-Archives, kriegst eine tolle Suche, was auch immer.
Ohne Werbung!
Ja, ich versuch nur diese Diskussion so ein bisschen nachzuversprechen.
Aber mir geht eigentlich total gegen den Strich, dass die einfach auch sich, also du kannst jetzt sagen, ja okay sie haben eine iPad-App und sie verkaufen den Print-Spiegel als PDF und das ist alles ganz toll, aber mich erreicht das überhaupt nicht.
Na, aber trotzdem klickst du darauf rum.
Ja, ich klick auf Spiegel Online. Aber ich sehe nicht, dass die Überwerbung jetzt diesen Service da von mir finanziert bekommen.
Das sehen die auch, dass sie das nicht über sich...
Genau, deswegen erwarte ich jetzt von denen, dass sie einfach mal ein bisschen nachdenken und sich dieses 21. Jahrhundert so im Total Perspective Vortex mal kurz auf sich einwirken lassen und mal drüber nachdenken, wie können wir den Leuten irgendwie die Möglichkeit geben, dass sie uns Geld geben?
Und dann haben sie Adblock-Werbung gemacht, vollkommen.
Sie haben gesagt, beschalt deinen Adblocker aus.
Und dann haben ganz viele den eingeschaltet.
Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, ich hab hier den Flashblocker drin und hab jetzt auf Spiegel geguckt, hab jetzt auf der Süddeutschen geguckt und hab jetzt auf Zeit Online geguckt und ich sehe hier keine Werbung. Warum? Weil das alles stinkende Flash-Scheiße ist. Weißt du, wenn sie da einfach nur eine unbewegte Grafik von irgendwas hin machen würden, kleinen Hinweis, Werbung, was weiß ich, kauf deinen Eon Strom oder frisst deine links drehenden Milchsäure, Bakterien, Joghurt, XY oder weiß ich nicht, dann wär das auch alles okay, dann würd ich auch die Werbung sehen. Aber da sie es halt wirklich übertreiben müssen und da gleich so eine Flash-Scheiße reinmachen müssen, ist halt Feierabend mit Ad.
Na, animated GIF ist halt letztes Jahr 1000.
Und eins sag ich dir mal, wenn Spiegel online Flatterbutton da hin machen würde, also die würden da ja wohl irgendwie amtlich Klicks absahnen. Also ich mein, das würde nicht reichen, um ihren Betrieb zu finanzieren, aber das wäre halt...
Wer weiß.
Wer weiß, aber die würden derartig viele Klicks da kriegen und zwar gerne von vielen Leuten, die da jenen... Also ich klick zum Beispiel bei der Taz, ich klick selten genug auf Taz, weil irgendwie selten genug mich irgendein Link oder Artikel auf taz.de erreicht, aber wenn ich mal klicke und da ist ein Artikel und ich dachte mir so, cool, hier klicke ich so und ich weiß, vielleicht als Limited Scope und so und Pipapo, schon das alleine würde ich tausendmal lieber machen als irgendwie diese scheiß Werbung zu ertrangen.
Ich würde Spiegel online vielleicht sogar auf Flatter abonnieren.
Das ist wirklich schlimm.
Das ist auch schlimm.
Das hat dazu gebracht, dass ich sie irgendwie nicht mehr mit Flatter bediene.
Ja, genau, das ist halt so das Ding, dass sie halt irgendwie, ich versteh das auch nicht, warum das so so ein Krampf ist für diese ganzen...
Weil es keine einfachen Antworten gibt. Das kann man an deinen Antworten jetzt auch schon ganz gut ablesen, weil dieses Irgendwie, Irgendwas, Irgendwie und keiner weiß eigentlich genau was, den punkteilen die halt auch.
Nee, aber wirklich irgendwie für den Service. Also ich meine, mit Cookies bist du doch auch drei, vier Wochen auf so einer News-Seite eingeloggt, du musst dein Scheißpasswort nicht einmal eingeben, die können auch einfach sagen, hier gibt es auch einmal Jahres-Abo oder was auch immer Jahres, full access all areas, pro Account spiegeln online, was auch immer, zahl uns 50 Dollar und dann lassen wir dich ein ganzes Jahr in Ruhe und du hast ein gutes Gefühl dabei, bitte jetzt hier mit PayPal oder mit was auch immer bezahlen, das würden Leute tun, das würde ich tun. Das kostet die überhaupt nur ein müdes Lächeln irgendwie, das mal zu implementieren und zu probieren, aber einfach irgendwie jetzt so, da schaltet doch euer Adblocker aus. Was ist denn das für ein...
Und ich denke mal, es geht überhaupt eher nach hinten los, oder? Mal ehrlich, ausgeschaltet hat das niemand und eingeschaltet jetzt eine ganze Menge.
Irgendjemand hatte getweetet, er hätte einen Anruf von seiner Mutter gekriegt. Wie wäre denn das mit diesem Adblocker, für den da geworben wird? Wie installiere ich denn den?
Die Adblocker haben selbst gesagt, dass Adblock plus, da wo sie manche Werbung, die wohl okay sind, zulassen, wenn die sich die Verlage daran halten, dass da irgendwie einen Peak von plus 125 Prozent an Installationen wäre oder an Downloads. Und Spenden auch irgendwie sich verdoppelt in der Zeit.
Mehr als verdoppelt.
Also ich meine, das war die totale Adblock plus und nur Adblock irgendwie Werbung. Ich weiß nicht, irgendwas haben die da getrollt.
Jetzt stell dir vor, sie machen mal eine Woche lang so irgendwie so ein Overlay und sagen hier Fletter, hier Jahrespro-Account, was auch immer, wie sie es nennen. Das machen Leute, das ist ja irgendwie, es ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute nicht sehen, dass irgendwie das Arbeit oder irgendeine wertvolle Geschichte ist, oder irgendwie ein Gegenwert liefert. Aber es versucht halt auch keiner.
Ja vielleicht muss man auch einfach den Paradigmenwechsel akzeptieren und sagen, ja das mit der Presse war eine nette Idee, das hat jetzt 150 Jahre funktioniert und jetzt ist es halt vorbei.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, das funktioniert schon, aber ich glaube, man muss halt jetzt mal irgendwie wirklich 21. Jahrhundert embracen und von dieser physikalischen Kopie und Verkaufseinheit und so wegkommen.
Das kann man jetzt online nicht vorwerfen.
Der Print ist doch komplett...
Doch ich werfe denen das vor, weil es geht aktuell auf dieser Webseite nicht, dass ich sagen kann, hier ein Jahr 50 Dollar, lasst mich in Ruhe mit Werbung, gib mir Access All Areas und Archivo und so.
Du würdest 50 Dollar im Jahr zahlen?
Das ist eine Seite, die ich jeden Tag mehrfach aufrufe. Klar, warum nicht 50 Dollar im Jahr?
Aber vielleicht rufst du sie nur auf, weil sie kostenlos ist?
Nee, weil ich habe schon viele von diesen komischen News-Seiten probiert. Ich habe auch echt krampfhaft versucht, wegzukommen von Spiegel Online. Aber was gibt es denn da? FR Online, also Frankfurter Rundschau, was gibt es noch? Zeit, aber sie sind alle, man muss halt Spiegel sagen, sie machen es einfach gut auch. Da ist viel Panorama bei und viel Schrott auch und irgendwie halbnackte Frauen, die irgendwelche Klicks ziehen bestimmt. Aber die anderen News-Seiten, die stinken halt. Ich finde Spiegel Online extrem nett zu konsumieren, auch wenn das halt so ein bisschen in den Boulevard abrutscht.
Kleiner Hinweis am Rande, FR Online auch keine Werbung mit Flashblocker. Also ich meine, der Flashblocker ist halt auch ein Adblocker irgendwie.
Und ja, deswegen, also ich zum Beispiel würde jetzt glaube ich sagen, wenn Spiegel Online mir die Möglichkeit bieten würde, einfach und ohne großen Häseln, ohne extra jetzt groß irgendwie nochmal Bezahloptionen zu haben, einfach mit so einem Paypal-Button zu sagen, hier bitte, zack.
Was ist denn der Grund, warum die bei Spiegel keinen Flatter haben? Was ist denn an Flatter schwer? Die klicken sich da in den Count bei Flatter, packen einen Button oben in, die müssen es erstmal noch nicht mal pro Artikel machen und dann wäre die Sache doch erstmal durch. Das kostet die doch gar nichts, oder? Das ist doch in 10 Minuten gemacht. Theoretisch.
Soll ich da mal was zu sagen? Also man kann zu Flatter halt als Kritik immer noch anbringen. Ich klicke meinen Flatter-Click und dann habe ich das gute Gefühl, ich habe jetzt alles getan und derjenige, der den Flatter-Click kriegt, der kriegt halt mal 5 Cent, mal 10 Cent, aber viel ist es nicht. Und die Bereitschaft der Leute, dann darüber hinaus noch irgendwas zu geben, ist halt dann wahrscheinlich null oder ist zumindest wesentlich kleiner als ohne den Flatter-Click.
Aber, ich finde das Flatter-Modell immer noch tausendmal besser als zum Beispiel das Spotify-Modell, wo zum Beispiel alle User irgendwie, was kostet Spotify im Monat, irgendwie zehn Euro oder was auch immer. Und dann höre ich irgendwie fünfmal dein Hunde, was wie war das, Hunde-Code-Lied auf Spotify, wenn du da überhaupt reinkommen würdest. Aber trotzdem kriegt Rihanna oder Lady Gaga meine ganzen zehn Euro, weil die halt, also weil der ganze Kuchen quasi nach Most Plays verteilt wird, wo dann gegenbei Flatter das wirklich so ist, wenn ich fünfmal dein Song klicke oder höre oder was auch immer, dann kriegst du halt meine ganzen fünf oder zehn Euro. Und das finde ich, den Ansatz finde ich schon viel fairer sozusagen, auch wenn das sich dann aufteilt auf die Anzahl aller Klicks, aber es ist halt nicht so wie bei Spotify, wo du Geld einwirfst und Artists das Geld kriegen, die du gar nicht gehört hast zum Beispiel am Ende.
Und das sorgt dafür, dass eventuell auch viel, viel mehr Leute überhaupt erstmal bei Spiegel klicken, dadurch sich der Preis senken kann, aber dafür halt viel mehr Leute bezahlen. So wie Apple immer die Preise von, keine Ahnung, Final Cut oder irgendwelchen anderen teuren Tools senkt und dann einfach das mehr Leute benutzen und sie wahrscheinlich am Ende sogar noch mehr Geld einnehmen als vorher.
Also ich finde auf jeden Fall, da ist echt viel, viel, viel Luft in diesem 21. Jahrhundert an Bezahl oder Geld, Monetarisierungsmodellen, außer jetzt, ja, aber Werbung oder, ja, kauft auch eine iPad-App oder ein Spiegel-PDF-Abo oder sowas.
Ich glaube, was die alle nicht verstanden haben ist, Werbung ist scheiße. Niemand will diese Werbung sehen. Früher hatten sie halt eine Möglichkeit, den Leuten die Werbung rein zu drücken. In Magazinen sind sie halt auf Seiten gedrückt, wo auf der Rückseite irgendwas Interessantes ist, also reißt du die Seite nicht raus. Und heutzutage hast du halt die Möglichkeit zu sagen so, hey, alle Werbung weg, ich will es nicht mehr sehen, es interessiert mich nicht, weißt du? Du kannst sie filtern. Und damit ist die Sache halt gegessen, also dieses ganze Modell, ich verkaufe etwas gegen eine Werbung, wo ich jemanden am Stuhl festkette, damit er die Werbung sieht, das funktioniert halt nicht mehr. Und ich glaube, das ist das Eigentliche, was in den Köpfen ankommen muss. Niemand will Werbung. Werbung ist scheiße, außer vielleicht für die Reklamebude, die die Werbung gemacht hat. Die sind dann der Meinung, das ist ganz toll. Aber alle anderen finden es scheiße, finden es nervig. Niemand will, dass die die Favorite TV-Show von einem Werbeblock unterbrochen wird. Niemand will es. Es will keiner, keiner Werbung. Es ist einfach scheiße. Und das verstehen die nicht. Und sobald ich die Möglichkeit habe, den Scheiß zu filtern, dann mache ich das natürlich. Ganz logisch, das ist eine ganz normale Reaktion.
Das genau meine ich mir, dieses alte Business-Modell auf Verkaufseinheiten, physische Medien, irgendwie diese ganze Tröde. Und bei der Musikindustrie, bei den Verlagen, überall ist noch nicht angekommen, es gibt Internet, es ist alles digital, verlustfreie Kopien sind möglich, Content filtern ist möglich. Und ihr müsst euch jetzt was anderes ausdenken. Die Leute wollen, also ich glaube schon, dass Leute auch wie gesagt für solche Sachen bezahlen würden, nur dass eben in den meisten Fällen einfach nicht die Möglichkeit besteht.
Wenn die mit Flatter oder mit was auch immer, mit den Spiegel online, Geld verdienen würden, dann würde ja eigentlich auch die Werbung bei denen teurer werden, weil die können ja sagen, ey, wir verdienen schon genug Geld mit unseren Artikeln. Wenn ihr bei uns Werbung schalten wollt, dann müsst ihr schon richtig viel bezahlen und es muss auch richtig gut sein. Und vielleicht ist die Werbung dann auch besser betrachtbar. Oder sie brauchen die halt einfach nicht mehr und die Werbeleute müssen sich das anders einfallen lassen.
Ja, aber es gibt halt das Freemium, weißt du, die Leute, die halt nicht bezahlen, und die kriegen halt die Werbung und die sagen, ja, ist mir das wert, ich zahl halt.
Aber diese Filtertechnologie, das geht doch weiter. Wenn Google Glass erstmal so gut ist, dass es Fullscreen auf der Brille kann und auch in der Lage ist zu erkennen, wo ist denn da das Werbeplakat?
Und es ist gleich weggeblendet.
Dann wird es weggeblendet. Hey, dann gibt's den nächsten Aufschrei, dann gibt's den, mach doch mal euer Adblock plus auf euerm Glas aus.
Das Google Glass wird eine weiße Fläche sehen und wird Werbung an der Stelle einblenden. So rum wird es bei Google Glass sein.
Ja, aber nicht bei Apple Glass, was weiß ich.
Du kennst doch diese App Wordlands fürs iPhone, wo du so on the fly irgendwie Text anguckst und der übersetzt es dir und so.
Ja, richtig, natürlich. Aber weißt du, sobald technisch die Möglichkeiten da sind, Werbung zu filtern, werden es die Leute tun, weil wir keiner will sie sehen. Das will einfach niemand. Wann hast du das letzte Mal auf den Werbebutton Banner gedrückt, weil du das interessant fandest, weil es dich interessiert hat? Ja, okay, das kommt alle drei Monate mal vor.
Alle Leute machen das den ganzen Tag, weil sie klicken immer auf den Download-Button, um dann erst zu hören, Scheiße, ich hab auf die Werbung geklickt.
Ja, also, ich meine, die Diskussion ist so hirnrissig.
Also du, du jetzt nach all diesen vorgebrachten Argumenten bist du jetzt der Meinung, ja dann, also ich würd eigentlich am besten finden, wenn ich jetzt meinen Adblocker einfach aushalte, das ist das faireste und beste oder was?
Ich mein, du schneidest verborgen.
Das ist ja wohl auch nicht dein Anspruch an das 21. Jahrhundert.
Du hast ja auch einen Adblocker und einen Click to Flash und so weiter, oder?
Ich hab keinen Click to Flash, ich hab einfach keinen Flash.
Auch geil.
Was auch eine Art Flashblocker ist.
Und es ist ja gar nicht so, dass ich jetzt eine grundsätzlich andere Position annehme. Ich versuch halt nur gerade irgendwie mal diese Diskussion zu starten. Ihr sprudelt ja ganz ordentlich in der Hinsicht, ich komm ja gar nicht dazu, um was zu sagen. Ich bin ja ganz auf eurer Seite. Experimentierfreudigkeit vermisse ich da halt eh. Das interessante ist, dass sie jetzt diesen... Ich war überrascht, ich hab halt diesen Banner gesehen, so nach dem Motto so, ah, Spiegel merkt, ich hab einen Adblocker, das haben ja andere Webseiten auch schon mal gemerkt, so bei netzpolitik.org zum Beispiel, war ja im Prinzip genau die gleiche Diskussion vor kurzem. Also, weil die Leute eben, ich glaub, da gibt es irgendwie 60% oder 40% Quote mit Adblockern, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, dass bei der Zielgruppe noch viel krasser ist. Und der Versuch eben, das Projekt netzpolitik.org über die eingeblendete Werbung zu finanzieren, schlägt halt auch fehl. Und da gab es im Prinzip denselben Aufruf. Deswegen finde ich es gerade etwas strange, dass jetzt, wo die anderen das machen, dass dann auf einmal so eine Riesenwelle los dritt. Aber ich kann das nachvollziehen.
Die haben halt mehr Leser.
Ja, klar.
Und sie erreichen halt mit dieser Diskussionsaufforderung Leute, die vorher noch nie wussten, was ein Adblocker ist.
Aber ich hab den Adblocker gar nicht gesehen.
Es ist auch so ein bisschen natürlich auch so, netzpolitik.org sagte ja auch so, hey, naja, okay, da ist Werbung, aber es gibt Schlimmeres. Das ist die Aussage. So, und manche sehen das so auch und manche sehen das halt nicht so. Und ich glaube, es gibt sogar eine gewisse Gruppe, die findet Werbung einfach interessant.
Bestimmt.
Ja, das sind die Werbetreibenden.
Nee, es gibt so Leute, es gibt für alles Leute.
Und das sind, glaub ich, ich befürchte auch so viel, viel, viel mehr, als wir uns auch hoffen. Ich hatte schon mal ein Gespräch mit einer anderen, eher weborientierten Postelle, der einen Namen ich jetzt nicht nennen will. Leider haben sie meinen Vorschlag nicht angenommen, weil ich nämlich auch meinte so, Leute, wenn ihr seht, da ist ein Adblocker, weil das kann man ja quasi feststellen, offensichtlich. Dann blendet doch dann stattdessen Flatter ein. Haben sie nie gemacht? So. Fiel mir aber natürlich gleich wieder ein, wenn, also sozusagen explizit als Deal so. Fände ich natürlich super, wenn sie das machen, weil das würde die Aufmerksamkeit für Flatter in einem Maße steigern, dass das schon fast als Durchbruch wahrscheinlich gelten könnte. Bin mir aber dann trotzdem nicht so sicher, wie das wirklich angenommen würde bzw. inwiefern das eben auch tatsächlich dieselben Einnahmen, also vergleichbare Einnahmen erzeugt, wie Werbung. Weil Werbung ist schon, da geht schon eine Menge Geld.
Aber das ist halt auch nicht nur damit getan, dass du ein Betten dahintust oder hier irgendwie so ein kleines Eckfenster hier mit ja, kauft doch jemand ein Jahr lang werbefreie Spiegel online oder so, sondern das erfordert halt auch, dass die ganz aktiv mit ihren Konsumenten so in so einen Dialog treten und denen halt das auch erklären und sagen, was Sache ist und nicht einfach nur so Hand aufhalten, so dieses so ja, hier irgendwie du kriegst keine Werbung, dann gib uns noch mal so Geld, sondern das ist halt auch jetzt so nach zig Jahren web für alle, die sich so ein bisschen an dieses kostenlose Prinzip gewöhnt haben, da gehört jetzt auch so ein bisschen dieser Dialog und diese Umerziehung so ein bisschen mit dazu. Und das machen halt auch die allerwenigsten dann halt wirklich so ganz offen mal dieses Thema anzusprechen und sagen so, Jungs, pass mal auf das kostet alles Geld. Das Geld brauchen wir für dies und das und jenes und wenn du keine Werbung sehen willst, dann wäre es halt schon ganz gut, wenn du hier und so mal bezahlen würdest. Und das bei Netzpolitik fand ich zum Beispiel echt gut gemacht, so wie sie da auch jetzt ihren Spendenaufruf und so diese Seite da gemacht haben und aufgeschüsselt haben, wofür eigentlich das Geld so drauf geht. Und das war halt so ein schöner, ja so ein, wie gesagt, so ein Dialog mit dem Leser im Prinzip, der dann mal so nicht nur einfach hier mal Geld, sondern...
Ja gut, aber der Leser ist dann natürlich auch wirklich Community und das ist natürlich jetzt, das kann man bei Spiegel Online jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarten.
Klar, aber ich mein gut, die haben trotzdem eine extrem krasse Reichweite und wenn die halt statt irgendwie nur so, ach, mach doch mal den Adblocker aus, halt genauso für andere Bezahloptionen mal irgendwie ein bisschen werben und irgendwie sagen wieso und warum das jetzt eigentlich ganz gut wäre, kann das schon meiner Meinung nach auch einen ganz guten Effekt haben. Nicht nur für Spiegel online, sondern auch für alles andere dann, aber ich finde halt diese Adblocker-Debatte, das ist so...
Sie ist halt schon ganz schön auf.
Das ist halt so tief geschossen, dass man eigentlich irgendwie...
Ich finde sie sinnlos, weil die Leute werden Adblocker benutzen und wenn die Seiten kreativer sind im Umgang damit, wie sie einem Werbung zeigen, dann werden die Adblocker kreativer im Umgang damit, wie man sie wieder blockt. Und an der Stelle kommt man nicht weiter. Und jetzt zu sagen, mi mi mi, bitte schaltet euren Adblocker aus, ist halt einfach überhaupt nicht zielführend. Das ist bestenfalls lächerlich. Weißt du, das ist so... Ja, da kann man dann auch irgendwie nicht diskutieren, weil...
Geht nicht.
Und ob Flatternu das, die Lösung des Problems ist, ich bezweifle es ja so ein bisschen.
Ja, ne, wie gesagt, es gibt ja da... Es gibt echt in diesem Internet verschiedenste Möglichkeiten, Geld einzusammeln.
Ja, es gibt jetzt hier auch was, weiß ich, hier gibt es auch dieses faible.org, die irgendwie hier mit Fairtrade für Adblocker irgendwie daherkommt, wo du dann irgendwie Geld freiwillig zahlst, ja, dafür, dass du einen Adblocker verwendest. Wobei mir das Verteilungsmodell an der Stelle etwas unklar ist.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja auch eine schöne Idee durchaus, aber...
Alles nicht angezeigt, da muss man dann so ein bisschen was bezahlen oder was? Ja, dann blenden sie noch mehr Schrott ein, damit sie noch mehr Kohle kriegen.
Ich glaube, dass die ganze Diskussion insofern auch überzogen ist, dass jemand einen Adblocker halt dann installiert, also soweit geht, einen Adblocker zu installieren, wenn er die Werbung ab einem bestimmten Punkt unerträglich findet.
Ja gut, aber das Problem ist ja, dass du die Werbung unerträglich findest auf bestimmten Seiten, den Adblocker installierst und es dann auch auf Seiten ausblendest, wo es vielleicht gar nicht so unerträglich gewesen wäre. Also du triffst quasi alle, dadurch, dass du manche Scheiße findest. Wobei ich jetzt bei Spiegel online, ehrlich gesagt, seitdem sie da diese blöden Rahmen drumherum, also das war so auch so der Tag, wo ich so mental ausgeklinkt bin. Also das war für mich eigentlich der Anreiz, dann auch zu sagen, ich kann das nicht mehr, ist das Fenster zu breit.
Also ich fand es jetzt interessant, die ganzen Seiten, die genannt wurden, außer Netzpolitik. Org, die haben hier irgendwie überhaupt keinen Flash, deswegen sehe ich auch alle Werbung. Aber jetzt so diese kommerziellen Spiegel, Süddeutsche, FI Online, Zeitz. Die benutzen echt immer noch alle Flash und keine Ads mehr, weißt du? Also das ist so, das ist halt auch so unglaublich selbst in den Fuß geschossen. Warum sollte man für ein Ad Flash benutzen? Damit sie es bewegt und zuckelt.
Ja, das ist mir auch richtig.
Und dann setze ich natürlich einen Ad-Blocker ein.
Das ist so...
Also wir fordern neue Ideen und Konzepte und sind für den unangeschränkten Einsatz von Ad-Blockern im Landesinneren, im Inland. Und Ausland.
Ich hab mal ausgetestet, man kann ja relativ, also ich verwende ja Ad-Block, nicht Ad-Block Plus. Da geht es relativ einfach, diese Exclusion einzuschalten.
Achso, ich bin uns auch ein Block, ja. Aber ich weigere mich einfach, die Services mit Werbung zu bezahlen, ehrlich. Das hab ich keinen Bock drauf. Und es gibt Leute, die die Werbung abzutreten, für die können sie die gerne einblenden. Für alle anderen sollen sie sich bitte irgendwas anderes ausdenken lassen, wie sie mein Geld einsammeln können.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wir schneiden ja hier auch keine Werbung dazwischen. Warum? Weil wir die Leute nicht nerven wollen. Und weil, wenn wir das machen würden, dann würde es doch irgendwie nur einen halben Tag dauern, dann hätte jemand sämtliche Folgen die Werbung rausgeschnitten und veröffentlicht.
Ja, wenn wir jetzt hier nach dem Five by Five oder Levo Laporte Modell anfangen würden, Werbung reinzuschneiden, dann würde sie schon die Hörer auch erreichen, weil diese rausgeschnittenen Versionen jetzt nicht so genau so populieren wie das, was in den Feed kommt.
Aber trotzdem würden wir die Leute nerven.
Natürlich würden wir die Leute nerven.
Extrem.
Natürlich würden wir die Leute nerven. Die Frage für diese Leute in den großen Verlagen ist natürlich eine ganz andere. Du musst aber mal sehen, das sind die jetzt gewohnt seit anno dunnemals. Seit es Zeitungen gibt, finanzieren sie sich zu einem großen Teil und teilweise fast ausschließlich von Werbung.
Das ist uns ja allen klar.
Ich würde sogar fast sagen, es gibt auch teilweise nützliche Werbung. Ich frage mich immer so, was wäre, wenn die Zeitung gar keine Werbung mehr enthalten würde? Würden die Leute sie noch also genauso nützlich ansehen? Kann man auch noch mal diskutieren. Aber nicht jetzt. Nicht jetzt, bitte. Genau. Ich meine auch so eine CT. Eine CT kaufst du auch wegen der Werbung?
Ich kaufe keine CT.
Und ich schon gar nicht wegen der Werbung.
Aber ernsthaft, das meine ich jetzt wirklich, weil du da einfach immer einen Überblick hast über Angebote, die ganze PC-Markt, tralala, Reckkram.
Ich komm so prima aus, ohne so Webmasse.
Ja, du kommst ohne aus, aber es gibt definitiv Leute, die das so sehen würden.
Ich kauf die CT immer wegen dem Delphi-Programmierkurs.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass die mit Werbung bei 5x5 und so weiter natürlich viel, viel, viel mehr Geld machen, als mit so einem freiwilligen Bezahlmodell, wie das jetzt hier gefahren wird. Also Meter, Ebene, Einnahmen über Fletter im Vergleich zu dem, was man mit derselben Audience mit Werbung erzeugen könnte, ist wahrscheinlich ein Bruchteil.
Aber sind deine Höherzahlen überhaupt vergleichbar?
Ja, vergleichbar sind sie ja. Aber nicht die gleichen.
Also wie viel Unterschied ist denn zum Beispiel zwischen diesen ganzen 5x5 und hast du nicht gesehen amerikanischen?
Ich kenne jetzt deren Zahlen nicht, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die signifikante 6-stellige Abrufzahlen haben.
Ja, wenn du signifikant 6-stellige Abrufzahlen hättest, wären deine Flatte-Einnahme und deine Failed-Link-Einnahme wahrscheinlich auch signifikanter. Also das ist jetzt so...
Ich stelle nur die These auf, dass du mit Werbung letztlich immer mehr Geld erzeugen kannst. Und das ist auch die Frage, die dir jetzt die Zeitung quält, weil die sozusagen gewohnt sind, einen gewissen Umsatz pro Views zu erzeugen, den sie so bei den freiwilligen Modellen so erstmal nicht sehen. Das kann nicht funktionieren.
Zum Beispiel bei den Podcasts. Was wir machen und was jetzt zum Beispiel auch hier bei dem 300-Herz-Podcast gemacht haben, wir erwähnen ja tausende Produkte, zum Beispiel. Und wir machen da jetzt Thomas Failed-Links rein. Ja, echt viele.
Da müssen wir aber noch ein bisschen nachliefern.
In den Show-Notes sind da bei uns schon echt viele drin. Und jetzt habe ich halt auch schon geguckt und es haben tatsächlich auch schon einige Leute über diese Failed-Links da Geld ausgegeben. Das ist alles, also wir haben ja ganz wenige Hörer sozusagen im Vergleich zur Mete eben schon gar nicht irgendwas.
Ja, aber das ist auch sehr gefährlich.
Aber das ist halt, das ist ja auch eine Form von Werbung. Das ist aber irgendwie Sachen, wo du irgendwie nicht irgendwie Leuten reinquatschst, ja du musst jetzt irgendwie den pinken Kinderwagen kaufen, sondern hier sind irgendwie Sachen, die wir selber benutzen, die wir cool finden und das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so eine nervige Werbung. Ja, hier muss der Hausküchen Fachgeschäft und jetzt nicht die Störwerbung stören und diesen ganzen Scheiß halt, weißt du, sondern... Also bei Podcasts funktioniert das ja mit zum Beispiel diesen Failed-Links und diesem Flatter halt alles sowieso schon viel besser und wenn du jetzt irgendwie 6 Millionen, was auch immer, Hörer hättest, dann hättest du auch dementsprechend mehr irgendwie Leute, die auf die Failed-Links klicken, die irgendwie, was auch immer.
Stell dir vor, die 6 Millionen Hörer kaufen alle ein Fireface.
Und die Zeitung...
Lass uns mal was dazu sagen. Da hast du natürlich Recht, dass das irgendwie mit skaliert. Meine These war ja auch nur im selben Skalierungsbereich. Ist es vermutlich so, dass du, weil ich hab da auch nicht viel Erfahrung mit, aber das ist so meine Wahrnehmung der Sache, ja. Wenn du dich für Werbung entscheidest, pro Target-Kopf sozusagen, dass du damit mehr Geld machen kannst, als wenn du dich für freiwillige Zahlungen pro Koffer hast, dass das hoch skaliert und dass es ausreichen kann und glücklich machen kann. Klar, natürlich. Ich weiß ja auch, warum ich den Weg und nicht den anderen gehe. Nur, das ist halt die Denke, auf die wir jetzt da treffen, weil die sich einfach über hundert Jahre und mehr geformt hat und in dem Kontext muss man da diskutieren. Dein Beispiel mit den Affiliate-Links ist insofern ganz interessant, als dass du natürlich dann auch wieder ein anderes Problem hast, nämlich, dass du so ein zunehmenden Maße verlockt sein kannst, dann doch über Sachen zu reden.
Du, bei diesem 300-Hertz-Podcast, wir reden über Audio-Gadgets und wir reden über alles und wir verlinken alles.
Ja, aber wenn du erst mal das enorme Potenzial entdeckt hast, dann findest du Sachengute, von denen hast du nicht den Traum gedacht, dass du mit mir später mal drüber redest, ja?
Aber das hängt dann auch von deiner persönlichen, moralisch-ethischen Integrität ab, ob das so ist oder nicht, und dann kriegst du auch das entsprechende Publikum dazu.
Die Gefahr bei Affiliate ist an der Stelle, dass du halt schnell selber anfängst, so eine Werbetafel zu werden.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wenn du...
Es kann halt passieren.
Es kann passieren, es gibt bestimmt schwache Seelen da draußen in diesem Land, die dieser Versuchung verfallen. Ich zähle mich nicht dazu, ich würde dich auch nicht dazu zählen. Und wie gesagt, wenn du das halt tust, dann kriegst du halt auch das Publikum, was du verdient hast.
Aber das Ding ist halt, ab wann denken die Leute, es wäre so, obwohl es vielleicht von deiner Seite aus gar nicht so ist. Das ist ja auch so eine Diskussion. Ich glaube, wenn du mit Holgi hattest, das vor uns Zeiten auch schon früher.
Auf jeden Fall. Die denken, bevor du ein richtiges Arschloch bist, wirst du schon für eins gehalten.
Also ich sag ja nur, es gibt da schon echt viel Luft. Und ich sage ja auch explizit, 21. Jahrhundert, weil ich ja auch weiß, wie es vorher alles war und dass die sich da so reingefahren haben. Aber ich fordere jetzt einfach mal Zukunft.
Ja, nicht nur irgendjemand muss die Zukunft bezahlen. Und da ist natürlich auch das Dilemma. Also auf der anderen Seite sehe ich das natürlich schon ein, dass jemand, der es gewohnt ist, ganz normal seine Werbekunden zu akquirieren und dann sein, wie auch immer geartetes, journalistisches Produkt mit diesem Werbezeug zu füllen, dass der in dieser denke, natürlich ist es, ich produziere nicht nur den redaktionellen Inhalt, sondern ich produziere auch den Werbeinhalt und all das spielt irgendwie zusammen und dass davon runterkommen extrem schwierig ist. Also ich könnte mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass ich so ein Spiegel online von heute auf morgen ohne Werbung finanzieren ließe. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist ja Spiegel online auch nur Abfallprodukt der Print-Publikation, aber ehrlich gesagt, so wirkt es nicht mehr auf mich.
Nicht mehr, glaube ich.
Ich weiß nicht, aber man muss trotzdem irgendwie trotzdem die normative Kraft des Faktischen akzeptieren. Da draußen sind Werbeblocker und sie werden eingesetzt.
Und da gibt es auch Leute, die Geld ausgeben würden, egal ob es jetzt groß oder klein Maßstab ist, wie auch immer. Sie sollen es mal ausprobieren.
Gut, ich denke wir haben das Thema jetzt ausführlich. Wir haben uns schon tot umgefallen seit der Müdigkeit. Vorhin haben wir das jetzt doch ganz epische Breite gemacht. Naja, also wenn ihr hier die Werbefreiheit und eingeschränkte Sponsorenneigung uns weiterzuschätzen wisst, wisst ihr ja, was zu tun ist. Wir liegen euch damit auf jeden Fall nicht in den Ohren.
Klicken sie jetzt den Flatter-Button neben ihrer Landesflagge an. Wenn sie jetzt auf diesen Flatter-Button klicken, kriegen sie noch einen, äh, wer was auch immer, Pixel, tanzenden Pixel noch dazu.
Leute, wir sagen Tschüss oder?
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.